position where computers will always say
white has an advantage but Magnus with
his team around him he would have
studied intricacies in this type of
position and he will realize that
actually there's no immediate
breakthrough for why the maneuvering
will continue for a long time I will
mention magnus's opponent tests a
hakkian maybe he's not too familiar to
our audience but very strong Armenian
Grandmaster part of the Armenian
national team I played him actually in
the Olympiad in the summer and his
opening preparation is phenomenal he
prepared a line I think I played once or
twice in my career he prepared against
it uh 25 moves deep and he found a way
to force a draw with black actually I
was on the ropes in that game and I
think these two played each other last
year as well in the world record Blitz
championship and Tessa hacking had
Magnus on the ropes there so that's not
going to be an easy ride for the
favorite of the tournament
definitely not Queen effort and Rook H7
by Marcus Carlson a clear idea of
defending this Pawn on F7 so that he's
able to Castle long but the Rook doesn't
really make a great impression on H7
then again Magnus is basically saying
well
um I'm trying to close the position so
as long as there's no way for you to
exploit this immediately what's the big
deal
I find it hard to believe but
yeah I'm I can see your face Laura so I
can see that you're not impressed At All
by Black's play it does look very
superficial as you mentioned and that
Rook long term on H7 it's gonna be stuck
there I mean it could be stuck there for
the next 40 50 moves yes Magnus is okay
on the other parts of the board but
it's all about the king side long term
and yeah I think he will be struggling
um unless we see sahakyan maybe lash out
I don't think white needs to rush white
can be patient maybe improve his light
squared bishop and prove his Rook on H1
get the king to safety
yeah looking good for white in this game
yeah I mean I would take quite all day
here just arguing with more than enough
time 13 minutes on the clock he has
absolutely no need to rush here
whatsoever he can just think of what
kind of plan so let's discuss what kind
of plan
uh uh white and black would be looking
to employ here of course the big problem
for white at the moments what to do with
this kingside bishop hasn't found a way
into the game
so do you try and maneuver it out via G3
for example if I play a move like G3
here
I'm not really sure where I want to put
this bishop here do I just want to put
it on G2
but now that we have our answer
Knight H2 and I love the move
yeah I mean it crossed my mind Knight H2
but it does feel a bit slow as I
mentioned maybe there's uh the luxury of
time here for white because the center
is blocked I guess the reason you like
that move Lawrence is because the
knight's coming to G4 potentially F6
afterwards
I guess it could be putting some
pressure on the H6 Pawn as well
yeah it's also cleared the path for the
F Pawn you mentioned this kind of plan
at some point of playing H5 and later
and pushing the white Pawn to F4
um yes the white Queen's in the way of
it right now but okay after Magnus
castles what else was he gonna do
um I'm expecting to see the move Knight
G4 almost instantly
just you've got to be consistent with
the plan right after knight uh G4 white
also has the idea of Rook H3 to F3
amping up the pressure on F7
yeah it's still hard to imagine black
doing anything on the other flank do you
see anything for black we talked about
white plans now they're not coming to G4
maybe the light Square Bishop coming out
as well via E2 now
yeah and that's the problem I don't
black sometimes can you know move this
Knight and take on A4
he self pins there and he would have to
follow it up with B5 in order to hold
the bishop but that always is it's
always awkward for black you can never
really readjust your pieces so black is
kind of in a weird position because
his pieces feel a little bit offside to
me and yeah so Knight G4 has been played
so I guess the CR and and the other
thing is that of course tempting move
here might be to a lot of players to
play the move H5
but I think this gives white a number of
options firstly you can actually just go
back re-route the Knight and now you've
got a beautiful outpost on G5 secondly
the move Knight F6 isn't actually that
silly either because after it takes you
can
maybe contemplating the pawn you might
run into some E5 stuff though I've just
got to be just a nice little idea here
for black is that E5 might work and
after takes you can take we can't take
back because of the pin down the E file
yeah so one thing sorry I love that
variation Lawrence but one thing uh a
student of mine actually told me he was
like 10 years old I think at the time he
said if you can get the break E5 is
black in the French defense
it's great basically you're gonna win as
black if you can manage to break out and
free your light Square Bishop yeah um so
you're right Knight F6 tempting but
maybe not in this exact position
precisely
um that being said if you do go back to
H2 black has kind of found a way also to
secure
uh an outpost from cell phone F5 but
okay Rook f8 played by Magnus Carlson
um
again a kind of
trying to not commit too much here
yeah but what is the idea I mean like
you said not commit too much but you've
got two Rooks which are very powerful
pieces defending just the F7 Pawn
it's the idea to break out with F6 at
some point
one
I think one of his ideas is actually to
move this queen back to the ape
uh to to bring the queen back into
action and then maybe play a move like
F6 or F5
uh
that looks logical to me
yeah and that begs the question why it
has maybe two moves before black
fulfills the plan uh kind of makes that
break out of pushing F6 how can white
prevent that is Rook H3 to F3 still on
the cards for example just to clamp down
control the F6 Square
um could white push H5 yeah there's
plenty of questions do you jump in with
the Knight to F6 just to block up blacks
Rooks yeah I've been wondering something
like takes tapes and then a move like
Queen d8
um
are we do you want to worry about
well I mean even let's say like this I'm
just curious
how this looks maybe G4 here it's just I
don't know
yeah and again black and block put the
Knight on F5
maybe yeah
something like this
but I've got G4
I still were both biased here right we
both we're both 184 players we want the
white Pieces by Nature yes
maybe it's not
so bad for Magnus and it's the sort of
position where he manages to always kind
of wriggle and squirm it okay Bishop E2
again to start again clearly in this
game is just not committing right to any
big decisions just yet he's saying
you know I want to
keep my options open
see what Magnus wants to do I fully
expect to move Queen d8 here
um that would be the only move to make
sense of uh magnus's yeah previous ideas
right
uh his previous maneuvers
and uh yeah I mean Tessa haki and I'm
just so impressed by the fact that he's
keeping Pace on the clock a lot of
players when Magnus plays this
provocatively this kind of strangely in
the opening a lot of players earn their
time on the clock and get punished later
um so yeah extremely impressive I've got
to say bye tasaki and Bishop
solid move doesn't change the nature
doesn't really uh pose too many
questions but he's playing quickly and
that's all he needs to do I'm expecting
queen d8 as you say and uh ah
maybe Rook H3 maybe another
non-committal move maybe what just keeps
the king uh nice and safely tucked away
on F1 G1 at some point
Still Loving White's position I've got
to say we could see a big upset in this
uh first round potentially
yeah and it wouldn't I think be the
first time that Magnus has had a bad
start to these tournaments he always
manages to stick around right he's
always going to be there at the end at
least
um
but you know when I first saw the
pairing I I wasn't excited for Magnus
because
you know as you said he's so well
prepared
younger guy
Magnus is black I was kind of curious
how he was going to play this game
and and we see it okay Queen V8 on the
board yeah
and
well
okay so now the question is what to do
as white
[Music]
um
yeah I mean my first instinct in any
position is always uh to ask what would
happen if I do nothing so for example if
white plays a non-committal move like
Rook well actually Rook H3 is
potentially not the best square if black
does play F6 because it is on the same
diagonal as Black's light squared Bishop
but uh Justin as an example if white
does nothing the breakout potentially
now with
I mean maybe even E5 but uh F6 Knight
takes F6 just swapping pieces off maybe
that's uh Black's main idea
um the then if uh if the opponent does
have a threat how do we stop it that's
the next question and Knight F6 is a bit
tempting to me at least uh I don't know
I just feel like that end game that you
showed earlier Lawrence with the Queens
coming off feels favorable for white and
less risk
I'm gonna put that on the board I've
also I'll put that on the board in a
second I've also seen another idea let's
say white plays a again a non-committal
move a move like King F1 let's say which
he's not gonna play but maybe the movie
F5 also exists and the point is that on
Knight E3 black has got a beautiful
Concept in the form of G5
which is
um a lovely idea the point being that
black manages to uh get out of the pin
because the queen is attacked and the
Ruckus attack there's a cute little idea
uh that's available in this position
um that's not gonna happen of course but
that that is an idea that is on the
cards what David was saying is that the
move Knight F6 here takes and now takes
is also available because even with the
pawn on F6 it's very interesting
because the pawn on F6 can actually be a
very useful wedge uh a bit later on
and now if black plays E5
which looks
kind of reasonable maybe why just says
okay so what takes takes
not even 53 maybe it should be three
yeah you can even yeah cheekily threaten
this Pawn
put the white Pawn on A5 push F3 G4
eventually it's still that rook in H7
I'm looking at it and I'm thinking what
are you doing mate what's that Rook
doing how are you going to get out it's
going to take five or six moves so black
and in the meantime work will have built
up
yeah this looks horrible for black uh
but uh okay Tessa hacking didn't go for
this it looks like he shuffled his Queen
into G3 instead
um a bit mysterious but getting out of
the uh out of the vision of the f8 room
getting ready maybe to meet F5 uh the
idea you suggested either by taking on
passant or just retreating the White
Knight
interesting idea Again by Tessa haki and
just he's so patient he's so calm and uh
that could be disconcerting for Magnus
right now
yeah just not committing just every move
is just asking Magnus well if you want
to make the first serious commitment you
can but breaking news let's go to
another pairing when I first saw it I
mention it in the introduction to say I
wasn't excited for one of the big
favorites that is Hikaru Nakamura
playing Black against Amin Tabata by and
we have this position uh David the bar
is uh fully up the other end of the
board Stone dead lost for Hikaru
Nakamura in round one
wow I mean this is shocking stuff G6
just played hang on why can't I just
take that Bishop takes G6 you ask a very
good question Lawrence I was trying to
figure it out myself it looks like white
can win the pawn back white had
sacrificed a pawn but you can win the
pawn back with interest Black's King is
going to be open if you capture on G6 uh
we should mention if you if black takes
back that Bishop then uh everything
drops Rook takes E6 followed by Rook
takes G6 Rook takes D5 everything
um it's hikaru's idea to go Bishop G5
maybe in this position that white knight
looks fantastic he needs to get rid of
that piece somehow but but now we can at
least take on E6 right because we're
attacking The Rook yeah you have to take
back and I can even chop another Pawn
because I'm I'm threatening mate here
this is a catastrophe
disaster look at his body language as
well you can okay now he looks up but he
had his head in his hands that's not uh
kind of uh that's not how we are used to
seeing Hikaru especially in let's rapid
chess this looks deadly I think in the
current position as well uh if we go
back Bishop takes G6 is just one option
you can also consider for example taking
on E6 and then Queen E3 you can consider
Rook takes these six sacrifices uh
plenty of uh maybe this is kind of a
less ambitious approach but you will win
at least one or two pawns back
um yeah well okay five has happened yeah
yeah and now it's about he is just gonna
take on E6 and take on B7 and he's gonna
have
what's the pawn count there uh
uh he's only gonna be one Pawn up
but with an attack and actually it's
impossible to stop you have to go Bishop
E7 here
yeah yeah right back now
does this exist
wow it's not necessary no it's not it's
it's it's oh no I'm dropping the bishop
Edie and I I've landed my Bishop you see
uh yeah that doesn't quite work okay we
don't we don't need to be overly flashy
here you're sharp for such an early hour
in the morning though I'm impressed
okay as you say there's options
um what's a clean way I mean for
instance
Bishop f for example you could
wow
Bishop F5 Lawrence
just over overloading Black's pieces I
guess there you have to calculate moves
such as Rook to V8 yeah
so if you take with the Rook I take your
Rook if you take with the pawn it's
clear that in the worst case scenario
take care and it's losing so you would
have to go rook 8b8 and now I was
wondering if I take on E6 take and just
move the queen
is this ridiculous
it's not ridiculous at all I love how
you put the queen on A7 defending F2
yeah but
you have got Rook A8 and then maybe uh
you know it might not be enough
as if on K8 what do I do
apparently it's when oh I've got Queen
takes E7 what am I doing
excuse me maybe even last move I can
just do it here what am I what am I yeah
but actually it's probably better
because then no there's no Rook takes B2
maybe this is good enough to win
wow and this requires some calculation I
mean this is not easy to see Bishop F5
just visually is maybe the most
difficult move in this variation
but he has time he has 11 minutes uh
here to battle by yeah very strong
Iranian player 21 years old wow big
shock on the cards
huge shock on the cards
um of course everybody watching do not
fear we will look at the women's section
as well we're just uh concentrating on
these two amazing games to start with
because two of the big favorites
potentially already in trouble just
breezing through the women's uh games
out the corner of my eye uh no big
surprises thus far so looks like round
one there is gonna pretty much uh go to
plan for a lot of these top players but
not in the open section the Magnus game
is also completely heating up but I
think we should stay here David because
tabatavite is on the verge of causing a
huge upset and you know a loss is
massive already this early because
you know unlike the blitz tournament the
rapid Championship is only 15 rounds
there's all kinds of tie breaks that go
against you if you lose early so this is
this will be a huge loss if Tabata by
can just keep his nerve massive leader
on the clock as well so you know it's
not going to be that complicated for him
to calculate 1966 Queen's xb7
and
go from there this should be a piece of
cake
exactly especially with 10 minutes on
the clock and
um Nakamura I mean for me this is an
even bigger shock because he's been in
such good form recently he won of course
the speed Chess Championship he's been
winning pretty much every title Tuesday
he plays in and to be in this much
trouble this soon it's uh it's
incredible I mean it's about to buy
we've got to give him credit for the
opening preparation
um I must admit I haven't seen the first
few moves of this game but just the fact
he had so much time on his clock
Nakamura on the back foot so early this
feels like nakamura's run into
uh yeah run into a real bomb on uh on
the board it's just
something this sometimes this stuff
happens you can't avoid it better get it
out early like you say it's a long
tournament 13 Rounds but uh it's not a
great start to his aspirations for a
world title another world title and 1966
the more I look at it as you say
Lawrence the more killer it appears I
think you'll find it it's the first move
you look at a simple capture but it's
that Bishop F5 move three moves into
that variation maybe we can look at it
one more time just to see whether one
has any defensive resources
Knight takes Queen takes B7 very natural
it's threatening mate
and you have to play Bishop E7 because
if you go Queen E7 then I I can just
take take and take and now yeah you
might have Bishop C5 but I can go rookie
two worst case scenario
and there's just no way the top player
survives here two pawns down should be
relatively easy conversion
so you have to try Bishop E7 and now
really the move I mean I'll be honest
with you this is the move I I'm not
using assistance here this is the move
that
um screamed out to me because I'm
looking at the file I'm looking at the
E6 Pawn
um I can see out the corner mind that
you know some kind of counter play might
be there so I know I have to act quickly
Bishop F5 looks completely logical to me
yeah I mean I I missed this move uh I
must say but it is no surprise that
something's in the air I I mean your
instincts their Spidey sensors are
telling you that Black's position is uh
falling apart especially with such an
open King on the light squares uh so
Bishop F5 is the killer touch will he
find it I think that's the big question
he has taken on E6 so if he just needs
to capture on B7 he's about to move
again to batter by
um this bishop F5 move I think it might
be one of the moves of the tournament
even at this early stage uh if he does
find it I just can't see anything for
black you can't defend E6 as as we
mentioned if he takes F5 here
number 27 drops if Rook takes F5 The
Rook on A8 drops
I mean this is just game over you you
can't
I mean you just can't play anything I
just don't see how black can even fight
on
yeah what a move but no it doesn't play
it it doesn't like that's actually
slightly surprised me H4
wow
yeah horses
it's the idea just Queen E3 swing across
attack a couple of Pawns maybe he wants
an end game two points up like we showed
earlier
that could be the point how do you
defend this
also looks terrible to defend
yeah just clicking G7 and battle on in
one of those end games but yeah like you
say it's uh not fun
this is horrible this is just horrible
this is miserable to defend
D5 is almost certainly going to be lost
yeah he didn't find the Tactical blow
but uh this looks good enough triple six
uh maybe just two H5 each five yeah
and if you take I take on D5
and you can't take because now your your
king is even in trouble
this looks like
oh yeah whatever something like this is
is gonna be mate
um
also looks hopeless slightly surprising
because I think Bishop F5 is very
findable but let's see H4 Bishop B7 on
the board
and let's see now if Tabata bite follows
through
with his move
I mean what else is he gonna do here
Queen E3 is just begging to be played
yeah we could go Bishop B he could go
Bishop B1 if he just wanted to play
Super kind of
um direct also
uh come in this way
Rook F6 maybe but not Queen E3 has been
played
and hikaru's got no choice except to go
into the ending
yeah Queen E3 just looks very powerful I
mean H6 you can't allow to fall so you
pretty much have to play King G7 I feel
yes and from there it's all very very
logical it's very consistent you just
take a pawn you keep playing against
that black king keep going on the attack
maybe he'll defend them with the damage
yeah
and now this would be classic Hikaru yes
just defending one Pawn down and holding
somehow
yeah I mean to battle I will be
disgusted if he doesn't win this though
because really the
the uh the chances there but you can see
the Swindle opportunities in an ending
like this this is not
Hikaru has saved worse positions in this
believe it or not this is true he's safe
worse than this against me many many
times many times he always seems to find
a way
yes yeah on King G7 on the board
foreign
technique is actually really really
strong
um in the Grand Prix series
um just from last year he won some
really nice end games I think he even
beat Wesley so
um in an end game so
um I do see some play some people in the
chat saying Hikaru defends such
positions for breakfast which is right
but uh this one is going to be an uphill
struggle
and uh Rook F6 meanwhile oh no not Rook
F6 Bishop six
he's clinging on for dear life that
variation you showed is on the board
yeah and Rook FDA also
on the board maybe you don't have to
move the B Pawn because Bishop takes B2
runs into cookie seven checks so maybe
you can be a bit more clever here
um
what about your move for D3 ah and he
just played it yeah Rook D3 beautiful
and now Rook F3 is a massive threat
uh
Rook C8 Hikaru Hikaru ignores the threat
now it looks like Rook F3 is
surely a killer wreck of fate
Rook of three Rook f8 Rook D6 there
maybe
oh and that's nice and if Rook CDA Rook
F takes F6 that's a really important
line so Rook F3 Rook f8 now if you go
here point is this runs into the love oh
the lovely yeah this works Rook F takes
F6 and the Rooks are overloaded
okay so what a square of Rooks there you
nearly never see that pattern uh really
yes tactic geometry
yeah and Rook D6 D4 Rook D7 check
um
if you try and hold on
worst case scenario
you take this Pawn
best case scenario that might be made I
don't know exactly how maybe some move
like
how to do this uh Brook F5 or something
choosing from 10 very strong moves here
yeah nice luxury to have maybe Rook C7
is the only defense just to cover the
seventh rank try and take on B2
I think that's right yes
oops Rook season
um
yeah and now the questions
hmm
what's the question is
still not easy still still requires a
bit of a touch here
yeah but I mean just put the point on B3
just Advance the white king black is
totally frozen uh in this position like
has to put the pawn on D4 but the full
on D4 is not going anywhere it's stuck
sooner or later this FNG pawns will make
the difference
okay and now you maybe just swap a pair
of rocks rookie six
um
something like this
um
you're right though Hikaru has saved
positions similar or Worse to this one
but this is really bad right because the
d-pawn is under control the bishop on G6
is cemented uh the white king can just
come floating in I find it very and and
he's got the advantage on time I find it
very oh we have had some action so hold
on a second so it went Rook F3
Rook D6 he did take on B2 allowing the
track King h8 and this is the position
now you can even go
can you go Rook B3 Bishop D4 is what
your car is counting on possibly
yeah I don't know if there's a Checkmate
because Black's King can hide on h8 G8
right I guess there's various ways to
try and keep things simple I mean you
can
for example take on f8 and take on
taking V7 I was going to say but
actually that's not so simple sure yeah
maybe there's ways you know I was going
to say at some point you come round
Maybe
take the H6 Pawn but black is hitting F2
in many variations
um yeah this one you can still play Rook
A7 here but
yeah
Bishop C5 yeah
kind of surviving
yeah and this kind of ending is never
winning forward
if you don't want to risk it no you
would have to go passive and I actually
think Hikaru holds this position here
mm-hmm
so maybe maybe you'll be three move
Lawrence
foreign
potentially
but then Rook takes just two
now
nuts because Roxy one is coming and this
is just one check because G7 is covered
oh no wait we can
play room two seven right
maybe with G7 we just go King f8
laughs
wow wow and white skin is the one that's
toast
that's amazing
wow and you can just feel like to battle
is getting nervous now can't you
yeah wow Hikaru how does he do it how
does he pass these difficult questions
to his opponent I have no idea
I mean he's still lost he's still I mean
barely surviving but somehow it's not
easy for white anymore
is there a way of
okay he'd swaps one pair of Rooks but
he's going for this variation we
discussed will Hikaru survive Bishop
takes A3
about to be played he's gonna do this
yeah I'm I'm not in love with this
even Bishop D4 immediately exists right
and the bar is just shot right down
mm-hmm
I'm sure you're right maybe bishop D4
5 maybe white plays F4
uh Bishop takes A3 F4 is an interesting
idea
no it's not letting me okay
Bishop A3 F4
even this I'm not convinced
is winning
but you're right
you're absolutely right he did take on
E3 okay
and are we gonna get this boring boric
A7 Bishop C5 Rook A2 I don't see Karu
losing this almost ever to be fair
yeah I think anyone else in the world
other than maybe Magnus and Hikaru you
would think that white is winning but uh
those two you would back to save this
end game
and okay we've got it on the board wait
to point up but black is going to get
active soon the king can start coming
the black king
yeah it's still gonna be an uphill
struggle we've got to say objectively
white is still uh the only one who can
win
eventually
maybe what we can do is we can go back
to the Magnus game because this is going
to be a bit of a grind now it's just a
case of is Tabata by gonna find
something here or not let's go back to
playing this game because that is
absolutely Wild
Rook F2 on the board
well mag this has got a draw in hand if
he wants oh no he doesn't quite
I was thinking well it's a complete can
you go Rook H2 check no he goes Queen B1
threatening mate
on H1
he wants much more than the drawer
Magnus yeah I don't think he would ever
even consider trying to bail out here
but maybe at the minimum you could give
a check
and take on E5 exactly
exactly
um you get rid of one Pawn what's the
count blacks one Pawn up yeah because
White's Queen is hanging
that's what he will do as well that is
classic Magnus he'll see that's a
risk-free
way of playing
yeah and the black seaport as well is
it's going to decide the game later and
why not play it safe
don't think you should get carried away
with any Rook H2 ideas Queen E4 checks
on the on the radar as well maybe but
your move Queen B2 looks the most
accurate and the most simple also look
at the clocks Tessa haki are down at 13
seconds I was praising his clock
handling earlier but it's changed
and yeah he's just too too strong when
things get messy Magnus he's good at
messes he's good at end game grinds
he's a full package and he's gonna get a
win as black that could be huge
confidence boost as well if he sees his
main rival Hikaru slip up
he does go for Queen E4 check
interesting
same idea though I think yeah you're
right yeah
we should have three queens 85
but now it's slightly different so yeah
exactly because now the D5 Pawn is
protected so I can take on G6
so yeah
your move order was more accurate it
feels like still Black's doing well but
um yeah the difference was that now
White's d-pawn is protected right uh
exactly they allow into an end game
yeah there are some endings which white
can definitely fight hard in here
remember you get 10 seconds bonus per
move
so Queenie for makes a bunch of sense
um to trade or not to trade that is the
question
I think I would keep Queens on the board
Lawrence I don't know about you Queen
and Knight normally work pretty well
together so move like Queen G7 my
yeah you might have to go back that's
the problem and White Queen and Bishop
are lined up towards the black king like
a blade D6 there maybe
oh yeah
uh yeah level three results are possible
yeah
depends how ambitious Magnus wants to be
here
because of course
well uh
no I don't I don't see it clear
at all actually
yeah if if you take the Queens off the
board that white G Pawn might be a big
factor in the end game
um like you say not clear at all and
it's not even clear who's better in that
end game if the Queens disappear it's
not clear who's better suddenly with the
Queen's on the board
yeah I mean we said it was the same idea
this Queenie Fortress rather than Queen
B2 just a few moments ago but maybe it
was a massive difference maybe that was
the difference between an immediate win
and yeah an end game where he's got a I
mean win it all again he's got a fight
absolutely yes
um hey
Justin
Lawrence oh sorry you go no I was gonna
say just because I'm sure a lot of
people are asking what's going on in the
women's section I will say there is a
massive upset on the cards on board one
Byron coven over
uh who I don't know very well at all
assuming she's from Russia has actually
got a really really good position
against the stenyuk and Olga badelka I
was mentioning her as well off stream
has beaten Katarina lachno in round one
with the black pieces Olga on on the uh
feed a rapid list is rated 22-38 but we
all know she's a 2500 feed a rated
player so massively uh
sort of uh deceptive rating that she has
in in Rapid but she's beaten one of the
big favorites Katarina massive massive
massive uh result there as has Elena
bival she's also much stronger than the
2179 rating that she posts has beaten a
Bella continuity and other uh you know
solid uh Pro so um very surprising but
let's stick with this game uh is this so
clear now Bishop D5 C3
okay
and now it's over to Jose
what is he going to do after C3 go does
he go passive with rookie one Rook F7
exists threatening Rook C7 check I like
Rook F7 because D7 is also on the cards
there and he does Rook F7 rookie two
check
played
it's still a free result game right I
mean the clock could be a big factor
here though Tessa haki and under under
10 15 seconds most of the time
but the black king is not fully out of
danger looks like it's an amazing net
and
what has happened there he looks like he
has
just allowed some type of check or has
he put his King on d8 this is the
current position
okay Black's once one move away from
playing rookie one and promoting to a
new Queen
white has seven seconds and one move and
he just resigns
yeah wow I think he just panicked there
there was maybe no defense anyway but
wow I mean Magnus working the magic
yeah I think there was no defense by now
it feels like something went wrong
around here very difficult to say
exactly what though because actually
after this yeah rookie one there's just
no defense to walking home the pawn
massive result for Magnus in a very
tough game to start things off
uh massive massive massive result
um
in other news should we go back to the
tibatify ending because that's still
going on Jana publishing has won his
game
against 11 panzulia that was one of the
matchups that I thought was a pretty
easy uh guessable uh result there
because Levon he's a strong player
strong Grandma's from Georgia but way
past his prime
struck has beaten meal Mass which is
also oh no sorry I beg your pun with
sugars not yet your unless they are
still playing Fabiano also against the
Young menzewsky doesn't look like he's
got much going on so a whole bunch of
stuff mvl has drawn against cavalliev as
well so
a lot of upsets in inverted commas uh
taking place
all right and me meanwhile we do see
Hikaru fighting for his life he's
actually up on the clock now here is
black the black rook and Bishop are very
very active but
that black king is it in a mating net
and uh to battle by pushing pawns he's
got some ideas of pushing with G5
followed by a pushing white supports H6
and then trapping Black's King on the
back rank
um Hikaru here he's calculating whether
he can give a check with his Rook does
he push the d-pawn he pushes his own
Pawn but
okay now it feels like white surely has
a way through
surely white can break now with a move
such as G5
or Rook D7
Hikaru here he's battled so well I mean
we called it earlier he does defend
games like this for breakfast and
is he on course to do the same again I
think Tabata by is missing a trick
though he could just repeat moves give a
couple of checks with the white Rook
gain 20 seconds on the clock
it's root D7 but now Rook C4 check and
the F Pawn drops
no that's a bread and butter draw for
for Hikaru no roots oh he goes D2 that's
kind of surprises me wow yeah
yeah Hikaru
thinks he's not risking anything here
that's incredible to me
Rook seafood and he wants to go Roxy
Fortune King if I have Rook takes F4 and
D1 Queen David wow look at this look at
this little tactic here
and D1 Queen discover check
oh my goodness
incredible
I'm sure
so after Rook C4 check do you have to
play with like King E5
suddenly black as ideas like Bishop B2
check maybe putting something on D4 to
block uh blocked but now I can go King
[ __ ] the white Rook there
ah now you want to go sorry very minimum
Rook D4
well I don't lose I can go Bishop F7 T
and go Bishop B3
mm-hmm and the same game most likely
will be a draw but uh okay that position
is on the board after King E5 does
Hikaru have more does he take on F4
anyway uh
okay he gave a check when his King is
advancing
yeah similar idea
Rook D4 played
yeah and now he's gonna he's gonna wait
yeah he does go for safety he takes and
he'll block with the white Bishop but
I think Hikaru could just sit on that
position I think he can just put the
black king on G7 and say you can't break
through on the dark squares
Miracle save here from the American from
Hikaru Nakamura incredible what it what
an endgame player he is
yeah I think they're like any chance to
see anything Lawrence no because also
the bishop can just give itself up for
the for the F Pawn and we have a
classical
that's theoretical draw I actually
expect them to
to agree a draw
uh almost
you know in the next three moves
basically
you're a fortune teller Lawrence they
have your shaken hands it is yeah
absolutely incredible uh what a safe by
Hikaru Nakamura a lot of people you said
in chat had no concerns I tell you what
I was concerned if we go back to here
uh this was the key position for me
Queen's xb7 Bishop B7 and now the move
Bishop F5 not that difficult a tactic to
see I think was a really straightforward
way to convert this Advantage black
can't deal with all the threats
um so that's why clearly very
disappointed because you don't get this
kind of position against Hikaru every
day of the week
um
but um I mean
yeah missed opportunity but yeah we've
got to give credit fully to Hikaru
um for those defensive skills that's
what's needed to win these World titles
you need to I mean you will have four or
five bad games in a 13 round tournament
but you need to cling on and survive uh
when that happens
and all right let's go some games going
Lawrence
yep let's go to uh another fan favorite
Richard report playing against the young
vacative part of that incredible uh
Uzbek uh gold meaning gold-winning
Olympia team uh for those of you who
don't know or don't remember uh this
young Uzbek team which was ranked
something like 20th or 15th going into
the Olympiad won the entire event uh an
incredible feat uh by an incredibly
talented team vac it off being part of
that team
uh playing against Richard Rapport but
his position looks toast because of the
you've got the same color Bishops here
as white I think you can resign here
with a clear conscience as black white
will play H4 he'll play King E3 he'll
play G4 F4 G5
he will then uh mop up the B Pawn
maybe he doesn't even need to mop up the
people yeah there was one final trick
Lawrence if white he hasn't played King
E3 if White had played H4 for example
then Blackwater played the bishop back
to F7 and round to G6 oh suddenly black
is saving the game I think
um so there was one final trick there's
always this last trick in chess and uh
therefore Richard I think correctly uh
drops his King back but
and what
yeah can vacative go for those white
pawns that's the final question
wow maybe he can
surely there's a way it's a lot of
pornstars
H4
okay why can't I put all my positions on
F4 G3 and and F4
F4 g3h it's
it's a bit similar to earlier if black
can somehow give up his Bishop for the
white G and F pawns it is a draw it's
the wrong color
uh h8 does not match the white Bishop so
some chances but like you say
um
surely white is winning here surely
white has enough time to go King C3 C3
yeah
I see absolutely no reason why
King E5
oh okay so King takes me to King F4
uh just H5 H6
uh
yeah why is the bar in the middle though
it looks like it's completely winning
for white wow is this is this not when
surely surely the bar is wrong here
sure defense wow Bush seven is clever
though from uh vacidov he's immobilized
the way H Pawn King G3 is coming
and he's not going to take on H4 the
black king he's going to take on G2 he's
going to leave the YH Pawn alive
uh
is this WOW could we see another miracle
I mean how many endgame saves have we
already seen today
and
okay Richard has a few seconds
does he push the Jeep on does he improve
the white Bishop King G3 is coming next
move no matter what
what is the way to win this that's a
great question
it's not straightforward Bishop sorry
King D4 played surely King G3 is the
only move here what else can you do
and what is raffle gonna do
clearly very very concerned
yeah rightly so I I think two of his
pawns are dropping um you can't save the
G pawn and how do you ever push the H
Pawn forward I don't think you can
or report dropped very low on the clock
there uh just a few seconds remaining
I mean I think he's uh out of luck here
report it looked so winning for white
but maybe he just
chose the wrong Square for his King
earlier White's King maybe went too far
away
and okay black can take on G2
take that pawn it's the only way to draw
the game but it will be enough
surely
although the buzz reacted again in
White's favor Lawrence King takes G2 and
the point is if you go F4 check I go
King G3 yeah and that is probably a draw
uh but maybe report's idea is to bring
the white king to G5 as soon as the
black king moves
maybe he's won it again
Bishop E8
played by vacidov trying
now he's going to come to G5 this way at
King 6h4
G4
yeah but this is now
uh a pretty simple win because now the
pawn just marches and you can't even
give up the bishop for for one Pawn now
so he's gonna try Bishop G5 but G5
yeah and Vac it off is not going to save
this position
yeah no trance anymore and I can back it
off vacca wasted one move with this
bishop and that was enough he played
Bishop H5 I'm not sure he needed to lost
the tempo and that gave whites King
enough time to Race Across
okay no Miracle safe it looks like
Rapport managed to cling on to this
winning end game and good technique here
from report just moving his King across
he's just going to put that Viking on H6
H7 and promote the dew point
easy one now for white
yeah vacuoled off camera sign here with
a clear conscience and he does
and disappointed vacuole because he
thought he might Swindle him very rare
do you see a position where your three
pawns up
with the same color Bishops
uh and still uh uh have some kind of
chance normally it's Stone dead there
but fair play to Rapport found the way
and got the victory
um
okay
well a lot of the results have come in
yeah
we are gonna take a quick break now uh
but we will be back with a quick summary
of what happened in round one lots of
excitement as expected don't go anywhere
we've got round two coming up in just a
jiffy
foreign
events but it is our first impressions
that we remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
forgettable emotions from the first date
the first expensive things you bought
when you got your first paycheck and
your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
chess.com's coverage of the world rapid
and Blitz championships today is the
first day of the rapid championships
takes place over three days we've just
seen round one well nearly we've still
got one game going on I'm here of course
with the one and only David Hal David
uh we've got the classic
rook and Bishop versus Rook
uh end game we see there's tons and tons
in these tournaments
it's board board 73 uh the guy playing
with white is uh mammal Petrosian trying
to uh squeeze this one out
tends to be won quite often when you say
David uh to even at top level in Rapid
championships yeah we see this Rick and
Bishop versus Rook scenario countless
times in tournaments uh especially
somehow in rapping and Blitz I'm not
sure why but um yeah it does have a very
high winning percentage despite the fact
it is objectively a draw and we have to
give credit to the player with the black
pieces the local boy
um Abdul Kaya I think his name is and uh
he's defended it so well so far he's
defended perfectly he's never really
found himself with his King on the edge
of the board but he's uh still up
against it he still has to avoid a
couple of uh pitfalls we know that if
the king does get kicked onto one of the
corners one into one of the edges then
it is disaster time so um he still has a
bit of time on the clock I'm expecting
him to at some point set up the second
ranked defense put the black Rook on the
same rank as the king you can't just
okay there we go he is playing that move
Rook to A2 and yeah I can't fault his
play even the top Grandmasters have
failed to defend it I've seen Peter
svidler lose this before in the world
rapid Championship to Magnus Carlson
we've seen Richard report win this in
the past we've seen uh yeah countless
countless losses by the defending side
but not this one I think we will be
hitting the 50 move rule soon so we
should be headed towards that draw and
uh once that draw is confirmed we will
start to see the results
uh announce we will see the pairings but
that's a bit later the players
they will be enjoying their break those
who are finished right now
um I don't know about you Lawrence but I
love that kind of extra five ten minute
break while someone else is slaving away
at the board
and uh it happens to be these two this
round
well I'll be honest with you David the
world rapid and Blitz is the only
tournament I've never played that I've
been dying to play pretty much all my
life uh for whatever reason I just
couldn't either get in or or find the
time to play it it is on my on my wish
list though uh so hopefully one day I'll
get uh get a chance to experience it
because it's just an awesome tournament
as David said we will know the pairings
of course only after this game is
finished uh in the meantime of course
what we could do very quickly while uh
these guys still played out is have a
look at perhaps some of the top uh games
from from round one we saw Magnus
Carlson win that uh mad game we saw
Hikaru draw uh a hopeless position
against a battle by a huge Point gained
a half Point gain for ikaru but some
other big dogs have been barking and why
don't we start with how about we start
with somebody like Fabiano caruana
uh playing against the Young linchesky
uh
uh we can flick through the game I've
not seen the game
in its entirety
but we can have a quick look
we have a Queen's Gambit accepted
very kind of well
uh peaceful opening inchesky tries to
get some activity but a little bit
overextended perhaps
it seems like this should be all right
you can see the bar just besides the
board David here
a little bit better for white maybe
nothing special
it looks very balanced in general the
reason we'd say this was slightly better
for weight is as you mentioned that
black E4 Pawn is a bit overextended a
bit weak a bit of a Target long term and
uh it just looks like Fabi as the more
experienced player as uh one of the uh
world's Elite did manage to outmaneuver
his opponent it started by getting the
bishop here just accumulating those
small advantages
this is classic rapid technique where
you just essentially do nothing you just
wait for your opponent to make those
mistakes you play quickly confidently
and eventually your opponent might crack
seems that's yeah Lawrence
exactly now targeting forcing black to
go five now he's got permanent dark
Square weaknesses as well Fabi just
jostling for the position
okay separates the Pawns
still kind of feels like black should
hold here but
I love what White's done though with the
H pawns uh just like you said he's fixed
a Target especially that black Pawn on
H7 now it's a permanent Target for white
slight Square bishop and
at the right moment it looks like shabby
did manage to crash through oh maybe it
wasn't a crash through it was more of a
mistake by the opponent
black should perhaps do nothing
right
massive uh I mean this is typical as
well in Rapid chess and Blitz chess you
get impatient you're playing against the
clock you're playing in a really high
pressure tense situation and
I guess black just resigned here because
white is going to match the king forward
to F4 Black's King is stuck defending
the H7 pawn and he transitioned from a
worse end game into a totally lost end
game here black and this is totally lost
because his Bishop is a bad one it's on
the same color as all of his pawns white
is gonna gobble all of them up
eventually
Knight teaches it Knight takes H6 just a
big big mistake
yep yeah
so all right slowly and steadily indeed
let's take a look at Abdul saturov the
reigning world rapid Champion David
let's walk through this game
yeah
Rainy World rapid Champion Abdus tour of
and a man in form he won the gashomorph
memorial recently a very strong
tournament with five rounds to spare he
won it five rounds in advance and uh an
English opening from the youngster uh
the Uzbek our master
he won last year's World Record
Championship pretty much based on the
English opening he beat Magnus there he
beat napoleonishi there aronian a bunch
of players in that opening this has
transposed however to a king's Indian
defense
I'm still very well known stuff very
solid Quincy a bit of a strange move
cartridge is a very aggressive player so
I guess he wants to play Bishop H3 at
some point is black
still very standard stuff
um
computer really liking white at the
moment but I guess that's just because
of a small space Advantage black is
still relatively solid
and uh developing pieces Queen d8 is a
bad sign though uh losing two Tempi is
black what's that Queen done not much
and white pieces are starting to come to
life Bishop H3 really nice move there
Lawrence
just getting out the ways uh yeah
essentially threatening Knight G5
exactly very nice move good Vision by Dr
satorov
Queen B4 flying into the action this way
and now this is nice if Queen B6 you can
play Rook takes E7
you know not fear of losing the queen
yeah I mean while we did see that end
game finally finished Recon Bishop
versus Rook what was the result I missed
it
I missed it as well I must say I think
it was brought in the end we'll try and
get that confirmed in a moment but there
we see the rest of the players just uh
mulling around the tournament Hall just
waiting for the parents to be announced
uh as someone who's played in the world
rapping of Blitz Championship several
times myself that's always the most
frustrating time oh it wasn't a draw it
looks like white did win uh Checkmate
next move Black's King did find itself
caught on the edge of the board
and uh heartbreak for the young Kazakh
player with black
after King A6 Rook A4 is Checkmate uh in
this position so yeah
that's a tough one that's gonna be a
tough pill to swallow
as we said though that's why this is
converted so many times the pressure
rapid sometimes you have to find only
moves so I need defenses and
Petrosian comes through
uh all right so we'll soon know the
pairings for round two of course the
place we've yet to take their seats
let's have a look at another fan for oh
I beg about we were actually mid game
here let's have a look sorry Queen B4
blackplay P6 takes
Queen takes D5 yuck because c65 Rook C8
is horrific so you have to play Queen 65
and now you just take one E7 Easy Pawn
and Rook C1 lovely move here I have to
set her off again playing on that bank
back rank theme the queen can't be taken
because if I could take C8 here drop the
queen back now the Knight is out of
place and you can just win the two
pieces
and the rest oh actually he had to fall
seed Queen C4 here
because there's a double attack on both
Bishops but it's good enough for T5
Queen 66
overloads everywhere
rookie 8 is coming
uh it is
you made that look easy Cadre traded
2584 I just said sort of just blow him
off the board in an innocuous looking
English
uh very very impressive indeed
yeah he's gonna be a tough one to beat
actually he might well be one of the
favorites to retain his title he's just
so direct so strong at rapid chess I
think rapid is the perfect uh format for
him
um you can't be too Direct in classical
in Blitz it can back fire but rapid he's
just uh forced to be reckoned with great
game
absolutely yes I'm just uh going down
this to see if there's any other major
upsets I can't see any big upsets just
yet uh Lil upset on board 31 maradly
uh has beaten a rachmanov miradley the
young azri Grandmaster beating the
experience
who's rated 100 points higher but not a
huge surprise for people who have been
watching chess Mohammed Muradi has been
uh extremely uh active doing very very
well and part of a small group of now
azri Grandmasters to start coming
through it's been a while David
uh it's it's it's been a while since uh
we've seen uh a kind of group of
talented azri grandmas because of course
they boast some of the top players in
the world mamajarov rajabov who's saying
off
um but a young crop it felt like it's
been a while since we've seen some but
that it seems like they've got some
coming through now
yeah you're right Lawrence uh some very
young talented players from Azerbaijan
but meanwhile it looks like the parents
have come out at least the results are
out for round one uh so maybe we can
check in on uh yeah some of the stats
some you mentioned
okay
yeah so we have no pairings but results
are up
yeah no pairings results are all
confirmed uh the board that we see in
front of us is actually the final
position from the muradli Rachmaninoff
game and interesting uh because
very weirdly this Knight on F2 is almost
trapped
in the in the position I don't
understand why black wouldn't try 94
here
trying to let that Knight come out maybe
black lost on time
uh because 94 does look like a move here
and I don't see
an immediate refutation David
uh yeah I mean neither Lawrence I've got
to say it looks like Black's just a pawn
up looks like a decent position it's
complicated some trips always not a
point I'm sorry but uh yeah it's
complicated position it must be time or
perhaps you played a move such as Knight
G4 or Knight H3 and only then realized
you'd put his Knight on a square it
could be captured but strange result but
strange things do happen in Rapid and
Bliss games that's part of the part of
the thrill I guess
absolutely
big result there for more Radley
uh vidit has beaten uh the Australian
Grandmaster Bobby Chang
um
well
looks like an interesting final position
let's see what happened here because it
looks as though wow it looks as though
things were actually
very unclear with just a few moves to go
uh White is a piece up but his King is
in the middle of the crossfire
Queen A4 seems to have been a mistake
here as well rugby three and now Bishop
takes E3 a big blunder allowing C7
Queen 67. wow that's a complete collapse
actually because that's the most obvious
move in the world
yeah I don't understand how that's
happened
this queen A4 move uh is another obvious
one and in Rapid chess when you've got
10 seconds left why not give a check it
looks what could be more natural it
looks very sensible but after Queen A4
suddenly White's King is completely safe
and I think the subsequent blunder uh
Bishop takes A3 allowing white to push
with C7 I think that was just kind of um
that was just follow through from kind
of the shock that suddenly White's King
is safe and no more threats to be seen
so yeah I'm a bit of a shock surprise
there uh kind of surprise ending to the
game but vid it's very tactically sharp
so I'm not that surprised that he
managed to get the better of his uh less
experienced opponent
all right let's keep on going uh we can
see another fan favorite Daniel duboff
uh haven't seen him around so much
recently it feels Daniel of course won
this tournament
uh when was it
four years ago 2018 I think and yeah I
think four years four years ago Daniel a
world champion in his own right playing
the young talented Belgium Grandmaster
Daniel dada
uh and winning
again uh looks as though
it is um
well a case of the better player
simply uh outclassing his younger
opponents
yeah White's two pawns up in the final
position
nice engine grind there from Daniel
dubov
but Lawrence we do have the pairings for
round two meanwhile they have been
announced
oh look at this one on board one Magnus
Carlson playing against half of
the chess bra Duo Eric Hansen
who
um I uh was just in LA with after
getting beat up by his colleague
bit of an early stoppage that's another
story
Magnus starts from White against Eric
Hansen
on board one we've got shigerov playing
against Rapport on board too that's
interesting mahmedov talking of azri
grand Masters and talented rapid and
Blitz players what about Ralph it's
gonna give uh yankova a good run for his
money another young talented Grandmaster
aravind playing against neponishi not
tirosian also young Armenian grandmas
against Carolina Harsha
get young guys everywhere those not so
young Sebastian mazetovich with a big
test even with white pieces against
artemiev and Sabino Brunello Who David
uh was apparently rated
27-25-ish at rapid I think even Sabino
will admit probably slightly inflated
there playing against Amin and moisenka
against dugoff which of those pairings
takes your fancy
well it's got to be Magnus Carlson
against Eric Hansen they're also good
friends uh I do have a bit of inside
information they were hanging out a lot
in Kazakhstan uh just in the last couple
of days in the build up uh to this event
so Magnus with the white pieces will
start as the favorite but Eric is anyone
who's watched the chess for our streams
knows he's a dangerous speed chess
player
um I'm also really interested to see how
some of the younger players do in this
tournament and uh feder Sev against
yakubov I think it's actually going to
be a huge game fellas
we all know uh especially players who
play on chess.com he's crazy good at
rapid chess and jakubov recently won a
uh a speed tournament online a very
strong one so I I do have a feeling
those were two of my underdogs actually
when I was looking through the list of
players before the tournament I had a
feeling feather say if this might be his
big breakthrough
um he's been up there several times he's
won medals in World Rapids but uh never
the God so I'm gonna be watching that
one as well
and uh yeah of course not just these top
10 boards but uh all the way down
Lawrence I mean the elite have just
flocked to uh flock to Kazakhstan it's
there's literally no weak players in
either of the fields uh in the open or
the women's sections it's just
yeah surprises already uh with some top
players dropping drawers dropping full
points but uh we'll see more of that as
the rounds tick on today
yeah and uh talking of of rounds and
round two in the women's section we can
see goyaj kinan there getting ready for
her game they've had to wait this entire
time for this rook and Bishop nonsense
to finish and have just been quietly sat
there uh
stewing and there's nothing worse than
having to wait for 20 minutes sitting in
that chair you just want to get the game
started get going they weren't able to
but looks as though they will be in a
moment
um
we saw voyagecon are playing against uh
lilit from Armenia I always pronounce
her last name badly David I know you
know her last name
thanks for putting me on the spot
Lawrence um okay Janna thinks right yeah
okay Chan yeah
very strong very talented very
experience yeah
not an easy game there for guy now with
black
yeah we also see harika I think there in
the background
um she is uh you know she's up against
Anna satonsky of the US several time U.S
Champion
um I think still waiting for some
players to take their seat you mentioned
that the weight between games uh it can
be long it can be arduous I remember
when I played in 2017 in Saudi Arabia in
the world rapid Championship we once had
to wait over two hours between one round
because there was an appeal and there
were there were no chairs there was no
waiting room
oh that was a that was a drag but uh
these places I was in Saudi Arabia
that was yes
but uh yeah Kazakhstan I've heard the
conditions out there for the players uh
very nicely will look very comfortable
and seeing a lot of the social media
about how the players are loving the uh
loving the venue
and then we see famed photographer
Leonard Utes
there we go Leonard
and Maria emilianova also there
been uh doing a great job for the for
the chess Community for many years these
two taking great snaps helping with the
technical side often shout out to
Leonard shout out to Maria
uh we're of course waiting for round to
to start
um
it's gonna be uh
it's gonna be an interesting one that's
for sure
interesting also to see that
uh some other names we haven't spoken
about
just yet
uh who are
participating and potential Dark Horses
because it's always fun to sweat the
dark horses now
of course what I'm about to say is going
to be
um extremely uh
uh
uh what's the word controversial thank
you very much
I believe there is another American
player playing is there not in the form
of Mr Hans Neiman
who uh
of course has been embroiled in
a major uh
allegation case
uh with Magnus Carlson and various
others but uh hands did not actually win
round one he drew against the local
player agmanov
so hands dropping off quite early
he may not be
uh let's say uh
well he he needs to get in to get gear
pretty quick you don't want to leave
these guys
uh too much room to just extend leads
who else is around that could cause a
potential upset a real Dark Horse
maybe Lawrence we could even do some
predictions because there are already
some yeah courses on the keyboards why
not look at the pairing so we can uh see
if any of those dark courses might cause
a surprise
let's do that and uh okay Magnus Carson
against Eric Hansen Dark Horse in that
one for sure is Eric
do you think he's going to cause a
surprise no I mean Eric has also got an
issue because he played on the uh the
Melt water Chairman's chess tour you
commentated a bunch of games this year
David I think Eric has got a bit of a
mental block against Magnus or some kind
of psychological
uh problem that many players do that
they just can't get close to Magnus
think Eric falls into that category I
expect Magnus win 90 Plus at the time so
not not a fan of Eric's Chances with
black
yeah I'm inclined to agree Eric's up
against it however he did win one game
against Magnus in the meltwater
Champions Chester and that was with
black and uh meanwhile on the camera we
also see our event against napoleonici
maybe our prediction for this one
well firstly I'm a big fan of the
Publisher's haircut that looks very
sharp so fair play to yarn uh aravind a
tricky customer but I actually think
that this is a bad opponent for aravind
yeah a Yan can mix it up he plays
extremely fast aravind is not as strong
as the other Indian
Superstars Arabic very very strong of
course but when I think of the likes of
Roman and gukesh and the like irrigation
Irwin just hasn't managed to fit into
that group just yet still going to be a
tough game for the animation but I
believe Yan will actually win that the
black pieces
yeah uh I'm inclined to agree again
maravint he's very solid however I've
played him a few times and with white
he's very hard to break down his opening
repertoire is very principled uh
meanwhile we saw Magnus Carlson arriving
and this game san and sugirov against
Richard reports uh we saw a report wrap
up a tough end game in the previous
round do you think he's gonna take this
on as well with black
this one I actually think is gonna most
likely be a draw uh sukiro very very
solid customer with the white pieces
decent rapid player and Blitz player I
don't see either of these players
getting completely out of line I'm
actually going to go for a draw in this
one
mm-hmm
and uh yeah I will say actually a bit of
a surprise I'll go for San and Seeger
off to surprise Richard report okay in
round two I mean while we see Eric
arrive and
the games up will start in just a few
moments
um how about yes okay hike materials Yan
against Fabiano caruana more predictions
this is a bad pairing for Fabiana uh
Mata rosian and the young Armenians tend
to cause Fabi some issues fabulous black
uh I will actually go for a matarosian
uh surprise victory in that game
all the time uh just a specific
match-ups where I'm not so keen on the
matchup I think this is one of them
which could be uh a small issue for Fabi
but let's see he's a class player and of
course can easily win this game I think
Marta rosian though is a tricky customer
nonetheless
Carlson against Hansen
Magnus has gone for 1b3
wow we're off and first surprise of the
game I mean Magnus he's never going to
play the same same opening twice
um that's one of the trickiest things
when playing against him preparing
against him and Eric already spending a
bit of time figuring out how to reply
surely he's faced this one before uh B3
is a rare move but most of the top
players do have an idea or two against
it
Eric his Achilles heel on the champion
stress tour and in Rapid chess in
general against the top guys is that he
tends to get in time trouble
uh like you said maybe a bit of a mental
block maybe not feeling as confident as
he could uh against these real elite
players and he needs to move just bring
the Knight out push a pawn in the center
there's a bunch of ways to be uh to
reach a healthy position after 1v3
Lawrence uh okay he goes for D5 after a
while
you impressed by this opening Choice by
Magnus surprised at all well I'm not
totally surprised no uh I think it's a
pretty decent choice
by Magnus because he's already going to
get that big advantage on the clock
Bishop B2 Bishop G4 now a very
interesting move believe it or not is
the move forward to F3 now I'm not sure
that matters is going to play this but
it is a principal move the point is that
it looks ridiculous to move your F Pawn
and weaken your king but after the move
Bishop H5 and now they move Knight to
each Street the idea is to bring the
Knight to F4 win this bishop and try to
play Bishops and Magnus does indeed play
F3
and now I think probably the best move
is actually just to drop it back to F5
then all kinds of interesting stuff can
happen for example the E4 here is a very
interesting Gambit and after d takes E4
playing Knight C3 playing some kind of
black mardemar variant and if e takes F3
you could even consider Queen takes F3
here and all of a sudden things get very
very exciting so after them and he does
go Bishop F5 and I fully expect Magnus
to play E4 here you can play E3 which is
a much more solid way but Magnus he's
he's not going to be able to resist
playing E4 against Eric especially I can
just feel it
um have you been coaching Magnus for
this event Lawrence have you been a
second I mean I'm just playing all these
weird one for openings that you're more
used to than he is perhaps
yeah I haven't spoken to Magnus but
I can expect even the move G4 here might
exist in all kinds of craziness could
happen so this is a critical moment and
E4 on the board
yeah it just it's just impossible to
resist playing this move
against Eric and Magnus is like okay I'm
gonna have a ton of fun now
uh in this position
and Eric's gonna have to calculate
because
you know this opening is not common he
won't have looked at this too recently
and uh Magnus is going to enjoy himself
enjoy calculating this game
yeah and I think already obviously a
critical Moment On The Board uh with
this E4 Pawn sacrifice Eric needs to
defend uh resolutely but also it's a
critical moment in terms of psychology
Eric as we mentioned does get low on the
clock against some of these uh Stronger
players and I don't think he can allow
himself to think for five six minutes
here it's very quick game and ideally he
would have done his homework on this
position before like you said it's a
rare position but if you play Bishop G4
as black I'll move two and Retreat the
bishop to F5 you have to have looked at
some of these uh I mean more direct
attempts to punish you for losing time
with your Bishop so ideally Eric should
either capture this porn or move his
Bishop instantly you can't afford a long
think here but he's already in the tank
I'm a bit worried for him already it's
only move four
it's uh looks like Magnus has got
everything he could have dreamed of and
he clearly knows more about this opening
than Eric does
yeah it's worrying times for the chess
bro early enough maybe in this one
Lawrence
yeah
uh Eric has to be very very careful he
doesn't want to be I think go it's
Bishop G6 I was thinking is he going to
play this move actually just sort of
saying okay I'm not that interested in
letting you just get this huge
initiative with white I'm going to drop
my Bishop back how bad can this position
be anyways
um now Magnus is going to have fun
though is he going to play H4
and try and go H5 is he going to play
Knight H3
excuse me to go to F4
uh
I don't think Knight C3 makes too much
sense D4 looks awkward there so I'm
going to say it's going to be either H4
or Knight H3 Knight H3 E5 uh sorry you
can't play E5
hmm
yeah both of those moves look very
attempting you could also perhaps make
an argument for a moose such as Queen E2
um threatening Queen B5 check in some
variations getting path clear for
White's King to Castle Queen side
um just defending E4 as well if you're
not willing to uh kind of allow another
opportunity for black to grab that pawn
so Magnus has options but it will either
way be a really unorthodox position and
it will be Eric most likely facing the
threats this early stage
um yeah I've got to say I love it this
is why I prefer rapid and Blitz to
classical chess these days
um just because okay H4 on the board uh
but yeah just because players do feel a
bit more inclined to freestyling so
taking risks and
okay H5 is it's a threat a massive
threat how does black defend
do you have to play it H5 yourself H6
yourself is black
and tends to play Queen D6 but I don't
think it works
um yeah oh wow Queen D6 Queen D6 might
run into E5 right yeah well I can just
shut you down uh maybe even H5
because now at least the bishop would
have an escape score on F5
Queen G3
ah the bishop is trapped on G6 it's like
a caracan almost with black space coming
out earlier
Magnus loves playing against the Aragon
absolutely
great opening Choice by Magnus here
an H4
if black does play a move such as H6 to
give the bishop an escape Square to give
it some Luft as we say some breathing
space then maybe now you're moving
Knight H3 comes with even more power
um okay H6 is that on the board Eric has
pushed the safe Pawn I think he's pushed
it to H5 actually
it's uh and mag just instantly reacting
do you think this could be preparation
has Magna studied this before or is he
just in the flow is he just kind of
trying to scare Eric with his speed
I'm not sure he takes D5 is a very
curious decision enough
uh didn't spend too much time on it at
all
but is this good I mean Knight C3 Queen
E5 check and can you now go Queen E5
Queen G3
so okay after queening five check
and he went Queen D6
like he's spending a lot of
time with his Queen
feels wrong somehow
26 it now it looks like a Scandinavian
with Black's Queen coming out so early
dropping back one square like you say
queen G3 is a Potential Threat white can
guard against that with a move such as
Knight H3 perhaps dropping back to F2 or
White Queen could come out to E2 perhaps
still ways for Magnus to kind of develop
but with gain of time and I think that's
key in this position Black's King as
well is going to struggle to find safety
on the king side that's true of both
Kings right now
yeah I would be inclined to play Queen
E2 here for magnets just develop with
Tempo Black's Bishop isn't really
attacking the C2 Pawn because it will
get trapped if it ever gets greedy
we should take C2 here just D3 would
trap the bishop
and
yeah again threats on the board Queen B5
check the White Knight coming forward to
B5 white wants to get cast with Queen
side
like has to try and give a check perhaps
on G3 just to mess with White's plans
and uh what has he played
the reigning world champion at least for
the next few months
yeah and
Queen F2 King F2 swapping those Queens
off
does this favor Black perhaps
white king is not safe despite the
Queens being off the board
I think this is massively in Black's
favor is it not
yeah
but Magnus has played Queenie too
if Queen G3 check swapping the Queens is
in Black's favor then
does white have to move his King Eric
doesn't even ask the question could be a
bit of a miss
he's just allowing us to finish his
plans
but he has got the D4 Square so I mean
if black Castle's queen size sorry if
White Castle's Queen side
you might not go Knight D4 immediately
but certainly exist and if black does
play Knight F6 how bad
is life black here probably
is all right for black
um I might still take white but it's
maybe not as bad as
it could have been
yeah these positions are often a matter
of tempo and white would have ideas such
as Knight B5 in that position throwing
the D Pawn forward and uh really going
on the attack as quickly as possible but
like you say I has ideas of his own
maybe if white does Castle queenside
Eric will instantly plant that Black
Knight
into D4 and uh there is a double Strat
Knight takes E2 attacking the queen of
course but C2 is uh on pre as well
certainly questions being asked for both
sides and I do like the fact that Eric
has sped up since that initial pause
early in the opening
um that's very problem yeah he's
actually up up on the clock now believe
it or not
which is surprising
do you think he might have lured
Magnuson just paused a bit at the
beginning just to pretend just to feign
ignorance uh that's often what I try to
do to spend a bit of time pretend to my
opponent I don't know what's going on
and then speed up uh as soon as they
fall in uh in line with my plans
because it seems to have worked out for
Eric Magnus yeah which move has he
played after Knight C6
uh he did Castle long how interesting
ah interesting and what does he want to
do against Knight D4 what's the idea
yeah and you can't take on C2 because of
some Knight B5
that's King in a lot of trouble here
and if Bishop takes two
also Knight B5
yeah maybe five looks pretty strong here
although
some calculation needs to be done Rook
V8 at the end yeah
not actually over
maybe night night D5 after Bishop takes
C2 there's a lot to calculate in these
types of positions
and uh
yeah I mean it's already super
complicated it's already both players I
think we'll see them spend four or five
minutes on the next few moves just to
make sure they survive the opening
and Magnus asking those questions as we
always see from him
I think if black wants to play it safe
just Castle keep the king uh
over on C8 maybe on B8 in the night out
to F6 as you mentioned
uh Eric just needs to play safe
and uh what do you think Lauren should
we stick with this one as it heats up or
should we check in with some other games
um we I mean this is a we can have a
quick look to see if there's anything
absolutely breaking elsewhere
looking through now
nothing whoa
oh no that's incorrect uh the maze art
Timmy of game said it was winning for
Marseille but it's actually
they didn't reset the board correctly
from the last round
um
there's always technical hiccups in the
early rounds of these tournaments
I think we should stay here because it's
such a fascinating
uh position
so Eric
go on love that choice by Eric sorry to
Castle queenside
Quincy for and Carlson's long has been
played Knight E4 Now by Magnus cutting
the uh the Bishops uh
roll off along this diagonal
hitting the queen
so now Queen B6 this looks fairly
logical
looks okay for Eric to me
yeah he's he's got central control one
more move if black pushes the pawn to E5
then I think he's solved all his
problems
um you don't really have anything to
fear at all the black White's
development while White's development is
slightly lacking so Magnus does play
Knight E2 trying to trade off that
fantastic Knight on D4
and yeah suddenly if Eric is feeling uh
a bit too agreeable and goes for some
exchanges then white is the one who's
leading in development wait Bishop on B2
might open up uh I agree with Jules
Gambit there in the uh in the chat
saying Eric getting aggressive
uh Eric wants to be aggressive here of
course he wants to create some threats
but you have to keep peace on the board
to do that so what do you think Lawrence
just defend that night with E5 Maybe
allow the exchange but on your own terms
yeah I think I had to move E5 I think
you can I think you can play more
more uh straightforward as well you
could just take on E2 Bishop takes E2
uh maybe just bring the Knight out I
mean how bad is this black
also looks acceptable to me
yeah that's a good point and if white
ever takes on S6 for example Knight X F6
ef6 in this position this Pawn structure
in an end game isn't great for black but
so much activity and look at those black
bishops yeah
great potential for them this looks fine
as well yeah maybe I wrote off this and
I'd exchange too soon I agree with you
Lawrence keep things simple
things safe
yeah I think I think this one is
is just fine for Eric let's see
uh how he decides to continue here after
Knight E2
looks yeah looks like he's got a bunch
of options
yeah it doesn't want to lag too far
behind on the clock though
yeah you're right
um he's spent a long time not just on
this last move
um I was about to say I know Magnus very
well and this is not uh the body
language this is not the pose of a
player who likes his position
um so he probably knows that Eric is
completely fine on the board but uh yeah
he's gonna try and press on the clock
Magnus he's got hustle mode activated a
lot these days he's very good at uh kind
of that dual
um playing both on the board and Clark
and okay the Knight exchange has
happened Eric has to speed up he has to
play 906 swap off white strong right now
no time to think I think any other move
actually and white will build up some
initiative oh E6 it looks like from Eric
but now it's harder to develop for black
which one is tied down to the G7 Pawn
that doesn't look like a step in the
right direction
yeah E6 felt a little bit impulsive
there by Eric I mean it might still be
fine
uh but it feels a little bit impulsive
the question is what do you do now with
white how do you improve your position
and Magnus in his typical pose uh he he
has got quite a poker face when it comes
to chess
he he doesn't give away a lot of support
when he's made a big plunder of course
he's normally up in arms
um he gives it away in that kind of
situation but in general you can see him
here if you looked at him and you didn't
know about Chess or anything you
wouldn't know if he was enjoying it or
not
um I think he's fine
he's just all right
uh
and uh
you know
he's trying to figure out a way but he's
probably also a little bit frustrated
because the position doesn't actually
that there isn't a lot to bite on here
with white yes you've got the nice
Bishop you've got the Knight on e4 but
improving your position here is is
actually not that straightforward black
has still got plenty of ways he can
prove improve uh completing development
for example of his King side
um Knight H6 Knight F5 exists or you can
come by E7 to F5 or D5
um
is always a useful move yeah King B8
tons of ways for black to improve if
white does absolutely nothing from
summative white also decides to play
King B1
so I think Eric is actually going to be
relatively happy and Magnus the more he
thinks about it maybe the more he starts
to realize
oh actually
maybe things aren't so great for white
here
um
and the body language question you
mentioned Lawrence uh Magnus we've seen
in the speech has Championship
throughout the meltwater Championships
tour he's very expressive in online
chess but over the board I think we'll
see this post from him for the next five
days uh as you say just uh very stoic if
anything and just mulling over the Moose
I wouldn't be surprised to see him play
a move such as A4 for white that's just
every time I see Magnus it's just
pushing pawns on the queen side
um he's been very influenced by Alpha
zero he could push with G4 at some point
uh White pawns aren't really playing a
role and you can't just play with pieces
as you say you've got nothing to bite on
uh if you just play with pieces they'll
just get exchanged to the very best
so it feels like he needs a pawn break
but which one to aim for
eign
so this is of course getting the King on
a good square but he's he's saying he
doesn't quite know what to do here
and now I expect
I think Knight H6
yeah I slightly prefer Knight E7 because
white if white does play G4 then your
knight might be stuck out on a limb okay
97 at least you've got two good squares
as targets now F5 and D5 and Eric does
play that move
um you know looking healthier by the
moment for Hansen
you know again Magnus that can be one
move that's a real worry if you can't
find anything better than that
I don't think he's gonna find anything
productive over the next few turns
either
yeah what else to do yeah White Queen
can't really be improved why it's
Bishops can't be improved why it's Rooks
same
um feels like you're stuck moving Pawns
and I really like the fact that Eric
kind of played 97 very quickly he
there was no news
yep and up on the clock so things and
and here's your move David A4
played by Magnus
trying to get some space over that side
of the board
yeah I don't know how I feel about it
though
it's it's not clear what the threat is
it's not clear what the idea is but uh
trust me magnus's pawns always promote
so watch out for that a pawn deciding
the game later and uh Eric might be
tempted now to play a move such as
Knight D5 just to make sure that white
doesn't continue pushing pawns on that
Queen side
um also hinting jumping into F4 or B4
again it looks very very healthy for
black this position
and uh yeah I'm noticing a lot of
support for Eric actually in the chat a
lot of players saying come on Eric you
can do this Eric underrated and what do
you think Lawrence Eric 2600 I mean it
feels like he should be much higher
especially in Rapid chess
yeah I've always said this about Eric I
mean his talent is undeniable he's top
top player
um
if he managed his time if his time
manager was better I think that would be
reflected in his rating
obviously also he's involved in various
different Ventures he's not just doing
chess and studying chess he's got it
Channel and and Esports teams and all
kinds of stuff it's very difficult to
reach a full of full potential when
you're kind of spreading yourself thin
but you know no question about it he can
do get out with the best of them
Knight C6 played slightly surprising
square but also looks fine
yeah I think that choice was influenced
by White's last move A4 now white will
never really push the a pawn further
Black's Knight still has a couple of
Juicy squares to jump into D4 maybe now
B4 maybe even A5 the White Queen is
lacking in squares I'm slightly worried
she might get trapped in certain cases
and
um yeah Magnus again the question how to
improve his last two moves have been
nothing type of Moves In A Way King B1
A4 they're not bad moves but they're not
necessarily improving his position long
term it feels like Magnus biting his
time waiting for the moment to pounce at
uh Eric still up on the clock now Knight
C6 and just passing the move back to
black it feels like this is the Calm
before the storm
um at some point this one will explode
but Magnus struggling to find a way at
the moment
yeah and another player struggling which
I managed to put the commentator's curse
on firmly for this round it seems
is uh somebody I thought was going to
win Jana pomonishi playing Black against
aravind but his position
is a complete mess Jana publishing here
uh
it looks
close to totally losing
h494 I I just don't see any
why and I don't see any
Swindle along the G file here
um maybe you maybe you don't have to do
it that way maybe you can even go with
F4 I don't know
is the idea that after all G8 after H4
that nepho wants to play something like
this Swindle his King out and try and
make something work could be even this
might still be good for white but
uh this is a critical moment in this
game that looks looks just horrible
David
yeah I'm completely in agreement here
um as Ty up says in the chat that Bishop
G5 is getting trapped no matter what I
do like this last move by aravind King
H1 just getting out of any potential
swindles like you say on the G file just
why stared out why get stared down by a
rook on G8 if you can Shuffle into the
corner hide with completely complete
safety that Bishop is not escaping and
F4 like you said H4 what's Knight is
bringing forward to G4
I don't see any way for black to
untangle uh get his Bishop out of that
horrible Square it sits on right now and
Black's King not feeling safe either
yeah it looked like a disastrous opening
from napoleonishi and we've got to
mention uh Napoleon he has a world
championship match coming up in just a
few months so he will be hiding some
opening preparation there will be
moments when he plays subpar openings
just to uh throw ding his future
challenge uh future opponent uh
and a throw him off and at least pretend
he's going to go in a certain direction
but this one has uh yeah not started
well
and of course the publishing came really
close last year he was only defeated in
the playoff for the world rapid Title by
Abdul sotorov so he has a score to
settle uh he also lost to Nakamura in
the playoff of the world uh World
official random championship
feels like he's always the nearly man
and uh this could be another case of
that
yeah absolutely
but this looks basically explained
well Bishop H6 played I don't understand
why things have changed after Knight G4
what's the big idea
I think he's trying to save himself with
tactics after white tonight comes
forward to G4 which has just been played
now Bishop D2
white will move the rook and as soon as
that happens F5 will at least counter
attack against White's Knight it's ugly
but
at least he's Clinging On temporarily
unless there's a tactical blow here for
white
feels like it's close to Checkmate if
white plays and moves oh wow
Queen H6 oh maybe we can show that
Lawrence oh my goodness
F4 now
wow
Queen H6
and here
he's threatening after Rook G7 you can
even
wow flashy way
flashy one Forks
wow is he gonna find F4 the young
Indians they are computers these young
these youngsters
um he finds it he finds F4 this is
brilliant by aravind
and now I mean rookie two threatens to
trap the bishop Queen H6 threatens to
win this is just all she wrote isn't it
yeah I mean black will be lucky to come
out of this with a piece down let alone
still in the game
um wow yeah too many threats here if
Bishop takes E1 doesn't work then you
might as well resign uh that black king
queen H6 check is even a bigger threat I
feel you can't take on F4 here it
doesn't work out for black you can't
give away material to survive
this might be the biggest shock so far
uh in round two
highest one of the highest seeds falling
and in quite a brutal fashion we must
say
just incredible
like you said these young these young
Indian players Lawrence they train so
much on calculation and it's for these
moments in games when there are forcing
moves you can create those threats you
can calculate four or five moves and and
they do it so quickly but uh Yan drops
his Queen back defending F6 so now
there's no infiltration from the White
Knight
just rookie too
that Bishop is trapped
rookie 2 is just clean okay two played
yeah F5 now you can play
plenty of moves white tonight can just
Retreat I feel to H2 but you could
probably come forward as well into H6
into E5 yeah
Bishop takes F5s exists okay Bishop F4
this is a Desperado
[Music]
um
gf4 Queen H4
the G8 Rook is hanging as well ah sorry
no no no I can't do this
um
it's just a piece up for one Pawn not
enough compensation for black
it's just a piece there's not really
much more to talk about
this is dusted for Napoli this will be a
big setback for him
uh assuming arrowman does not
ruin this uh pretty simple position
you know
sorry Lauren so I was gonna say Reynold
in the chat there being very harsh uh
about another trapped Bishop by
naponishi some bad memories there
getting [ __ ] strapped
I was actually with you in Oslo for that
round of the World Championships where I
was very critical of yeah
I got a lot of pushback for it but I
believe my criticisms were founded and
reasonable because I think he did play
very very poorly in that game especially
given it was a world championship match
I thought the level was was pretty bad
um
yeah it's not necessarily about
it's not necessarily playing party but
it's also playing too quickly we look at
the clock here and he's still got almost
eight minutes left and he's a piece down
in a hopeless position and yeah I
struggle with this a lot myself just
handling the the clock uh just finding
the right balance playing quickly but
also playing strong moves and I think
that has been the problem issues uh
challenge throughout his career
um so yeah I mean well if black has
nothing better than playing moves like
A6 then yeah it's not a good sign white
will eventually crash through you
mentioned it Lawrence taking on F5 at
some point giving the piece back to go
for checkmate he's setting it up aravind
a great game very smooth very well
controlled by uh by the young Indian
and uh meanwhile maybe we should switch
away we're assuming that napon Yoshi
can't fight back in this game
um unless let's go somewhere else
should we go back to Magnus maybe not
because there's you called it David I
should have listened to you sugarov
playing White against rap or Rapport
when this looks like some dodgy benoni
and this is this is the sort of position
that you learn when you whenever you
learn the bernonius black that you
should never get into it was black
because it is horrible
uh
white has got his Central push through
wow I mean the B5 is just is just uh
punt basically
and isn't this just totally losing
yeah it looks like you're getting
Steamroller in the center White's pawns
are Marching through White's night is
about to land on the E4 square and
Report he's done something that fisher
did with a lot of success against Basket
in 1972 he put his Knight on H5 as black
but it just got exchanged and
White's left with some fantastic pieces
one bad Knight on A3 but the rest of
White's position is beautiful and yeah I
think we'll stick with this one for a
little while because magnus's position
looks equal still
um okay not too much changing there but
yeah this one Lawrence like you said
white has so many beautiful options 94
he even just takes on B5 calling Black's
Bluff
report he's known as a bit of a crazy
player he surprises his opponents
surprises the crowd with every move but
uh this one
seems to have backfired I don't think
black can profit from the pin on the B
file that White Knight on B5 sitting
pretty
one more move if White's Queen can move
off B3
this game over White's gonna crash
through on D6
Queen can go to A4 C2
wherever this this this just looks
hopeless like I mean
the structure is ruined your pieces
aren't working you've got a a night on
f8 a woeful night on f8 I see
really close to zero hope
um
you just need one or two accurate moves
and secret is a bit low on the clock
he's under two minutes I like those
moves you mentioned I mean queen A4 is
the simple one if you just want to
survive get out the pin and
okay he does go for that approach
when A4 I'm expecting report now just to
beg for an end game just trade off on B5
Bishop takes yup Bishop takes Knight
recapture and now Queen D7
there we go we do see it record making
some moves and at least he'll get the
Queens off the board at least till yeah
yeah maybe you should Europe hasn't
actually played this
optimally because yeah now takes takes
takes and Rook B4
typical move you see a lot in these
benonias as well
and B2 F4 E5 are a little bit tender
maybe this is not so bad
um
maybe it is
no I mean I agree normally they say in
the benoni you get ugly positions in the
early stage but then the more pieces
that come off the better your position
becomes and uh yeah I like to comment a
moment ago about reports setting up his
pieces on the background ready for the
next game but he's getting those pieces
off the back rank and now the Queens
have left the board
yeah he's still alive it looks like a
few more moves have been played the
Queens are off and black has captured
upon on B2 it's now level material at
least temporarily but it will be the
black structure
comes Under Fire
um already that D6 spawned the Eternal
weakness in the benoni
and the son of Sorrow opening
it looks like GTX E5 is forced and and
uh yeah
F5 or does he want to go Knight D6 and
take back
that's a good question still spoil for
Choice some Knight C4 at the end
uh I finally positional approach but 96
might be the Tactical path to an
advantage
yeah something like this because I can't
take because either Knight C4
immediately or or taking followed by
Knight C4 and all the pieces are hanging
or Knight F5 as well there yeah tricky
nice yeah obvious nine F5 as well no
this just looks Dreadful
for
Rapport who is probably going to go down
uh so we could
we could really be seeing two of the top
four seeds losing uh in round two
Bishop Buffet is an ugly move uh maybe
it needed to be played but uh purely
defensive
and looks like sigirov yeah
pushing this Advantage he's going to be
a pawn up in a very very pleasant end
game but yeah you asked the question
Lawrence where should we go
um this one is going to go down to it
conversion phase now so maybe we can
move on and check back later
yes
where do you want to go anywhere in
particular I can see out the corner of
my eye
aravan's still just a piece up very easy
win
uh
what about Duda we haven't spoken much
about the answer stuff yet playing
with the black pieces here against Ralph
mahmedov
C5 just played by Ralph mahmedov
but the position
looks
uh
difficult to say the least for why does
it not I mean understatement Lawrence
Black's two pawns up right I know it's
triple pawns on the D file I had to do a
double take just to account there black
is two pawns up
and absolutely D3 Pawn especially that
D3 Pawn is going to be the winner
yeah it's hard to imagine why surviving
this one
yeah I can't see anyway
um for Mama Dove to fight back JKD as uh
he's being called there in the chat
does look like he has full control I
love the fact that he's planted his
Bishop on G6 a great defensive piece but
also protecting that D3 Pawn Max Knight
is ready to jump into E5 at some point
very well supported there
white can take a Pawn on D5 uh Bishop
takes D5 as possible but after black
plays D takes C5 suddenly all sorts of
things open up and
yeah as soon as position opens up it
will be that D3 Pawn again that decides
the game
alrighty
um another Superstar player who is going
to get a lot of attention is anishkiri
he'd just be uh Sean sargassian uh
he found a beautiful tactic hero move 35
look at this uh so I guess in trying to
get out of Dodge with King 2 H7 looks
bam Knight takes G7 always be aware of
discovered attacks the point is of
course that if King takes G7 y can play
Rook G3 check discovering the attack
against the queen and with that key G7
Pawn gone Black's King's position has
been opened up he tried giving off the
queen but actually didn't put up any
resistance after Queen's xc5 but I just
got way too much material lovely little
shot thereby and he's giri who of course
you know somehow he's not really in the
conversation
for winning this tournament right I mean
even when we looked at the top players
he his name didn't really pop up but
he's more than capable of of winning
this tournament he's got the talent is
he gonna have the nerves
and the psychological might
we'll soon see nevertheless Eric
uh the bar not liking Eric's position
Eric is an exchange down something has
gone wrong for Eric Hansen here
c49 C7 Bishop A5 by Magnus
yeah yeah
moving into the kill now Magnus yep
yeah and that we do see a result a
handshake Eric does resign and it was
just before we jump back into the game
actually that I think he made that
mistake giving up the exchange he didn't
need to and yeah we all know that giving
up uh material against Magnus
never works out well especially in the
end game he always seems to convert and
um yeah by now
um
Yeah by now I think Eric will be
regretting some of his earlier choices
but uh maybe we can rewind Lawrence just
to show the audience what happened
yeah I was uh just looking through it
looked as though he had everything kind
of under control
for a fair portion of this game we were
we were discussing it earlier I think
the opening went actually just fine for
her so I'm very curious where things
started to go very wrong and I think it
was really around here
um still feels as though black is is
fine he's got decent control and
coordination A5 mixing things up and I
think here the move C takes B5
could have been
uh the big the big problem here that
being said the position is is not easy
White's Bishops are suddenly coming to
life with the position being open the
black king
is slightly vulnerable so maybe it was
already getting difficult but already
around here after uh the next few moves
Eric complete lost his way takes takes
Bishop C4 and yeah now 93 giving up that
exchange uh not good enough because it's
just a full exchange
and again somebody like Magnus
um you're just gonna get punished you
you know it's it's just not enough
to uh to play like this
um and yeah Magnus made pretty light
worth of it towards the ends
yeah and uh meanwhile as we uh as we saw
Magnus won that game maybe we can go
back to richer report it looks critical
in that one right now
um what I mentioned earlier uh I
mentioned earlier that I thought was in
big trouble but he's bailed out into a
rook and Bishop versus Rook end game a
repeat of round one uh wow I mean he's
done well to survive this five I've got
to say reports and he is the master of
rook and Bishop versus Rook I remember
in the championship I think it was three
times in one tournament he had this
exact same ending but it was always
that's incredible inside
ah and now he has to show defense
exactly which is not easy
um this one could go on for a long time
50 moves but we just wanted to show the
top players they always know how to
survive they always know what to head
for and uh it would be a bit of a shock
maybe if he loses this one as he is very
experienced in this end game
absolutely yes we can certainly come
back to this I believe a little bit
later uh
uh aravind has yet to beat yeah napona
Sheikh I mean aravind is uh
a full piece to the good here got to be
a little bit careful that his Queen side
poems just don't disappear off the board
after which of course an opponership
would have some drawing chances but did
anyone see how that's possible
uh wonder what aravind is taking so long
over
in this position here
yeah it feels like the nerves are
kicking in the nerves are kicking in
Lawrence uh for arriving but he should
still be the favorite to win maybe we
can jump to Fabi uh we talked about him
build up to this game
and uh yeah it looks like a very
interesting battle in that one as well
you mentioned uh Armenian opponents
aren't necessarily a uh
kind of a strong uh strong point there
for Fabi with some mixed results in the
past that's uh yeah he's up against a
very underrated player and yeah I agree
with that in the chat that everyone
should be studying Rick and Bishop
versus Rook endings we've seen two
already today and it's only round two
but we'll see countless more uh
throughout the next five days and yeah
here Fabi has black here's a piece up
but white has a lot of Pawns
and Fabi is the first to create a threat
who takes G2 will be mate if why can't
fight can't find a defense
Rook G1
maybe there's nothing better the
question is can Fabi play a move such as
Bishop F1 is the black King 2 open can
you get away with that
if you don't create threats against the
white king then maybe white is just
about okay
okay
seven Queen C6 yeah this looks
kind of
one of those frustrating games that you
can play with black where you feel as
though a win should be imminent but
oftentimes it's not Queen E7
uh played and now how do we secure our
King a little bit more
between C8 saying
I don't want to commit
yeah it's a useful waiting move I'm I'm
surprised and also disappointed that
Fabi didn't go for the white king more I
feel he could have maybe put his Rook on
G7 kept his Queen and Rook there going
for that white king but now maybe white
will be able to trade off those Queen
side Pawns if the BNA pawns disappear it
feels like white is one step closer to
safety and Fabby says okay enough of the
fun Queens are coming off what do you
think Lawrence this one should be headed
towards the draw now
yeah I think Martin rosian's got really
good chances to make a draw now even
with the queen trade I I don't think
this ending is particularly dangerous
for why it takes takes takes Bishop
takes P5 and now I don't know H4 for the
time
yeah how are you ever supposed to win
yeah get that Rook active Rook B1 as
well
put the Rook on B2 King on H2 feels like
a fortress
um I mean worse comes to the West right
Lawrence you just trade off all the
pawns and you go Rook bishop and draw
that
so this is
for sure
okay
where else can we go
and uh meanwhile it looks like Duda did
take the win in his game yeah
yeah maybe we can check in on those
games we've already followed uh
yeah nepo okay still battling away
trying to complete that Miracle save
not sure he'll be able to but uh aravind
visibly nervous in that one let's catch
up with the current position
yep
so where are we never wrote excuse me
uh
we'll spoil for Choice we've got to say
so many fun exciting games going on
let's keep an eye on those favorites
well excuse me I've just got to refresh
the
okay yeah but it feels like this
position has been there forever
so there's some kind of issue with the
um transmission yes this this was here a
while ago so I don't know what's going
on
uh if we could go
to
okay
take the
no we're not getting the moves
very frustrating
yeah
these things often happen Let's uh maybe
zoom in on the player's cameras if we
can yeah uh just just to see if we can
visually see the uh 3D board and uh it
does look like aravind here oh he's only
down to one Pawn now Knight and pawn and
Rook against blacks rook and two Pawns
so uh they're probably actually getting
closer to a draw if the white one
disappears if it gets traded off Rooker
Knight versus Rook is a much easier draw
than rookie Bishop versus Rook so we
wouldn't see 50 moves of a long
difficult defense and it looks like
napoleonishi that sharp haircut that
fresh cut uh yeah he's working those
Miracles he's showing the tenacity to
save difficult end games
wow this is the story of the day so far
Nakamura getting out of jail
um in his game report potentially saving
a difficult position now naponishi this
is why the top players you have to knock
them down 10 20 times just to get that
point
and uh aravind nodding his head there
very low on the clock it feels like the
clock is costing nepot very very strong
foreign
yeah let's see two seconds just getting
the move in there aravind Rook A6 but
feels his own EPO I don't know it's
definitely gone in his favor the past
few moves
and I think nepo's gonna find a way to
make a draw the king now into G3 as well
Rook F6 check yeah the king now just
floats around you can't move the Knight
you lose the pawn
if you move the pawn nothing much is
going to happen it tries moving the king
but King between three and it looks as
though arabin is kind of coming to terms
with the fact that
really there is just no way
to
to operate here got to make sure not to
lose on time I wonder if nepo is being
slightly ambitious here because if he
forces the Knight to move
uh he can
of course it should be a draw regardless
but
with the clock situation
uh
he might try and get a bit ambitious but
it doesn't look like it you can see
aravan repeating here
yeah arvind is still advancing his King
he's still trying to create some
nuisance here but
there's nothing to do if White's King
ever steps forward to attack blackstroke
we'll see a rook trade and uh yeah the
game will just fizzle out immediately to
a drawer so I think we're in for a long
defense here the punishi should hold it
he's got rid of White's last Pawn we
will see that rookie Knight versus Rook
end game I mean she's smiling he knows
it will be a draw eventually he knows
how to defend it
um Lawrence maybe we can switch back uh
let's do that wondering whether the
report is defending that rook and Bishop
versus Rook end game for example I'm
talking of those long grinds
I I believe I believe Rapport is
defending
uh this I mean it's just a standard rook
and Bishop versus Rook quick update on
some of the results uh from the top
boards Brunello did lose with white so I
mean Mase did not win against our Timmy
if he lost
uh with the white piece
of David one of the games that you were
saying could be an eggshell for feather
save
but looks as though he has come through
you yangi has also wonder all the
favorites so far Magnus Carlson
all the favorites coming through at the
moment
yeah so um other than other than
Carolina who has just drawn
um maybe reporting upon this year as
well it looks like all the favorites
yeah just doing the business
it is surprising to me because they had
some shaky positions some of the top
guys top rated players but
that's why they're uh I guess that's why
they're the best they always find a way
and it's not about winning pretty in
these rapid games it's about grinding
out those results
as we see report grinding out trying to
get that draw in the end
lacks King still dancing not forced to
the edge of the board
and uh yeah I think Rapport he's done
his homework he's probably studied this
for hundreds of hours this [ __ ]
Bishop versus hurricane game and it all
pays off in the end
yeah I think so especially
uh recently
uh quick update on the women's session
we will take a look at some of the
women's games from round three
so far some
well stalwarts of the game on full marks
agnitzel
all on Twitter too as is tan jean ji uh
she's doing just fine
uh hampi
uh uh you know
class player Class Act
definitely should always be in the mix
especially I would say for the rapid
tournament I think she's probably a bit
stronger rapid than she is a blitz
a good result van zatinski holding
harika with the white pieces and good
result also for Lily mature who managed
to hold the draw against
which will uh be a slight surprise the
rest of the games have gone to form
so no big changes there
all right
we are watching this rook and Bishop
game
um
I would love to see
uh
the actual updated position of arabin
but it's just not possible
for the moment let's go somewhere else
what about Sam shankland
playing as manual petrosium what that is
not a game we need to concern ourselves
with
that isn't that easy
to win
have you set her off
is also
uh it's just very calmly on two out of
two
I believe
it looks like he has won a very nice
game there again Abdul satoroff
just great technique he looks like the
guy uh again to beat
still slightly lower rated compared to
the likes of Magnus Hikaru but just as
dangerous
and yeah we're having to scroll quite a
way down to find some surprises uh it
looks like Andre esepenko is about to
lose uh to Dem chenko
let's go down demchenko with uh yeah a
lot of material up
yeah asapenko again another one of those
young underdogs that I thought might
cause some damage might go far in this
tournament but
um damchenko who's also dangerous also
underrated uh taking the point in this
game
yeah absolutely
yeah I mean we are in the final stages
of round two so a lot of kind of quiet
to end games a lot of grinding going on
as players try to eke out those extra
half points
um Lawrence maybe we can stick to one of
these end games uh see the technique by
the top players
which
game let's see here uh I mean
let's see if uh Shigeru managed to put
any pressure on at all with this rook
and Bishop pluses
Rook
um
I know how much you love the same game
Lawrence let's get academic about it
well because Plex King is nearly in the
corner yeah Black's black is
uh I don't think Richard has done too
well here
it doesn't matter it's still a draw but
uh
shugirov is managing to slowly escort
this King to the side of the board and
is it now impossible to set up a second
ranked defense here
maybe rookie Jade is a good move
yeah there's two ways two ways to defend
this end game one is to check from afar
and as long as you place your King on
the right squares it should be
sufficient so I think that's what report
is going for the second rank defense as
you say to put the Rook on second or the
seventh rank or the G or b files that's
also good enough but okay I like what
sukiro's doing he stopped any checks
from the BlackRock white king nicely
centralized
but uh Rapport can still continue trying
to check from AFI there we go this is
Rook on H7 trying to swing across
the problem is Black's King is near the
corner but not near enough so it does
take three or four very helpful moves
from black to allow that King to be
pushed right onto the side
and uh there we go asking questions with
the check
so you get off at not making any
progress
yeah I think this is one of the games to
study if you want to learn how to defend
with just a rook against a rook and
Bishop
and yeah it feels like from the body
language as well sugar off isn't feeling
too confident he played that last move
very slowly looking at the clock
admitting defeaters in his attempts to
win it is a draw
yeah doesn't even bother trying to
uh push us through three more rounds
today once the conserve his energy
okay
let's check out Jordan first
wow very cool very difficult Rook end
game here for black to defend Jordan on
the front foot that white epon will it
win the game
do you know your endgame Theory Lawrence
well I mean here it looks as though
he has got a winning position
but uh something went wrong around here
all right
I mean this position is a classic one
without the pawn on A6 but with the pawn
on E6
I guess it actually helps why because it
limits the scope
of Black's Rook so what
this move is seven possibly was
a mistake
yeah maybe the idea is that you you
should now take on A6 and uh black
cannot really continue the checks your
simple plan is to go King D7 and E7
and uh
suddenly for example if Rook hhack King
D7 Rook H7 E7 comes with check White's
Pawn uh steps out of the way discover
check and you're guaranteed to win now
so maybe Jordan just uh yeah missed that
one moment got a bit impatient pushing
his pawn and
suddenly if we catch up with the game uh
the game position he has one black spawn
but he's allowed Blacksburg to come
around and check on the long side uh
Black's Rook is going to check from A7
from A8 and this is a very well known
draw now a few moves ago black didn't
really have the ideal defensive
formation but
yeah it's uh it's a slip from Jordan it
looks like he's now heading hands he's
realizing
that there's no weight through for white
black and just wait on the eighth rank
and in order to guard against checks you
have to put the white Rook on some bad
squares
okay
it's going to be a draw yeah this this
looks like it's gonna be drawn I promise
she did magically just like we saw
Hikaru Nakamura do in round one draw
that game against aravind
uh here
okay
and now
oh oh
what has happened here wow what has
happened
miracles do happen he just
foreign
oh no look at this in this position here
after King D6 black just had to repeat
with the move Rook A8
and now you've got the long side but he
went King F6 missing the beautiful rugby
one another point is off to Rook 67
simply Rook F1 check and we win the rook
and now after Rook B1 there's nothing to
be done Rook F1 check and now the shake
of the head by cedipoff who is disgusted
with himself Grandmaster should not be
making this mistake what an awful
blunder
by the black player here The Grandmaster
playing Black understands now that his
position is toast and in fact we look at
the position on the board Rook A1 and
you can't capture the long side here and
Jordan is after going to show he's gonna
have to show queen versus queen and king
versus King and Rook
um
and relatively easy
conversion would you say avid
uh I would say yes um it's also
extremely hard to defend the Rook on
safe squares especially in Rapid chess
I've tried playing this one against the
computer I will say queen versus rook
and it's incredibly hard to win because
computers always find a way to put their
Rooks on squares they can never be
captured by double attacks by checks and
so maybe some uh some work to be done
for Jordan but in human terms it's
extremely difficult to defend I think
he's already got his king and queen on
some great squares and black has no
checks right now right this one should
just be a matter of time but I want to
say as well that Rook end game it was a
cautionary tale as you mentioned never
put your Rook on a passive Square
um as mentioned in the chat here by Namo
s it's literally in uh the classic book
100 end games you must know that trick
um that's black felfer to allow this end
game and Jordan will slowly start
closing the door he'll slowly start
finding those checks and uh well
he almost put his Queen on a square
could be attacked but
um
yeah and eventually black will find
himself in zuk Swang uh often white
there are actually nice ways to
triangulate the White Queen you give
your opponent the move and yeah black
has no safe squares for the Rook this
one yeah I think Jordan's found the
winning technique already
and
yeah I can't see this one turning yet
again it's already turned a few times
since we've joined at this end game went
from winning to drawn to winning but it
won't change again
Comcheck
do you think he could be someone to uh
kind of upset the apple cart Lawrence to
there was a title Jordan
huge fan of Jordan spent some time with
him in the summer this year in Spain
um lovely kid
I say kid but he is still very young in
his early 20s
um
uh very very it's like it's been around
forever yeah he has been around forever
because he's just been such a genius
youngster uh but uh
you know his big breakthrough coming
when he won the vikan say Tata Steel
Championship uh has obviously worked
with Magnus as many people no
um just a very very talented
young player and
uh definitely is capable
of winning this tournament and putting
the final touches on here another Shake
of the head all right
who understands his task is now
pretty much
uh hopeless
and queen defrocheck
might just end it actually
I've got to give praise to Queen H5 that
quiet move just to create that Zig Swang
and now Black's King no matter where it
goes would have been attacked uh there
would have been a double attack hitting
the black Rook as well they're up too
far from his King so there was the Anish
giri a nice touch as well congratulating
uh his countrymen or maybe asking about
the game it looks like Gary is pointing
out a quicker win uh to Jordan there but
uh yeah some nice camaraderie between
the two
foreign
yeah well they're very good friends of
course as well and
uh to be expected a bit of banter from
Anish
I believe we are going to now go for a
short pause
uh we'll come back shortly with a
summary of what happened but no major
upsets in that round as far as I can see
Carlson beating Hanson a few escapes yet
again Rapport and the punishing were
both in terrible shape but they are top
players for a reason they are extremely
resilient and make both survive we'll be
back in a few minutes where we will then
of course be looking at Ground three
five rounds today plenty more chests
don't go anywhere
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
edible emotions from the first date the
first expensive things you bought when
you got your first paycheck and your
first Investments with freedom broker
Freedom broker look at your favorite
brands from A New Perspective
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
this is round three of the world rapid
championships of course part of the
world rapid and Blitz championships
taking place in almatic Kazakhstan uh
this year we've seen a bunch of actions
so far and well what we've really seen
are a bunch of escapes by some of the
top players some of the top players
under real pressure early on thinking
Nakamura in round one and in the last
round we just saw in the publishing was
dead to rights managed to escape as did
Rickard Rapport so the top guys hanging
in there by the skin of their teeth
I'm once again of course joined by The
One and Only Grandmaster David Howe
Olympic gold medalist
uh and very very cool guy
uh David uh we're gonna take a look now
at pairings for round three who do you
fancy coming up in the open section
and uh yet again Lawrence well first of
all thanks for the kind words but uh yet
again we do see some massive games
tomaszewsky against Carlson tomaszewsky
uh he feels like he's been a 2700 Grand
Master for the last 15 years or so he's
going to be very difficult to beat Duda
against Bluebell bluebound the reigning
European Champion that's not going to be
easy either uh Yu Yan Yi shimanov that's
a very strong Russian player there
um I mean it's stacked I'm personally
looking at a pairing such as donchenko
against Gary because I really want to
see players such as Anish giri push on
uh after this great start and we do have
I think 22 players on 100 after two
rounds so okay not that many from such a
big field and it will be about kind of
positioning yourself after day one in
those top positions you can't really win
the tournament on day one of course but
you can put yourself in position and
yeah all of these guys uh that we see on
the top 10 boards right now they will be
wanting to continue uh their good form
shout out especially to Anish giri and
Yoda van Forest the Dutch are the best
by test
um or something along those lines
um obviously very good friends that were
chatting after that game Jordan will be
very happy to have converted got a tough
game now against cinderov and other
Superstar from the Uzbek uh Olympic team
and in the women's section we can see
that
well the portrait of a lonely figure
Olga guria
waiting on board one she's about to play
tan zhangi uh Olga though a fantastic
player in her own right uh certainly
capable of beating tan we've got gong
against agnita
on board two and we've got Canada Nova
uh who beat uh Lala Yaki lushfili
actually in the last round playing White
against humpy canuro Valentina goonie
not on board for uh class player
Valentina when she's on form playing
against fatalieva and Vivaldi with that
great win in round one against Bella
continent and then beating
matzevskaya also Imran too so we have
all showing some real form early on
those games are going to be very very
interesting indeed as we can see the
camera pan
around the playing hole looks like it's
a I don't know the exact uh
where they are playing it looks like a
basketball court or something like that
perhaps or an indoor Stadium of sorts
yeah I mean it looks very Grand there
all the players in one hall or the flags
uh around of course and I mean I've
played in plenty of these types of
venues myself I've always enjoyed it I
always found it a bit intimidating with
so many cameras
um so many fans around how about
yourself Lawrence do you think the
players there
enjoying the venue are they embracing
the yeah at the moment I I think so
because also one thing that I know they
will like is the space having space
between the tables is nice when you're
all hunched up it's not that great I
remember
um a few years ago in Berlin did you
play the Berlin World rapid and Blitz
you might have been there actually I I
know unfortunately
I also missed it but from what I
understood and from what I saw it was
all quite you know there wasn't that
much space so I think with such ample
space for everybody they'll be happy
uh to be there looks as though uh it
doesn't look too hot there either we've
got we can see Olga girio there with a
with a scarf on uh of course complaints
of uh playing all being too hot is often
brutal
uh so we can see that and tanjongji
sporting the face mask
um
not necessarily an indication that
there's anything wrong with her but I
would say more in Asian culture
certainly they do tend to wear the face
masks voluntarily
um yeah you you mentioned the
temperature Lawrence and it's minus
eight outside minus eight degrees
Celsius outside in Almaty very cold
we've seen some of the players uh I
think they were skiing they were out in
the snow and the run-ups of the event
um so hence the scarves I guess
but uh yeah as you say the tournament
Hall it's a nice luxury maybe that's the
biggest difference from maybe amateur
tournaments to professional tournaments
you could kind of the higher up the
ranking list you go the more space you
get
your boards during the games and just in
the background there as well we do see
tomashevsky waiting for Magnus to arrive
and they are off
looks like aka the professor
he's called the professor for a reason
um and that reason being that he's
uh a scientist uh when it comes to the
game of chess
uh very very sort of precise player
doesn't like big messes at all on the
board you very rarely see Thomas
Jefferson are too wild and wacky and and
weird of course he's more than capable
of playing those positions as well but
he likes a more systematic approach
and um certainly
uh you know he you mentioned David you
feel like he's been 27 under 15 years he
has been 2700 for 15 years I played
you've ten you've gained so much in the
world championships uh when we were both
18 with the same age
um he was already extremely strong then
but he has literally been he never quite
made it to the 2750 level but he's been
just a solid 27 10 27 20 player for 15
20 years of very
uh sort of uh the sort of guy you would
want on your team in a team event if you
need some points because you know he's
going to get them
Magnus
wow uh we have got uh it looks like a
modern opening Magnus game with one G6
against thomaszewsky's 1v4 and Thomas
keep playing principally and actually
taking the center here with E4 now David
you I've mentioned this a few times of
course you have been the person who is
covered Magnus the most over the past
few years because of the uh notewater
Championship tour and
um I will say his success with the perk
or the modern in that tournament for me
it's been absolutely shocking especially
is dismantling of Eric Gacy like
numerous times with black just destroyed
him how does he do it how does that
happen
Magnus is unique he's a phenomenon we
know that he could do stuff that nobody
else in the world can get away with and
yeah it feels like in a way he's been
freestyling Magnus as we see there he's
just pushing pawns to the sixth rank not
really committing just staying really
flexible and uh he called it himself in
an interview uh anti-young player chess
and of course tamashovski is not a young
player thomaszewsky's even a few years
older than Magnus but
um I think the idea is to just stay
clear of opening theory that is after
all where 90 of time is spent by a lot
of players these days they know how to
study the opening they have plenty of
resources they look at it with a
computer and these types of positions
that we will be about to see in this
game there's no way to memorize them
there's no way to
predict exactly what your opponent will
do every turn black has five or six
different uh options on every move
therefore a bunch of different move
orders and we see Magnus again not
bringing out his Knights not really
committing his Bishops he's essentially
asking his opponents tomasheski in this
case what are you gonna do are you
feeling brave if you come at me you'll
leave yourself open to counter attack
and if you just play too slowly too
passively you might get punished later
on that mindset that mentality will
endure for the rest of the game and
Magnus likes his opponents to show
weakness he likes them to show respect
to him we call that the Magnus effect
and uh yeah it's that's I guess Lawrence
the long-winded answer to your question
why magnus's experienced so much success
with this opening it's because often his
opponents are just thrown into unknown
territory they've never faced this type
of uh not necessarily opening before
this approach before and uh therefore
they're just caught in two minds to
attack to defend here tomashevsky just
playing very quickly
um just very kind of classically
developing his pieces and uh Magnus I
think he'll be pretty happy with how
things are going I think if I'm not
mistaken we're looking at the board here
the um the digital uh transmission isn't
quite coming up yet but we're looking at
the board I think he's going for the
hippo a setup where black just wallows
within the sixth seventh and eighth
ranks just waiting for the opponent to
get ambitious to Lunge forward and then
the hippo will strike and uh yeah Magnus
putting his Knights on E7 D7 in front of
his king and queen just kind of curling
up into a ball and yeah this is the type
of approach that pays off in Blitz chess
bullet chess because you can kind of
almost pre-move your first uh moves as
black but in a rapid game this is risky
strategy what do you think Lawrence uh
is this something that will work against
the professor
well I think it's a very good try
because as I said I don't think uh that
uh
uh you know uh tomashewsky loves these
slightly unorthodox structures and these
unorthodox positions and of course just
want to confirm guys if we haven't got
the games just yet in uh in our PGN
format so bear with us and we'll keep
with the the uh the main uh main camera
here
um
so
I think that uh you know uh
this is a very decent opening Choice by
by Magnus effectively
um yeah I don't I don't mind this choice
at all actually
by Magnus Carlson I think it's I think
it's very very adhesive
and he's already forced his opponent to
think tomaszewski went into the tank for
a minute or so there uh bringing his
Bishop out and Lawrence you also
mentioned earlier uh in the in the day
Magnus often does get off to slow starts
that is his Achilles heel in these
longer tournaments these longer formats
takes him a while to get the engine
going to move up the gears but this
tournament he's already started with two
wins out of two is that ominous for his
rivals
Magnus is he looking uh in the flow
already
well I I'm not entirely entirely sure uh
I I don't think it looks ominous I think
people just expect people uh Magnus to
to do well so whether he's got one and a
half out of two two out of two it's
gonna be kind of the crunch rounds in
the middle that are going to be crucial
so I I don't think people are worrying
too much about what Magnus is doing you
have to worry about yourself at the end
of the day
um and
uh
yeah like I I don't think it's such a
big deal basically at this stage it's
just far too early
I think world world Blitz Championship a
few years ago where Magnus started with
zero out of two and uh he did later on
uh catch up of course and
uh get in the medals but hey we do see
some quick moves Magnus did set up with
the hippo he's starting to advance pawns
forward bringing his Knight forward now
I think we will jump into the Crux of
the game later uh when things do reach
their climax but all 32 pieces on the
board and that in itself is uh I think a
small win in terms of the opening it's
like you said Lawrence no matter what
the opening Madness will be fine he
knows his stuff he knows the strategy
where the pieces belong but it's about
getting a position that his opponent is
uncomfortable with and tomashevsky I'm
not saying he won't like White's
position uh we will see that in a moment
but
um yeah it's maybe just again something
he's not familiar with it's not his
comfort zone necessarily it's not
something that they teach in the Russian
School of Chess
an area where he's very educated
yeah I mean he's he's definitely a
classic
uh you know
a Class A Classic uh
what's the word a student of the gang no
doubt about it
absolutely no doubt about it
um
so let's see
well Magnus there castling with this
last move and
um one thing I've learned from playing
the hippo is that you very rarely Castle
or if you do it's got to be when your
opponent commits on the other side of
the board and I've got to say the
opening Madness is playing right now
that's my main bullet repertoire when I
play bullet on chess.com for example I
nearly always play the hippo because you
can remove the first eight moves and uh
you are very flexible you react to what
your opponent's doing Tom rashevsky just
putting his pieces on centralized
squares and
in a way that's allowing Magnus to
dictate the game it feels like
tomaszewsky is just waiting waiting
waiting yet to exchange pieces yet to
open up and tomashesky is an end game
expert as well when I've played him uh
which has been on occasion uh well
especially when we were younger he was
always the grindy type of player as you
said risk averse but uh extremely kind
of focused on the small details here you
can't really focus too much on the small
details you have to play with a grander
plan in mind
and um yeah we'll see yes you do when we
do get those Transmissions back we'll
see a few of the plans that Tom
rashevsky will have to have to go for if
he wants to win this game
and uh yeah meanwhile maybe we can make
some predictions Lawrence uh we didn't
yes happy to do that happy to do that
um
without property being able to see this
position obviously
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna go with for a
Magnus win because it just feels like I
can see a knight on G6 Pawn on G5
yeah typical Magnus kind of uh
uh sort of uh
what's the word I'm looking for showman
showman position actually we have
managed I believe to get some moves in
so we might
only the women's event well let's do
that I'm going to go for a Magnus win
there we'll do some predictions a bit
later on
um and
uh let's go to the women's section for
really the the uh you know the first
time we're gonna have a proper look at
some of the games there uh looking at
these games I
have to say hmm
well they're all actually very tight
let's go to Olga geario against
tanjongshi
we had a queen's gamber declined
yeah yeah a very typical position here
they're still theoretical as far as I
know you mentioned Queen's Gambit
decline but the center has exploded and
uh right now Black's Bishop has just
retreated it's up to White do you
centralize the Rooks if you push a pawn
forward in the center maybe lock things
up a bit more uh olgaria has played for
the Russian team for
10 or more years now for experience in
tanzongi really at the peak of her
career on a high in the candidates final
and yeah this is going to be a really
interesting Clash
I do feel that this type of position is
easier to play with white from my
experience you just centralize the Rooks
and
very worst comes to the worst you tend
to kind of get a position with
symmetrical Pawn structure with no risk
but uh yeah what do you think Lawrence
um at this yeah stage there are 14
leaders and these two uh could be some
of the favorites for the rest of the
event
yeah I mean it's again one of these I
think although the women's section is
slightly shorter in terms of
the length uh
you are getting it the main names up
there I I find it
um in the I find it more difficult to
believe that there's going to be a
complete Outsider in the women's section
to to win Dark Horses tend not to come
through
um just because the experience of the
top players and the Gap in skill level
is is just much greater I believe so for
example if you look at Canary
and so on even when Abu asareva won she
wasn't a true Outsider because you know
she was already 2400 plus you know for
example for for a 2350 player to win
this for example somebody like Alina
bivol she started off great but if she
were to win I would be in shock because
the the true the true strength of of
these players do does tend to show a bit
more in my opinion as the rounds go on
um as for this particular game yeah I
mean Olga also she's classical she's got
to hurry up a bit I think black is all
right though
uh to be honest I think I I mean I I'm
not even sure I would take white here
uh it's not completely clear to me yeah
you can bring your Rooks in but I'm not
that enamored with with White's position
here
um so yeah I don't know David
um
yeah and we might have our first
disagreement of the day Lawrence I do
yes enjoy White's uh chances in these
types of positions I think we've had a
couple weeks
uh it did look like tanzong you just
brought the black queen into the center
um are we on the current position
uh uh no white White Knight has jumped
to C4 no we're we're a bit far away and
we're not getting the moves
through uh
uh it seems at the moment
uh we're gonna try and get a refresh but
it seems as though we're having some
issues with the moves coming through so
we will just have a look at this bird's
eye view of the board
still looks as though tanjoshi is
probably all right
yeah and one thing that I think really
makes Tanzania stand out apart from her
tactical Vision
um is the it's just her Focus she's
always looking for resources I played
her in gibrato once and uh yeah she's
just barely leaves the board her eyes
never leave the board and
um even on her path to the candidate's
final this year when she uh she won a
very difficult knockout phase uh even
then she she was in trouble in many
games but she found those resources and
again that's a key ingredient when
winning world titles especially in the
rapping Blitz you will run into tough
positions whether it's this game whether
it's the next few rounds you will run
into trouble at some point and she's the
type of player that will be hard to
knock down so even if Olga with white
tier is able to obtain an advantage in
the opening hands on you won't Flinch
she won't worry too much about that and
uh it is her taking the big think and
throwing a pawn forward we will again
try to get that position back a bit
later but it's just looking very messy
look at the middle of the board there
lots of pieces lots of action and
yeah I think result
will be decided in that kind of time
scramble a bit later on in a tactical
melee where tanzani does thrive
and um we do see in the background of
this picture as well yuyangi against
shimanov on that left side and I think
that's humpy koneru on the right side
playing against Carmel lidenova so some
big names on the top boards
and
Lawrence what do you think should we
stick here for a while should we
maybe take a look around
um
we we can definitely uh move around a
little bit for sure yes
uh
let's see
what we've got
um
started yeah we could do some
predictions uh
okay so tomashewsky Carlson
I said zero one
what do you think
I will trust in the professor I will say
a draw I think uh Magnus yes he's on
fire but uh it's gonna be difficult with
black
to be someone so solid
okay
uh yeah should we go to that Michael's
game yeah I think we can go to that
Magnus game
yeah we do see them on the camera right
now so just uh to the left of the game
we uh we were at a moment ago in the
background this time we can see jul
musad the French champion on the left
facing off against fedes and there we
have it we have the moves we have the
board
uh Thomas right with black
yeah and and
thoughts Lawrence on the position yeah
just a typical kind of hedgehogy
perk where
you know you have to decide as white
whether you want to commit in the center
uh with E5 or D E5
um
timing that is actually
fairly important very important in fact
um
and a lot of the time you don't want to
make a committed decision so you know
Thomas Jefferson Place Queen into
queenings who's actually guarding
against Knight H5 as well this Knight
was also potentially coming to H5 to
then come into F4
so Queenie to has that concept
uh
so
does it feel like a small loss of time
though for white Lawrence because White
Queen had already moved
a little bit a little bit yes but I
don't think that time is such a big
thing in this position I mean
sort of jostling for position feels like
what you should be doing a lot with
white I think it's worse to over commit
to an idea prematurely
uh then you know just trying to find
some harmony with your pieces but I also
don't think that objectively that
magnus's position is that bad so Queen
D7 has just been played and now for
example does the movie E5 actually make
any sense here
yeah
because
I mean
now with the queen on the queen D7 feels
like an odd move to me
doesn't that move feel a bit strange to
you
it feels very strange but there is a key
variation here potentially Lawrence and
I think Magnus has a tactical idea in
mind so if white does for example lose
patience and Russia for porn forward in
the center maybe E5 as you said then
black can take on E5 and after a
recapture put the queen on C6
get out of that attack on the D file and
uh yeah suddenly white struggles to
defend uh
93 how much does he struggle
yeah maybe 93 but then 97 you have to do
some oh Knight F4 wow um no I mean
that's Alicia very quiet now yeah
but 97 I'm I'm cute I wanna
I wanna put I want to put a bishop D3
which would be four uh Bishop B3 1965
Queen H5 924
yeah we're not in this game's reports
yeah but we might find the answer to
these questions because tomashewsky has
indeed pushed E5 so right now for the
first time there was intention we're
about to see some exchanges some tactics
Magnus does go for this variation he
does grab a pawn uh on E5 asking uh for
lines to open up trying to get his Queen
to C6 creating some trackmate threats
and I think only now tomaszewsky pauses
because he realizes what is about to
come so we will see that position we
analyzed a moment ago up here
do you take C5 you have to be consistent
here with why you can't change your plan
now
Queen C6 looks almost forced Queen C6 93
yep defending G2 I think white has to
play Knight E3 if you play F3 for
example it's very ugly you leave some
holes in your position and Knight H5
will happen like you said earlier it's
jumping in
some key squares
so Queen C6 on the board
is 93. hmm
tomashevsky will play Knight E3
no question about it
far to the professor
well I mean it's pretty much the only
move that's
that's the other thing I mean you either
go F3 allow Knight H5 or you play 93 so
93 will be played I'm just sure of it
and we have to find a uh convincing
answer I do like that uh that message
from Nintendo Nintendo a moment ago
finally they're choosing violence I
think Magnus is taking massive risks
here after 93 but yeah we're yet to find
a solution uh to the attack on blacks
Knight and F6 apparently the engine
thinks white is much better according to
Antoine in the chat
yeah it's looking dangerous yeah this
doesn't matter like E3 Lawrence
doesn't surprise me at all that white is
much better here
and summer shivsky will play this move I
think he's calculating what to do
against 94 actually Knight D7 just feels
wrong to me
um
you know
yeah although you are attacking E5 so
white has to be very quick it's quite an
urgent situation
um yeah you have to defend E5
it's not so easy white has a bunch of
ideas but it's very much recovery
calculation
is a bit low on the clock right now
yeah so 97 94 black has options but
tomashevsky needs to move you need to
speed up
and he does play that move but after
almost two minutes and yeah he could
have played that move instantly like you
said Lawrence it was clearly the best
move by process of elimination
uh yes but uh he was probably just
uh you know making sure that after F3
Knight H5 that things simply were not
that great
um
okay wow what
Bishop B5 your move
but why I don't get it takes takes you
just want to take down here David and
win a pawn and be is this what it's come
to is this how we play chess yeah this
isn't how we used to play chess
it is greedy black does have the bishop
pass compensation E5 will fall but yeah
I'm curious what the engine thinks of
this one
um is this good for white White's
rookies on the seventh household you are
pulling up albeit a double Pawn on the B
file but white Knights are ready to
spring forward to G4 Black's Queen
doesn't have too many safe squares right
there's a lot of pros and cons in the
columns for both players
wow like D7 by Magnus it feels like he's
not bluffing necessarily but taking
massive risks he knows that if he wins
this one with black
uh he'll yeah he'll have another white
in the next game he's got a chance to
rack up a huge score on day one of the
tournament
I mean I find this
very odd all of it
um nevertheless okay 97
let's see I I think tomashevsky is the
sort of player to play Bishop B5 here
though I do think that that's his kind
of way of playing a bit of clarity an
extra bit of material
it doesn't look
too messy after that
um
I don't know
uh and
Lawrence I've got to say I'm being told
that Bishop Bishop B5 is the only move
that maintains an advantage for white
wishes
it's a bit of a surprise because white
as you mentioned can play Bishop D3 can
uh I mean there's a bunch of moves you
can consider but Bishop B5 it is a two
move tactic so it's definitely going to
be on tamashevsky's radar uh he will be
able to calculate that one easily it's
just about the assessment like you said
maybe we can put that on the board
um after the Knight is captured on D7
how do you evaluate that position do you
see that even after black takes on E5
for example with the Knight do you see
that white still is in charge because
actually aesthetically it looks like
black bishops are coming to life black
has won the pawn back maybe the white
Rook on D7 will have to step back at
some point but it must come down to
tactics maybe taking on E5 for example
some Knight G4 ideas maybe the black
king is actually a big Target
and uh okay Queen takes E5 very clever
move that stopping Knight G4 or at least
deterring uh any Knight jumps maybe
Queen D3 check the attack continues
yeah I don't see it yeah I I don't see
it either to be honest but this is the
position tomashewsky is kind of trying
to process in his mind right
and he does go for it it should be five
on the board
I I I just don't see it
okay yeah
we will get an answer this uh the beauty
of Rapid chess we don't have to wait too
long for those answers
we will brilliant
fantastic
Knight takes E5 is again okay cool if
black doesn't take that pawn
surely white is better the White Knight
Will land on G4
Rook D2
camera or just going back
no this is this is not you can't Retreat
surely you can't retreat oh no no
it takes takes there are what means way
to attack that black queen
C4 is clever hitting C7
that white knight in E3 is pinned
however
Lawrence what do you think yeah I mean
rug C8 Rook A1 maybe is what what it's
trying to
to be played here but it feels very
uh
uh uh sort of uh
artificial
for what yeah
yeah because long term black is the one
in charge right
Bishops like as the better Pawn
structure
so it's all about Dynamics and you did
mention that that's not the strongest
point of Thomas's game necessarily no
no Route 67 is on the board
uh and I'm very curious to see what
happens after either Bishop's 85 or
Knight takes C5
which will be played
one of those two surely because if black
takes time out plays Rook da tries to
evict that white Rook on D7
then maybe just a simple trait a simple
exchange on d8 White Tonight landing on
G4 will spell the end of Black's counter
play what's not in G4 will just contain
everything protect E5
yeah you have to take this Pawn now as
much you have to take this it's just
there's just no way he's not taking this
plot
I'm just curious which way he's gonna
actually take it that's that's the
Curious Thing
yeah would you take this uh let's assume
that Magnus knows he's slightly worse
would you take this position but three
minutes extra on the clock or would you
uh take tamashevsky here
slightly better position maybe your
chances dynamically but three minutes
down on the clock
I think I take Magnus because I think
even though we can see the computer
prefers White
uh intuitively it doesn't
feel at all better for white
and if the advantage is only sort of
plus one that it's giving I think I
would take the three minutes because I
think there's still an extraordinary
fight left in this position
uh I'm very curious what what Magnus is
going to decide here
down to two minutes now uh his time
Advantage is disappearing and like you
say it's intuitively difficult for white
the moves for example that Queen C4 that
we mentioned in that variation is not
obvious swinging weights Rook across to
A1 that you showed a moment ago that is
not obvious it's
it does take some really creative ideas
uh just to keep up the initiative you
have to keep pedaling keep up the
momentum with white otherwise you're
just suffering in a strategically
difficult position so if I'm a Magnus I
would have just taken this Pawn to be
honest and just crossed my fingers and
hoped and prayed that I was okay also
passing the move back to tomashevsky
who's been very slow over the last few
turns but
yeah critical moments will happen very
shortly
Magnus he's about to reach looks like
he's about to make a move his hand is
twitching
and he does take that pawn with his
Bishop as you mentioned this was an
option because now if there is a trade
Black Knight leaps into the center
exactly
I think Mission 65 is is perfectly
reasonable no I actually prefer black
here this is the weird thing I mean I
think I would take black out of just a
preference
uh obviously I'm seeing here that the
evaluation it says it's better for white
but I don't fully understand I
understand the Rook is only seven I
understand the black king is slightly
weak but I've got activity
and queen C4
might be a great move by Tom moshevsky
very clever move
his style as well right getting the
Queens off simplifying uh the position
simplifying his plans C7 is the target
yeah suddenly Bishop takes E5 if you
have to part with the bishop pairs black
strategically it's not that dominant
anymore
and uh I did appreciate in the chat a
few people were saying yeah the
initiative is not obvious for white but
at least now you have a plan you just
want to trade off Queens you want to win
the C7 Pawn
exactly I'm a great move by tomaszewsky
and he he was thinking about that one
while Magnus was in attack
yes he was
there's also Queen Tech C6 which
actually exists in some lines because
Bishop CA Rook takes F7 exists so
actually Queen takes E6
uh is actually a threat right
yeah I thought F7 Pawn is pinned yeah
very clever threat I must admit my
eyesight was directed purely on the C7
Pawn tunnel vision but uh tomaszewsky
yeah I love Queen C4 I've got to say
it's not an obvious move actually
instantly drawn towards trading pieces
but uh he's done it on his own terms and
Magnus at least now I think we can start
to understand why he might be on the
back foot if the Queen's come off if the
dark Square bishops come off
white might win a pawn
yeah
down on time
are we gonna get our first little mini
upset so far
results possible for sure
and look at magnus's body language
they're looking away looking up to the
skies seeking inspiration he's I don't
think he's found a move he's happy with
a reply here
and I can't see a decent reply for black
either
um for example if black takes the white
Bishop on G3
white might flick in the Intermezzo and
trade off Queens immediately and
yeah suddenly C7 C5 a week record D7 is
monstrous
yeah not easy at all to suggest
what Magna should be doing hence why
he spent a couple of minutes here
and your idea of taking that E6 Pawn is
really relevant here Lawrence maybe if
Queen takes Queen we can show this one
last variation while Magnus Ponders and
after Queen takes Queen the Knight
recaptures
after Bishop takes G3 F takes G3 white
is not just threatening C7 but also
threatening Rook takes E6 in some line
so for example if Rook C8 defending the
C7 Pawn then
bang Rook takes C6 wins on
yeah um fighting for his life
really is
um yeah great calculation Now by
tomashesky
Magnus now under two minutes
I have a feeling we might see a big
shock not just a draw in this game I
think we might see tomashewsky take it
Magnus normally when I've seen him when
he plays rapid chess if he tanks for
this long it means he knows he's in
trouble and often mistakes come because
he's trying to force the issue too much
precisely we will see
Bishop C8 wow unexpected attacking The
Rook
but feels use slow
yeah but also logical right he's trying
to The Rook on these seven was recording
causing Magnus huge problems
um
so now yeah tomorrow will take he will
bring the Rope back
I think he might take on C7 Lawrence I
think he might sacrifice The Exchange
that looks wow
giving up some material but look at that
white B5 Pawn it's just gonna run
through surely
wow
So You Wanna Give Up The Exchange
and then you what you're saying is if
the bishop ever comes here you want to
put the Knight on C4
put the phone on B6 and just push
wow disease as well
shocked if you place that
I mean it's so tempting to me retreating
oh okay he doesn't go for that he
sacrifices in a different way though
similar way all right and okay maybe
just as good the B5 Pawn now is pushing
forward
box Bishop will be able to block maybe
on some light squares Knight F4 by
Magnus
what's he doing how's he seeking Council
play
surely just I mean 94 maybe the answer
is Knight D5 black wants to give back
some material just to swap off pieces
and yeah I mean it's hanging by a thread
Black's position strategically but he is
material up
long term
yes he does but he has to deal with this
immediate initiative which is which is
not easy to deal with
um
you're saying Lawrence you're glad to
see
well I'm glad to see Tom rashevsky yeah
taking taking some risks and and playing
principally rather than you know just
retreating The Rook there and saying
okay
I'm not even gonna look at the old town
is I I I'm very happy to see that move
very very happy
and that gives us the Dilemma as well
Lawrence do we stick with this game it's
getting so exciting now do we switch
over some huge battles taking place
Thomas
that's a good point
um
I will say that
maybe we stick with this one just as
it's so exciting right now it's it's
potentially dramatic for the tournament
as a whole Knight D5 by Magnus
is he getting over the worst if the
knights come off
maybe he's slightly closer to safety
black does have the luxury as well of
giving up some material later on uh
giving some material back and trying to
go into an opposite color bishoping game
potentially
yeah we need to drink here banking on
Magnus to save this we have seen
Nakamura and napoleonishi a bunch report
a bunch of players save worst positions
than Magnus has got right now so
the theme of the day continue
yeah I'm struggling to see a follow-up
for tomorrow maybe Knight takes D5
followed by bringing the Knight into D6
just trying to paralyze Black's Roots
would be a monster
and just
yeah White's formation
get rid of it
I think that's very likely to happen
just like this also rookie seven
sometimes but just basically seven if
Rook a two
can you just go into one
so come Lawrence
yeah push the people yeah
black looks completely stuck yeah
well
so muchevsky with a Chance
is he gonna find it
the problem for tomashevsky is that
there is a chance of bailing out you can
play Knight B6 he's just exchanged
Knights on D5 note B6 in that position
would pretty much force a draw so will
the Temptation now 20 seconds for
tomachowski would the Temptation prove
too much will he go for that draw will
he swap off pieces or will he go for
more oh passive negative decision by
Thomas Jefferson
yeah Knight B6 though and after Bishop
takes B5
I can't see Magnus losing this one
anymore
yeah this is 65.96 A8 and
draw
opposite color Bishops
a week but yeah true
yeah
yeah yes they were both very short on
time as well
uh
uh yeah and of course important to point
out in the current position that you
can't just attack this bishop because
when this happens
you are you get hit this way so you're
kind of forced to take on B5
Magnus is arming and owing trying to
uh you know figure something out see if
there's another way to play this but I
just don't think there is
Rook ae8 Lawrence Rook 88 maybe but 1967
looks very tempting there oh wow
I don't think you can take risks here as
Magnus
oh wow he's played it has he played
rookie Rook 88 he's going for the win
Magnus here but surely he should be
fighting for his life
and okay Tom rashevski didn't take any
fancy risks there he just traded off a
set of Rooks and it's equal material
Knight and two pawns for Rook but Magnus
is getting active
with his Rook
hey at least he will eliminate the
d-pawn there's no way for white to keep
that one intact
do you think Lauren's still a draw
um
I would take white now because
I am
maybe not I mean Magnus is
you know extremely efficient with his
pieces
so uh it's a tough one maybe we should
take C5 Bishop takes B5
really tough one
yeah which pieces should white aim to
exchange should white aim to exchange
the knife for the black Bishop should
white keep all the material on the board
that's Rook is going to get very good uh
once it reaches the second rank maybe in
the first rank
[Music]
uh still everything's gonna be solid
though yes
it's going to be difficult for Magnus I
think tomashevsky now just wants a draw
actually
to be honest
yeah I think he signaled with that
Knight B6 move a bit earlier yeah didn't
really believe in his winning chances he
didn't back himself
and uh maybe that's why Magnus played
Rook aeat sensed a bit of psychological
weakness from his opponent
he's very good at that
absolutely
and as Antoine says in the chat you have
a hard time believing black ever wins
but it is Magnus it is Magnus after all
and okay Knight C7 like gives a check
last Bishop will move
that white knight is slightly offside
though
he needs to get back into the game
we'll stick with this game just because
it is so dramatic potentially uh
devastating if Magnus can't stop these
white pawns uh would be huge for the
tournament but there have been other
games we will check in on those results
we will show some of the action a bit
later
um in both the open and the women's
sections
okay re-routing his Knight still feels
like black
is okay
but can Magnus hope for more
the more you look at it Lawrence
yeah I believe in Black any chances
I mean objectively no but over the board
anything can happen
and uh Magnus is uh is a master at
making opponents uncomfortable as well
right he does he doesn't just let them
settle
it's it's it's very I mean it's very
annoying to play Magnus
I've never played him in a proper game
like you but even in the Blitz Games
we've played it's it's just very
you know
uh uh
it's just very tough there's a there's a
psychological element to it now he knows
he's stable and
well
you know
um that's enough yeah he with his
stability he can breathe the the white
horns have been held up and now he's
going to try and make something work and
he is making progress
he is making progress
that white king you got to fear for it
slightly and especially if black and
push is Pawn to G4 so that's why
tomaszewsky's planted his Bishop on E5
he's saying okay if you push your Jeep
on your F Pawn will drop
that's it does feel like Magnus is
squeezing water out of that stone as uh
feeling Khushi says
feels like he's creating those threats
suddenly tomashesky has awkward
questions to answer 20 seconds on the
clock the F2 Pawn attacked if you ever
touch the F2 Pawn for white
think that will backfire the G Pawn is a
clear Target for blacks light squared
Bishop and okay white just dropping back
his King tomachevsky is praying for the
draw here remember
no this is getting this is getting weird
for Tom and chefsky now it takes look at
that white knight
it just can't contribute to the game
G3 check FTC three F3
breaking through oh my goodness
you have to move you have to take that
pawn
it's probably lost now but what a tactic
uh clearance tactic on the second rank
now
you're right Lawrence that is a killer
wow G3
I agree as well with uh Jay Luke poker
someone I mean Magnus needs to teach us
end games how does he do it every time
and uh hey
that past F1 he's got to win a black
surely now
how do you stop the pawn and you don't
is the answer Magnus takes the win
Thomas resides
wow very disappointing for you of going
not to hold that
uh and we just saw a Super Chat there
this is why the Magnus is the greatest
ever yes
effectively yes because he can win
positions where he's a lot worse
find resources put the pressure on he
measured thomaszewsky really well in
that game uh he could feel like Tom
roshevski would crack under a bit of
pressure and he was right
uh quite incredible
now uh
where should we go
next
uh yeah there's still a plenty of games
going
um what do you think should we stick
with the open section uh Grand Kristoff
young Christoph Duda is I think doing
the business on board two with white
uh it looks like our difficult Rook end
game for his opponents and past pawns
how do you stop those A and H pawns if
your blue bound here is black
that black Rook is stretched can't stop
both Pawns
it's uh it's what we call the trousers
two legs of the trousers the a h Pawns
and
I don't see a way Lawrence can you
defend well
just checking C3 and King B4
mm-hmm
yep any move with your king pretty much
the white Rook will slide as well
somewhere on the sixth Rank and then the
acorn starts running
yeah these top players they're all so
good in the end game
um Duda Nakamura naponishi Carlson we've
seen them all
um kind of really Revel in these uh
these simplified positions
the opponents have no answer
and yeah Rook F2 looks like Duda has
moved his Rook white doesn't even care
about the F Pawn
yeah those two are Runners the A and H
ones no way to stop them now
and the a pawn also promotes with check
which is a nail in the coffin for black
and some variations you can start a pawn
race but white is by far the quicker
in this position
yeah it looks like the closing stage is
now bluebound running out of resources
nothing to be done
which other games have caught your eye
Lawrence
um
well sundarov
is
uh doing the business
against Jordan van Forest I believe this
is the position after move 58
this is all she wrote surely
uh
well
Jordan playing on inertia here but
ultimately this position is Stone loss
Bishop F6 E6 and look at Jake mate
in this position looks very very strong
I've just a tour of Beijing damchenko
Geary beating donchenko
arterium
let's go to Tyrion in a have a look at
denchenka against Gary
oh it's Gary's favorite type of position
a risk-free endgame
and yeah no chances here of a loss of
course for black and therefore he can
push at will
and then we see Gary just moving in for
the kill positive body language he's
also got the benefit of White's Pawn
being a clear Target on A4 so White's
Bishop is stuck on it on this diagonal
defending that pawn
okay the river repeating the position
though it's not clear when he makes a
dart with the black king towards that
white a pawn you've got to time it right
uh before you start running
to A4 with the black king first he's
maneuvering his Knight around
is do you want to trade off any pawns on
the king side I don't think you do and
the more pawns that disappear the closer
white gets to the draw so he's found a
nice way for the Knight to sit on a
active Square while blocking the white
Bishop's attack on F5
I love this technique so far Lawrence
yep
yeah Alexander dinchenko though shout
out to him for uh of course being uh
great guy great young guy seen him come
up through the ranks in uh in Germany
um
incredible hard worker
you know obviously massive Talent
but um
um
yeah he there was a streak he went on
last year I think it was seven games in
a row against 2600 Grand Masters I
remember in the French league
yeah incredible performance and he beat
me as well I must say in the world Blitz
last year okay
very talented player at least I've got
to say that yeah
um
yeah but meanwhile I love again what
Gary's doing
I think maybe on the last move he could
have given a check to the white king
forced the white king back to a really
bad square and then started dancing in
with his King but
um he feels he can do that immediately
Gary the Black Knight will protect the
pawns and the black king will rush over
towards the a pawn
it still doesn't feel over yet it's not
so tricky Bishop's just so good when
pawns are on both on both flanks
I can wait forever yeah so Bishop B6
yeah when you time it Lauren yeah no
it's not over
it's it's not it's not straightforward
at all
and Anish might just decide to jostle
for position here for another 40 moves
uh if he has them
classical Niche yeah take his time well
he doesn't want to rush that's for sure
and
okay he goes
oh he's hesitating that he lingered with
his hand on the piece yeah King C3
yeah doesn't change too much
and now he's going to the Bourne
uh so there will be
there will come a time when he jumps
over with the Knight as well to take
that A4 Pawn but it will come at the
cost of Black's pawns so it's all about
timing
prediction here Lawrence will will he
find the win Anish
I have a feeling you will I feel like
still practically but don't think I've
played so many games with him in
positions like this he is very resilient
in notes ah Knight C4 you can't take on
F5 because of uh Knight E3 check
yeah this was a bad square but after
King F2 maybe you have to go back anyway
to D6 yeah unless you go for the white
Pawn there unless you go through for
example yeah but I'm thinking if you go
like this for this Pawn here like this
let's say King takes a foreign
yeah suddenly the white king goes for
the G Pawn are you entitled to push the
ape on you have to use your knight to
block the white Bishop's diagonal you're
right Lawrence this looks like a draw
still
so maybe don shenko is still alive
you've got to be careful with where you
put the king that's uh don't want to
walk into any nasty night folks
that's true
yeah I don't see how you keep the cheap
one alive
and okay we
can go back to the current position
maybe with uh Gary pondering whether to
go for that white acorn
if you have to play Knight D6 then you
haven't made any progress no back to
square one you could push F4 but white
won't run forward with the King anytime
soon and that only makes it easier
okay and Knight B6 it does go for it
interesting
so Bridge ref594
yeah interesting now I love it okay I
love your move Bishop D7 uh Lawrence or
maybe you start moving the king first
and you wait yeah
yes exactly
King F3 King F3 go for that black G Pawn
once you remove that then yeah mistakes
are
oh the evaluation bar dropped just there
but uh mistakes are pretty high still it
didn't it didn't like clean F3 at all
yeah
move on the board
yeah
them change goes down to his last
seconds
okay what is he gonna play oh did he
lose on time then no it looks like he
moved his King
Black Knight dropping back problem is
now how do you stop the a pawn
can you stop the a pawn he's going
towards it by the white king yeah
hey maybe you're just in time if you run
with the white king towards the corner
but the evaluation bar drops goes in
Gary's favor
last king is gonna block off the white
king look off its counterpart
as soon as the white king commits
Lawrence maybe the black King's gonna
jump the other way
yeah exactly
uh King B3 was a mistake Bishop C2 King
B2 still looks tough
firstenko G4 but now the pawn is fixed
on a light Square
the cheap one
yeah no this is
yeah and denchenko with a big sigh there
yeah I think this is just all she wrote
yeah the a pawn just runs through you
can't trade off here it would have been
a winning game porno game and yeah we
see the resignation
Gary he's on fire okay
certainly doing quite well isn't he
um
and uh meanwhile some other key games
going Gary takes his third win in a row
we do see in front of us grishook as
black against ladislav kovalov
from Belarus
and I'm doing a quick count it looks
like black is three pawns up
is this game even still going
inside
taking the win yeah no I think this
one's probably done
yeah and there's no time on the white
clock so I think that's
that's been done
in the women's section uh a few drawers
on the top boards
here you draw uh against tanjong ji gong
dragon sagnitzi and kamalidinova draw
against zombie Canary that will give
some boost to the field gunina uh with a
lovely win as did Nina batshit really
and Elena Elena daniellen is also on
three out of three
so only those are on a hundred percent
so far
yeah
um three three leaders in the women's
section after three rounds and uh in the
open section
I think it's gonna be a few more
but uh maybe we can recap uh what's
happening on some of the top boards
Let's do let's do a quick recap of the
open section Magnus Carlsen uh staying
strong beating tomashevsky in a very
complex game Duda beats bluebound for
the save beats Musa uh artemiev beats
keema we've just seen Anish giri beat
donchenko sindarov lost to Van Forest
massive win there for Jordan Andrew
satorov uh not going anywhere reigning
champion on three out of three uh we had
Arjun irrigation we've not even talked
about him yet so far David on three out
of three as is his countryman nihal
sarin destroying Grand Masters left
right and census so there's a solid sort
of 10 players nine ten players on three
out of three and obviously a bunch of
very strong players after that on Two
and a Half
um wow well
there you have it we we can see another
uh ending here but I think this might be
a good moment for us to
go to break
uh this and
oh we're staying until this is done okay
uh we've got uh shunts I guess in
playing white here against dragnev I
thought I recognized dragnev flying with
the uh black creases but actually this
is going to be a draw straight up right
it's just a repetition
uh Rook D4 version F3
ah three
uh maybe this is not necessarily yet
yeah
Rook D3
like needs to eliminate one of the white
pieces and the white Pawn uh I don't
think we'll see The Rook sacrifice
itself for the pawn and that long game
that long end game of Bishop and Knight
versus King but uh that's got to be what
chanceian is aiming for dragnav though
very strong uh Australian Grandmaster I
do think he'll be able to save this like
you said just keep harassing white
pieces
now you can attack the white Bishop
again
unless white can stabilize yeah yeah
it's going to be different I need to
find the construction to stabilize here
but maybe you can knight F6
yeah maybe Knight F6
um the black king is so far away
otherwise you could sacrifice for that
white knight
uh yeah played suddenly white tonight
can come back to G4
I think
you still have to go around in circles
right but maybe you are surviving here
with all the white pieces
you're right three Lawrence maybe yeah
there we go
yeah I do kind of Hope in the back of my
mind that we do see bishop and Knight
versus King just uh so we can all
refresh how to Checkmate that one it's
been a while since I studied it
so yeah also we're seeing in the chat
Jordan van Forrest that's the biggest
turnaround we've seen you wrote that one
off Lawrence uh a bit I did Jordan was
yeah dead he's down yes he managed to
turn it around amazing
and uh okay we see the the Knight go
back to F6 I think White's just
repeating the position to gain a bit of
time on the clock to gain those extra 10
seconds
we will see Knight G4 most likely unless
he wants to go to G8 with his Knight but
that looks clumsy don't put your knight
on the rim
and G4 defend it with the bishop bring
the white king
whose King is closer here if anyone's
surely it's white whites
no back to 25.
rookie six
I've got to say I don't understand
rookie six at all why didn't black bring
the king
I know you can't bring the king because
King B5 runs into Knights he's seven so
you have to go back to D6
and now
Maybe
or maybe E7 Knight E7 bring the Knight
around to F5 push the H Pawn
wow it's getting close okay now he drops
back to E3 same idea black king has to
be careful where it goes to
him before
and I have five now what do you start
with King C2 Maybe
the white Pawn needs to push the black
King's Edge in closer we'll see two
Lawrence I have a feeling we'll see the
black king get into that h8 corner at
some point black will give up his Rook
for the White Knight it's the wrong age
point it's the wrong Rooks Pawn here
thinking like
yeah it looks like earlier he chose the
wrong Square for his night white tonight
should have used the E7 Square because
then H6 H7 h8 was just coming almost
impossible to stop that without uh
giving up your Rook
now Black's King just needs two more
moves to enter the square off this y H
Pawn
if black team gets to E5 it's going to
be a drum no more chances
I think you can do it now keep moving
the king
he does
what do you think Lawrence
yeah and then more chances now for white
no I wouldn't you can try H6 though
because Rook say g697 check he does play
try it good try rookie three check
King E2 and then
um you can go over cage three probably
but uh
the evaluation bar is teasing us now by
jumping forward dropping back
is black in time it's a matter of one or
two Tempi now
King has to come back but which Square
he chooses E5
okay you just need one square more King
F6 and I think you're safe as black yeah
now the king can come now the king can
come Knight H5 yeah take that night you
just take it yeah
you can get into the corner
yeah
yeah and this is not gonna uh go on for
too much longer well defended by dragnev
uh H7
now you can just take it
oh no 94. oh okay
G7 yeah
yeah and they should
a great draw King G4 okay
and draw a grid
wow all right we have the same
yep another save another interesting
in-game
we are past halfway stage for today
round four coming up no major blowouts
just yet some of the top names up there
Carlson Duda or Tierney of Gary erici
sarin the list goes on are plenty of
Chess yet to go round four coming up for
both the open and women's sections don't
go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Blitz championships taking place in
Astana you can see in front of you a
live shot of the playing Hall the
players not yet settled for round four
two more rounds today uh we will have
plenty of action yet we've had action
tons of action so far Magnus Carlson
leading the way getting off to a fast
start this year is on three out of three
as is Anish Geary on 303 as is Jan
shishtoff Duda on 303 and many others uh
will be detailing that and wow have we
got an exciting round for for you guys
but before we go into just those parents
with me is my good friend David Hal
David it's been an interesting first
three rounds and the theme for me that I
cannot seem to sort of Escape is uh that
a lot of the top guys have gotten a bit
lucky to to be on the points that they
have a lot of near misses for these guys
who has impressed you the most so far
and what's your evaluation of uh what's
been going on so far yeah you're
completely right Lawrence they do say
you make your own luck and it's a cliche
for a reason the top players they're so
tenacious and they're all very
well-rounded they've got these facets of
their game they take their chances
they've got great Killer Instincts so
when those opportunities arise they
normally capitalize but as you say I
mean Magnus Carlson really riding his
luck pushing uh things really to the
brink there triumphing eventually
against tomashesky Nakamura saving a
lost position he has dropped two draws
however after the first three rounds and
I mean the list goes on all the players
they've had difficult positions at times
it's just about how they deal with that
and
um yeah I mean there's so many uh
impressive players already so far I must
say I've been so impressed by
abdusitorov in particular the reigning
world rapid Champion he's got a lot to
live up to but he has hit the ground
running he's won three games out of
three and
I mean Lawrence we've got some huge
games in this round have two satoros a
reigning world rapid champion
against Magnus Carlson for now we're
training World classical champion and uh
what a game that one is gonna be
well it is and I remember compensating
on it live last year and effectively we
had a a situation where Magnus uh pushed
and pushed and pushed and pushed and he
made it blunder and after sex work took
advantage of that mistake and ended up
beating Magnus Abdu Center of them went
and I think he beat the partnership I
think he beat mvl and he ended up
winning the tournament they're playing a
lot earlier in the tournament this time
round four Magnus with the white pieces
uh should be very very interesting
indeed what a match-up that is by the
way 4-2 is not bad either Gary Duda
these have played uh you know these guys
have played each other tons over the
past few years both in online tours and
live and look at boards three and four
as well got better save against sarin
the young Indian genius a great pairing
film in my opinion against her cell and
Jordan
having to play the tricky uh artemia as
well very very tough in the amongst many
other very interesting parents for
example Eric Acura what an interesting
pairing that is as well
um
or interesting parents in the open and
also in the women's section uh we've got
uh three players on 100 batfish really
runina and Daniella and it is bats
actually against winning on board one
for stenio on Two and a Half will be
very happy to have the white pieces
against Elena and Yellen
um as will tanjongji again for very
talented kunai uh uh sorry a bigger
party
on board three tons of uh chess to be
played in the women's but of course the
highlights of this round favorite has to
be Carlson against expectation
and or predictions for this particular
game
tough question Lawrence expectations I
know it's going to be a fierce fight
neither of these two players ever backed
down Magnus won't underestimate to
Satora perhaps that was the case last
year when you said
Bush and gave up this tutor of his
chance to search for a house on that
chance of course in terms of predictions
I do think it'll be a draw just because
both players are in such fantastic form
right
uh yeah I'm expecting a full-blooded
fight in that game and yeah I think Gary
Duda as well anything could happen Geary
starting really well writing out some
top end games as you mentioned Duda is
not one to be underestimated either
taking his opponents into these murky
Waters always seems to come out on top
so meanwhile we do see some of the
leaders take their seats to see nihau
sarin there sitting down is black on
board three we see Jordan bumfries
taking a seat Anish Gary and good
spirits the adjusters pieces at the
start of the game
I mean there's so many highlights I
think there's nine leaders in the open
section right now so nine players have
started
fire essentially and um yeah I mean I
don't think the players will want to
lose momentum by playing safe now have
to take your chances in the early stages
of this tournament because towards the
end you are guaranteed to face the top
guys every single round so these are
these small games here are still around
four there's like a long way to go they
are essential if you want to win a medal
of the day
absolutely yes I like the fact that uh
Anish is already getting settled early
uh you know I think that Anish has
um
uh you know uh he still wants to win
some big titles he's still got the
hunger and this is one of them don't
make any mistake about it this is the
world rapid championships uh Anish Gary
is not here to to just have a little bit
of bansa he's a very very serious
competitor and uh this particular game
is an interesting one because he knows
that if if Duda wants he can give him
chances
um
the honest is not gonna uh over risk
with white but he'll be looking forward
to having some chances if Duda feels
like that now uh it really depends on
dude or I think I think if Duda is super
solid Anish won't mind I think if Judah
tries to be his ambitious self Anish
also won't mind what he will mind is if
he doesn't take a chance if it's
presented to him
so critical game here vanish got to
mention Lawrence before we move on to
the other parings the last time that
Duda and Anish met Duda unleash this
incredible tactic Checkmate in 11 moves
I think you can go and vote for it in
the hs.com move of the year uh and I
mean that was one of the most beautiful
tactical sequences I've ever seen as we
see the shake of hands between the two
so Gary will have a score to settle
nobody likes to be uh defeated in such
style so uh yeah I mean that game I
can't wait to watch him I mean while we
see feather save having a chat with
Jordan I didn't know they were good
friends but
um clearly both in good spirits yeah
and here they are
yeah and uh Happy Gary of course you
can't resist joining the fun
but do notice how Magnus tends not to
get involved in the pre-game banter or
chats
there is a there is a reason you know
Magnus is very very focused when he
uh you know is in mid Tournament of
course we know he can be jokey and want
to have fun outside of the games and
outside of the playing wall but he's
never really one to arrive early and
just joke around with his competitors
and I think
that's for a reason he's you know he
wants to instill a bit of fear into his
opponents and if you're too nice and if
you're too sweet uh you might lose a bit
of your Edge and I think manx probably
feels quite
uh
you know uh serious about that
uh
yeah sorry you go to Lawrence no go on
go on
I was going to say you're right it's a
type of Mind Game in itself arriving a
bit later you know uh just making your
opponents wait for you
often Magnus actually loses two or three
minutes on the clock in classical games
because he wants to make his opponent
sweat but uh yeah you can see the mutual
respect here Magnus arriving on time
adjusting his pieces both dressed to
impress in Black
predictions I've got to ask Lawrence
yeah I mean this one is uh
I'm gonna go with a Magnus win actually
and the reason I'm doing that is because
firstly I think Magnus will be
relatively confident after what's
happened he's on three out of three when
I I think he understands that he really
shouldn't be on three out of three
um
so he will think okay things are going
well in general
so
the energy is good
um and he's got the revenge Factor here
and the sator of cost him the title last
year
uh and no doubt in my mind Magnus wants
to
to
you know get some uh get some revenge
for for what happened
uh and he understands how big a bigger
spot this is because you know if Magnus
wins this suddenly there's only going to
be a handful of people on four out of
four and you can already start to think
about separating himself from the field
he's got the white pieces so everything
is basically saying
this is for a Magnus win
um and and I agree I I think
I think this is a great spot for Magnus
and I'm expecting a very tough game for
a No Deal book
uh the Norwegian Avenger Magnus Carson
trying to make up for that defeat last
year and I actually did vote for
nordeback as my uh Abdul sotorov as my
player of the year just because I mean
he won the world rapid Championship he
led Uzbekistan to a gold medal at the
Olympiad what a year it's been but yeah
stylistically he does take a lot of
risks there's still some consistency of
course for a young player uh is required
to maybe break into the elite In
classical chess but yeah this format
just suits his style so well so well
drilled in the openings great coach in
Ivan sokolov uh foreign it looks like
the players
something's held them up uh they're not
starting yeah quite yet
another holder
not completely clear Magnus I can tell
you this does not like getting held up
you can confirm that David but hasn't
got
an enormous amount of patience let's say
in these uh trivial matters
yeah people wait for him he waits for no
one that's magnus's uh that is
that is his life monster
um
okay about opening predictions in that
huge Clash on board one uh Lawrence last
year it was the English opening that
Abdus uh took down Magnuson
oh tough one
um
oh you're running out of time I'm gonna
I'm gonna go for a caracon
oh it's a 1b3
wow
Magnus
that he employed against Eric Hanson
just a couple of rounds ago but
this is risky and it's predictable now
because he's done it before
wow reacting instantly I think of this
choice is it right to provoke your
opponent this much at an early stage
um even got the center
laughs
well he's played a sideline which is a
sideline that um I actually uh played
against uh uh myself with black
it's not a particularly good line as far
as I know Magnus here has played the
move uh for Knight F3
the main line of this particular line is
is Bishop B5 with lots of theory but
Knight F3 is an old favorite of some of
the Danish players
um
but uh I believe black can just go E4
here kicking the night
and after 94 you can just take
and either Play Bishop E7 or D5 here
and
you know
how bad can your position be here as
black but actually no we get a totally
different move we get Bishop D6
immediately is that is that correct
we get because
that has been played and it looks like a
clumsy move Bishop D6 in this current
position but it's a trendy idea gets
that other variation you mentioned
Lawrence after Bishop B5 that clearly
was abducator's preparation and he's
sticking to the system or the type of
setup that he knows I think that's one
that all Club players or casual players
can relate to if you're opponent
surprises you why not stick to
um a setup that you're familiar with
um so Abdus tour of planting to ask my
Bishop on D6 maybe we can update the
border and uh yeah not challenging
magnus's set up I think that's just good
strategy again in general yes black was
fine if he'd push the pawn to E4 but why
walk into something that Magnus has
clearly studied earlier today and uh
okay Magnus chooses to transpose into
almost an English opening putting the
pawn on C4
very classical setup now you mentioned
those Danish players playing this
variation as white this is the last
invaration after all and they love to
play on the flanks black castling
I'm expecting white tonight to develop
to C3 it looks kind of like a reversed
close Sicilian in a way and that's one
area that you have some experience well
I don't know about that but uh it's a
it's a weird kind of uh
English of sorts I mean I I don't know
but I think Magnus is going to be very
happy because this move Bishop T6
doesn't feel like it's the critical move
I mean as I was saying I think you go E4
there
and now okay you can still go E4 as
black
in this position but uh
no I think uh Magnus will be super happy
to have already a bit of a messy
position that address is actually going
to have to think about
so again great opening choice
but okay he's gone for D3 he's gone for
a very classical
reversed kind of Sicilian
um you know a movie like rookie eight
could happen and then bishop f8 and we
could have a slow reverse Sicilian here
which I think will also suit Magnus
yeah Magnus loves these really flexible
positions it's a bit like the strategy
he employed against tomashevsky the
professor right he just he said it's a
very flexible Pawn structure waited for
the opponent to come at him and then
reacted and it feels like the same again
and uh like you predicted has planted
his Rook on E8
If This Were Blitz Magnus might consider
trying to set up a g-pawn push with
white Magnus has really got into those
types of ideas recently for example
playing like Rook G1 pushing the pawn to
G4 but okay this is rapid it's too risky
for this time format I think he has too
much respect for Abdus toroff so I'm
expecting to see Magnus just play Bishop
E2 maybe get castled yeah maybe you
could start with the important uh
playing Pawn to A3 just to cover any
Bishop B4 check ideas but I like that
move
yeah I mean it's uh
it's gonna end up eventually in a
reverse Sicilian and it's going to be
about who understands those positions
better
you never know I think magnets will
certainly have more experience in those
positions and he does go you through so
a lovely spot there David
um
and uh yeah
um
it's uh
uh it's a flexible system for for Magnus
um a five fairly standard
there should be two now then after
sector will put the bishop on f8 he'll
play
uh D6 or D5 that's really his big
decision about whether he wants to open
him or whether he wants to just play
super close but we've got a long game
in store here this is this isn't this is
going to be a tough game
yeah and maybe with that in mind we can
move around uh the horn and check out
some of the other battles we mentioned
Gary against another
big clash in this fourth round
oh wow
okay at least more simplified than the
other game that we just came from more
pieces have been traded off suiting Gary
potentially black has an isolated Pawn
on D5 early thoughts Florence
yeah
um very comfortable for black even
though he's got the isolated Queen's
Pawn even though he's got the wrong
color Bishop to a certain extent
uh these positions uh with the play on
The Queen side they're just not quite
enough
for white to get a really serious
advantage
it's from a line in the Catalan which is
uh very very popular very quickly go
through it uh Bishop B4 check Bishop D2
A5 Castle's Queen C2 and now let's move
C5 in tested a hell of a lot of top
level CD and then now this classic move
or this uh well not classic but uh
computer-ish kind of line CD Knight D4
Queen B6 it's all been seen tons of
times and then you voluntarily give
yourself the isolator Queens form
because your activity for your pieces is
so good like we see here all of Black's
pieces cooperating so as it turns out
this is actually not a particularly
dangerous I say to Queen's Pawn position
as far as I can tell
for black
yeah I completely agree Lawrence it
looks like black has got the dream
scenario uh in any iqp in any isolated
Queen spawn position active pieces the
bishop G4 the queen on B6 they look
really well positioned and Knight might
leap into E4 however stylistically
um if we project if we forget the
objective evaluation stylistically I
would think Gary here he loves these
grindy positions where he can just sit
and kind of wait and not do too much
slowly improve on every turn and do that
is slightly impatient from time to time
and do that these days he's he's more
well-rounded than he was perhaps two or
three years ago but I have seen him lash
out especially in positions where he's
only fighting for the draw so if Gary
can somehow consolidate improve the
white Rooks then maybe some chances long
term
um I do think that giri's opening Choice
was influenced by those kind of uh
stylistic personal factors rather than
any attempt to grab an early advantage
and we should mention as well for
example if white moves The Rook uh same
Rook has C1 black has to be really
careful about whether you can take on B2
right with the queen because you might
well get trapped Rook CB1 for example
and yeah the queen is caught so black
can't really profit from the activity of
his pieces yet and we'll still have to
knuckle down and play a few solid
accurate moves I feel to equalize
at least fully uh
yeah absolutely agree until early days
early days here
yeah which game catches your fancy here
David ah with sport for Choice Lawrence
they're all pretty interesting matchups
uh at this early stage maybe we stick to
the open section temporarily and we can
move to the weird section in a moment
maybe we look yeah or three
um if we can
pull that one up Salah against Napoleon
okay
um is this board three maybe this is
slightly low down but napoleonishi salad
they've dropped half a point I think oh
did they did they both drop off one uh
both for his fed a save excuse me
I mean this one would
yeah Salah in the punishi just looked
very tense very imbalanced in that one
both very aggressive players
uh had to save against nihal sarin
okay he's on a hot streak he's
especially in Rapid chess after his
performance in the global Chess
Championship
yeah he did phenomenally didn't he in
the global test championship
got to the final there
um yeah early days early days but
initial feelings who would you take here
Lawrence I think it's just a very
standard Queen's Gambit declined
um
I'd probably take white just because the
space advantage on the queen side is
sometimes a bit irritating
but uh
no I mean it's uh
it's it's not much to talk about just
yet this position let's put it like that
I think we can move on to a more
exciting position
how about
van Forest against artemiev
wow
okay what is this
it looks like it might have originated
from a type of philidor
um looks very blocked now
let's check out the opening okay it came
from the Italian
with the early Knight F6 and the bishop
on E7 a mark hebden special
uh
of course most players nowadays put the
bushwon C5 this is the old way of
playing this position Levon has played
it a few times as well
um so it has been played
Daniel dubov plays this almost every
time as black against the Italian Magnus
has played it many times so clearly it's
kind of a Magnus Carlson Camp type of
idea as black and remember Jordan van
Forrest a second of Magnus he will have
analyzed this as well so okay how did
artemia get his Knight to B4
looks like uh
yeah I think it's blocked up and black
is chipping away at the White Center
yeah
very tense I've got to say I'll tell me
if it's one of my favorite players when
I uh when I try to learn certain opening
setups when I'm looking for ways to
provoke the opponent to take risks or
acceptable risk
in the opening and he's just performed
fantastically in Rapid chess throughout
his career I think at one point he was
world number three in Blitz this was
going back five years already
and yeah yeah absolutely
it's hard to evaluate this one so early
tough yeah I think black is doing okay
actually I think this kind of setup for
white is is not that dangerous at all
um
so
yeah I think I think uh artemia will be
reasonably happy let's keep on going
through and see if we can find what
about irrigation
Arjun playing against Rapport now this
one is a bit more
attempts to say the least
yeah and also we should check in on uh
Fabiano in a moment because that one is
crazy already I think he's already
winning as black after 18 moves but
um yeah I mean these games are looking
chaotic Eric I see against rapport
why does it pull up if I can count
correctly
but white king is stranded in the center
position
you would you'd have to pay me a lot of
money to play this from the white side
uh
really dislike this position in general
um
you know
uh
sticks the height for weight
your king as you mentioned Lawrence
yeah the stakes are high you can't even
go Bishop B3 because it runs into
Queen's xp5
and you just lose second yeah so you
can't block the diagonal
uh
you know and if you go Bishop A4 because
your Bishop's on pre
then black and black straight six and
suddenly these these Bishops are
starting to really cause
huge damage uh down here and down here
uh position looks
horrible for why to play
um
castles Queen side there you go there's
about to ask you Lawrence uh I bit my
tongue I wanted to ask you would you
ever be tempted to cast a coincide but I
thought it'd look too stupid I feel too
brave of course I
I do uh and and I I you know it's a move
that you
uh you always keep in mind but of course
in this particular position
so double-edged
putting your kingdom
on the side of three open files yeah it
can never you can never find true safety
so
yes so it's very very tricky
see in the future chat there saying that
uh without the commentators you would be
struggling to uh get a hold over the
position but this is the type of
position that even the commentators I
think we struggle with right Lawrence
because it's so irrational pieces all
over the board so many open files open
diagonals white king is stuck in no
man's land on on the queen side here
about to get yeah hit by some tactics
and uh yeah I mean this one is a hard
one to even evaluate I've been looking
at it for a couple of minutes now and
I mean black has so many tempting moves
I would be tempted to even sacrifice on
A3 a bishop here just to open up lines
he drops back very sensible
and yeah Black's Knights are going to
come out soon white king long term is uh
yeah in huge danger so I love what
reports done Eric I see one of the best
uh one of the most successful players of
2022 but
looks like a tough start to this game
for him
yeah
um tough tough tough game and I think uh
a great spot here for airport
uh I think that
uh we should
continue through uh I do want to keep an
eye on Magnus against address and wow
you spotted some action yeah I mean
we've got to see it because look at what
we have here
a poor on G4
uh playing in the style of Bobby Fischer
and others uh playing against this uh
this structure
it's uh it creates an interesting
impression
yeah I don't want to post Lawrence but I
did mention the G4 ID earlier you did I
remember
every time I see Magnus play nowadays
especially in these kind of kind of
flexible setups somehow upon lands on G4
and we should maybe show why that pawn
uh could not be captured or why it was
not captured how it got there
um because Magnus set it up in a really
sneaky really patient way after Bishop
G6 white played G4 and
it looks a bit Rush he's just trying to
stop the black F Pawn moving forward
he's trying to solidify E4 as an outpost
for white tonight but after Queen D7
what a move uh yeah I want to move Now
by Magnus so calm just
seeing H1 shuffling into the corner and
if Queen takes G4 looks like a
discovered attack Knight takes E5
hitting the queen in two directions
and yeah suddenly tactically Black's
position falls apart
wow and uh yeah if we catch up with the
game position still that tactics in the
air if black ever takes actually Four
Pawn with this queen
and in the meantime I don't know about
you Lawrence but I struggled to find
plans if I'm black in this setup
um when it's like an open Sicilian and
you're kind of stuck you have no Pawn
breaks what next yeah
well that's exactly it with no Pawn
breaks it's it's very very tough
I think sometimes you can drop this
Knight back to uh back to B6 try and
play A4
uh disrupt the the white structure but
you know that's why I said I thought
uh Magnus would be very happy with the
outcome of the opening because he's got
all of this flexibility
um
to do as he wishes
and um
you know I think that yeah
and I think Knight B6 has been played
yeah not abec just the way he moves his
pieces it's so calm so confident
um it's disconcerting I've played him a
few times over the board in Blitz and
he's just kind of yeah he never seems
flustered even when Magnus is or even
when any of his opponents are doing some
strange aggressive stuff like G4
and uh yeah he's dropped his Knight back
I guess he's going after the B3 Pawn you
mentioned that's the only Target in
White's camp
uh essentially the blackened uh a Martin
I like what Magnus has done put his Rook
on G1 but the question for him now is
what next does white motor Forge with G5
do you prepare it first uh it looks like
Magnus has moved he's my Rook G3
Lawrence yeah yeah it's that Rook doing
the G3 now this is classic you go Rook
G3 in order to double
uh sometimes this Rook uh slings out to
H3 and all of a sudden yeah so black has
gone A4 this is precisely the uh the uh
sort of concept and after B takes A4 he
wants to go Knight A5 this is the only
way you can play if you just wait here
for too long as black Israel comes to G1
this comes to a H3 and in the right
circumstance you play G5 and you just
get mated that's black so you have to be
fast here so I like what abusatorov has
done
uh playing A4 you have to play b6a4
otherwise Bishop B3 comes and now the
move Knight A5 Core Group late I'm I'm
sure of it by atusa tourov and you know
he's trying to get him his Queen side
counter play before black as before
Magnus can get in his King side
Captain's play effectively
yeah like you say it's a race and Magnus
really has to uh go through the gears he
has to pick up the pace because now
Bishop B3 is a threat as you mentioned
Rook dg1 I guess is magnus's idea but as
soon as black starts coming in with his
pieces for example okay I think just
judging by his hand movements there we
did see Magnus swing across but uh yeah
Bishop B3 is coming Black's kind of
evacuating the king side just leaving
white to do as he wants but White's
other flank has fallen apart those two
white a pawns are definitely gonna drop
off over the next few moves what d-pawn
is tender
um Queen takes A4 is a move here Knight
takes A4 as a move Bishop B3
all the while the clocks are very very
balanced
it's just so complicated I've got to
admire these players they never ever
back down they never go for those types
of positions with no risk they're always
happy to kind of provoke their opponents
to go for their own plans very principal
to okay I'll do some tour of Bishop D5
I've gotta
you get that move
I don't get that move it feels like he
committed to the queen side that's the
side he wanted to play on and then
suddenly switched
and it's his idea to play Queen takes A4
on the next move for example if y
continues you mentioned that plan
Lawrence
if white puts the Rook on H3
um maybe Queen takes A4 and again it's
just like the featured chat uh here it's
it's
ethap I'm not pronouncing that right
it's ether does say yeah these players
Never back down and it does feel like
that last move was the slight backing
down by Abdus
I kind of want to play G5 though I've
got to say it feels so tempting to blast
through now
huh
something like this I'm not sure if it
works
take on E5 in that position after F5 uh
and I take C5 for example
and you've got to do some counting to
make sure it works
we'll take C5 for example Bishop takes
E5 white will lose two pieces for a rook
but White's gonna get a lot of Pawns in
the center
huge massive Pawns C7 is attacked
mess is the one I keep coming back Chaos
on the board
you said I have Pinterest after G5 F5
Knight F6 does this move actually exist
here
the evaluation
takes
I'm wondering now like
am I threatening just to go E4
Force you back and then take on E5
looks like that might be a threat
there's also some clearance ideas like
F7 at some point opening up the white
Bishop on B2 along the exact diagonal
yeah as uh as has also been mentioned in
the future chat this does look like a
reverse minority attack if Magnus does
play G5
I'm just playing against the opponent's
strongholds and makes sense that's where
all his pieces are gathered
can you imagine being updated tour of
just kind of chilling playing a move
like Bishop D5 knowing that so many
sacrifices are in the air
I would be freaking out now it just
isn't a move that was on even on my
radar really to be honest in
in the previous position there
um
so I'm very surprised
I'm very surprised and I do think we see
G5 magnets I do think I you know he's
playing principal chess today
he's not shying away from the
complications or the mess
and
yeah why not because yeah and
no no you called it Norris he's just
played it
yeah yeah it doesn't surprise me at all
yeah very very tense position G5 has
been played F5 and okay he doesn't jump
in with the sacrifice that you mentioned
Lawrence what do you think of this one
calm retreat
um
might also be fine
the sacrifice did look tempting
yeah uh screaming out to be played in
Knight F6 blowing open the black king
side
it's uh Knight C3 he wants the bishop
and black center is a bit loose white
King on this diagonal though
um yeah Magnus will want to shut down
that black light squared Bishop as soon
as possible
what do you think Bishop C6 perhaps
maintain the tension yeah um I actually
have I haven't got a good feel for this
position whatsoever there's Bishop C6
Bishop B3 you can play F4 you can there
are a whole bunch of moves here there
was an interesting Super Chat I should
say from none other than Grandmaster
than Feingold who did ours where are the
other big guns Ali Reza where is Wesley
so
where is
um
uh who else is missing
where is fishy why aren't these players
playing I'm I'm very much yeah yeah a
lot of big names
also missing out
I guess it is Christmas uh people do
have other commitments other plans and
uh the tournament was only announced
just over a month ago yeah so it's not
easy uh for everyone to
jump at the opportunity and fly over to
Kazakhstan but we do have most of the
world's top players here and we should
be grateful for that and meanwhile
um talking of the world's strongest
players abdusator of drops his Bishop
back and Magnus did push with E4 so this
is an idea you mentioned breaking the
lights yeah the backlight Square
Bishop's contact with the white king
locking that
Target on E5
and it looks good blacks Knights are
offside they are misplaced at least for
the near future so
kind of strategically I like what Magnus
is doing as well not as direct as what
we wanted to play of course we're just
having fun commentating sacrificing
pieces going for the attack but
um he found a less risky approach
and I takes A4
okay
still feels like it's killing my thread
for black yeah yeah still a mess of
course
how about Knight takes A4 here Lawrence
Bishop takes A4 and just a car move
Queen I mean played it somewhere Queen
C3 Queen B1
and this Knight will be recaptured I
think yeah
and queen C3 yeah and now actually you
have an issue with black here right
because Knight takes E5 is a big threat
so you have to go Knight C6
yeah and G6 by Magnus Carlson
you know what he wants to do
Lawrence he wants to plant his Knight on
G5 nip no matter what
if H6 there's already ideas
oh my God and if hg5 he wants to go Rook
H3 King James at the worst he wins back
the bishop
yeah I mean you could even start with
Queen C4 I gotta move d4 oh oh okay
check Queen H3 give it to me
and Bishop C4 has opened up and Bishop
I didn't even see Bishops before I was
trying to clear the third I love how
you're applauding your own move but it
is worthy of that Applause it's such a
genius move d4 and in those positions
you sense there's something right it's a
mating net caught DeForest
[Music]
we could get this loving life
he's having fun with this attack yeah
he's having a look maybe yeah Knight D4
good move
probably had to play it
probably had to play it
so now what do you do
locking your idea of D4 that clearance
move opening up the white light Square
Bishop the third rank yeah yeah Knight
D4 clever these players they're so good
making me blow with counter blow
now Knight G5 doesn't quite work I think
still a bit still very tempting to just
sacrifice pieces
like Knight G5 Knight takes E2 just
Queen C4 or something like this
but
suddenly it's not so clear that path
towards the black king White's Rook as
well can line up on H3 at some point but
black has threats as well
if you trade off nights in this position
black will gain a few Tempe against the
White Queen and you run out of attacking
ammunition for example Knight takes
Knight the black porn May recapture and
there's no more Knight G5
suddenly Magnus might have overextended
wow what a game this is living up to its
billing for sure what a game
yeah I default great move I've I love
that one from my body store if he needed
to find it otherwise he was just busted
he was done
uh yeah what do you think now Laurence
well I have no idea either
so if I take
let's say e takes
green sea
greenware Queen C1
yeah potentially say I don't know I mean
I don't know
I say Black Friday
yeah nothing going on
it's just bad for what what has no
threats Bishop C6 is coming lining up
against that white King on H1 suddenly
the attack turns
so Knight takes D4 off the cards off the
table
does that mean Magnus no she has five
oh my goodness I mentioned this is like
a semi joke but he's going for it after
not that much calculation Knight takes
E2 he wants to play Just Queen to C4
setting up these types of smothered mate
ideas
we'll show we'll show that if let's say
black played a silly move we would now
play check
check
it's not even uh
yeah not even example we can show after
after Bishop E7 maybe after uh Queen C4
Bishop E7 just to show the smothered
mate
double check and then classic
giving up the queen to smother the black
king beautiful
absolutely beautiful wow Knight G5
Knight takes E2 feels like you should
play If you're trying to test white if
you don't play Knight takes C2 then
White's Bishop simply runs away the
attack continues
wow Magnus just throwing everything
including the kitchen sink at his
opponent
um I think Abdus you have to give up
your queen something like this
literally Knight takes G3 maybe Lawrence
with a check oh yeah yeah sorry
at least hold up White's attack and gain
as much material as possible
I was wondering rookie seven but oh okay
seven I think there's some beautiful
variations here surely Lawrence
um something along the lines of Rook H3
and Bishop takes E5
what material balance do we get there
Rook H3 maybe Rook h39 Checkmate again
okay we have wow
what has happened
it's even more crazy than we thought
Knight takes you just give a check
maybe we could go inside
to check but this check is bad because
you've got Queen takes of seven a
mistake by Magnus because now yes you
win the the piece back but
you know you've got you've won an
exchange here as as Magnus Carlson
but is this enough for a serious
Advantage I'm not sure black has got a
bunch of Pawns
wow what an interesting
what an interesting concept
yeah if we do a quick count now Magnus
he's got a rook for a bishop and pawn so
black only has one Pawn for the exchange
is it enough that's the key question as
you mentioned Lawrence uh it's unclear
that black bishops look potentially very
very strong all of White's pawns are
weak
as you mentioned as well the big
question is whether Magnus could have
gone for more whether he had more
I think he just trusts in his endgame
technique I think he believes in himself
that he can convert this but maybe it
was worth investing in an extra minute
or two to look at those kind of mating
attacks that we were highlighting in the
meantime an exchange of phones what is
going to take now on E5 surely
C7 will be attacked C7 will be attacked
white king is a bit vulnerable but you
can give it some breathing space
can you play this or does this run into
drug test G7
question a very good question
and Black's King still vulnerable you
should be this is nice
and Richie to mate
oh my two is Nate Lawrence
oh my goodness check met by a Checkmate
very rarely see that
wow wow okay so
yeah I mean it goes on in those
positions there's still some calculation
to be done but okay this is on the board
Rook takes G7 wow
missed that variation we just showed
where you can meet the check you can
block a check with a checkmate
whoa I mean I think you just have to
take this Rook Rook G8 is a monster
threat we have to take take and now this
is a threat or this is a threat and if
you go Rook D5
Rook G5 and Lawrence we have a result
abducator didn't even want to fight on
he resigns
magnets
what a game what a game Magnus just uh
very very focused
very informed
and he
takes down
an incredibly important Point against
abdisator of massive massive weight of
Magnus putting him on four out of four
just uh
an absolutely brilliant performance
absolutely brilliant so it's so
instructive from start to finish the
opening the flexibility going for the
attack that G4 moves strategically and
tactically strong and then I mean the
calculation required to finish that game
off we we doubted him we doubted him
going into that end game The Exchange up
but he'd calculated it all and
killer blow at the end with some nice
geometry um yeah put up a strong fight
but uh Magnus was too good
Magnus too good uh
quite incredible
uh where do we go from there everything
else is going to be an anti-class surely
Lawrence well it it may be but another
person on three out of three is is the
ornament forest and excuse me but this
is awful for artemiev
uh after Queen E3
uh move 23
this position just looks toast for
artemia no
I mean if we if we do a quick count
black is already The Exchange down and
about to lose another exchange blacks
remaining Rook is trapped am I
hallucinating what's uh yeah I don't
think so what's that Black Rook doing
no you're noticed by hallucinating at
all it's it's just a goner in fact I
think their current position is not
actually being shown
at the moment so
um
we'll trust we'll trust the bar there
where else do you want to go we've got
irrigation rapport
that has to be fun I'm keeping an eye on
the women's section as well it looks as
though goonina is completely crushing
that's yesterday
maybe we can take a look there we
haven't been there for a while in the
women's section
and uh okay this is board one oh
here we go
um gunina as black as you mentioned
phenomenal rapid player she won one of
the strongest uh rapid tournaments
there's been in the UK in years
a few years back
a bunch of Grandmasters
um okay they called her Valentine
Valentina the Destroyer if I remember
during that tournament but yeah this is
this is just a piece up uh White doesn't
have enough compensation and fully
expect Valentino to be good enough also
this apron being able to march down on
board massively important
the problem with that maybe some holding
chances for white but uh not in the
current position
exactly
and um what do you think some other
candidates uh to look at
in the comment section
not so many that I can see right now so
we'll go back to the main
uh Main Events
um
and
okay this game
go on
the up I was going to say the updated
version of uh Jordan vanfurist against
artemiev it looks like it's changed
considerably but still good for white
um white is two exchanges up two Rooks
against two minor pieces
likes pawns look pretty good on the
e-file but white has too much material
surely unless a black knight lands on G3
yeah Jordan's going to take the win we
could see Magnus Carlson against
bamfords to end the day
uh students against master
I think that's very very very
uh likely actually
okay very very very very lightly
uh
so um
okay
yeah I must say I've never seen artemi
have crushed like this um I'll tell me
if he loses it tends to be honest with
some small detail in a really intricate
position but it looks like start to
finish Jordan just
power play uh just found a way to win
material and never look back
yeah lots of uh informed players
continuing that streak
incredible
incredible level and the consistency
now what about our generic AC he's
struggled against Magnus in the tour
but he is not struggling against raffle
in this position porn up better position
great winning chances surely this is
very good for what
and we we doubted him as well that
opening we mentioned earlier it was so
unfathomable it was uh so irrational
that position with black sacrificing a
pawn attacking the white king look at
the white king now super safe he traded
off all the right pieces Eric icy he's
left yeah as you mentioned a pawn up
better minor piece
how do you defend the H6 Pawn you'd
never ever want to put a rook on h8 to
go passive and defend
if the Rooks come off easy win for white
with the extra Pawn
and yeah Eric icy continuing
um yeah his fantastic year report he's
defended a difficult position already
though so we shouldn't write him off
maybe the Best Bets to just plant a
knight on the E5 Outpost in front of
White's uh isolated Pawn in the middle
and just hope to cling on I think you
just have to pray here
that something goes a bit wrong for Eric
icy
this is definitely a prayer situation
for Ricard
struggling in this position massively
massively struggling
um expect irrigation to actually convert
that so that would mean that Eric AC
van Forest Carlson would be the three
leaders are in haven't spoken much about
him but he's still there and he's better
against feather said is it enough to win
and to press
possibly not but he's gonna try
that much we do know nihal sarin can
play this position on for two centuries
if you so wishes
um yeah this is a dream scenario this is
the ultimate fancy for any grinder who
just wants to sit and massage this small
advantage and torture the opponent and
uh yeah if Rooks come off Lawrence do
you think black can win this good night
against Bad [ __ ] scenario yes yeah
so maybe that's the gothic get the Rooks
off yes I think
I think the Rooks coming off here is
massive
of life
um
how he does that though I don't know do
you
do you think with Rook song
that he still has chances though as
black
it's difficult because white Frick will
always be able to hit some targets like
E6 is slightly tender the H5 Pawn ties
down the black king G7
um I did like that uh that little
feature chat from Japan night a moment
ago
nihal definitely needs to channel his
inner Magnus and uh yeah that being said
as is also mentioned here in the future
chat fedisev he's very very tenacious he
holds these things uh these types of
difficult end games all day long
um I've played plenty of Blitz games
against him and somehow he wriggles out
often he turns it around fully but nihal
is
positioning his pieces on better squares
that black knight now has found a
purpose maybe coming around to D6 with a
check
yeah this one I think we're going to be
here for the next 20 30 minutes so
um maybe we'll check back a bit later
yeah let's let's definitely do that
quick look at the women's section uh no
big results just yet looks as though
humpy is doing well Elena Danielle and
might be better against uh
uh Alexander Christina by the way
uh the bar loves it for daniellin
um
although I don't quite see why
it looks like we've just seen a
handshake just gone through a repetition
of moves Danny Elian not oh realizing
her position was so advantageous maybe
the black light Squad Bishop kind of
come in Via A4 D1 looks like white King
was actually in big trouble but
yeah missed opportunity um I've got to
say danielian she's really underrated
she's really really strong in speed
chess so tactically sharp and uh
apparently yeah we see the players
discussing the game with each other
maybe discussing the final position
about whether black had chances for more
but uh in the end she took the pragmatic
decision took the draw because she was
low on time and uh yeah because danuk
I kind of picked her as one of the
favorites before the event she's just so
good in all facets of the game but uh
yeah this one a lucky Escape
yes you should be considered one of the
favorites after her performance last
year it was uh incredible her and as
well I ever did it phenomenally and I
will say where is a survive
uh uh I know I'm not pronouncing her
name exactly correctly but do we know
why she's not here or have we just
missed her completely which would be
weird I'm scrolling through the
I think she is playing she is here wow
she's just got off to a very slow start
that's why okay
okay
and it would make sense because of
course she's from Kazakhstan so
for her not to play this would be crazy
um
uh a lot of the we mentioned a lot of
the top players having slow starts often
that just means dropping a draw or
dropping a draw or two uh it's not
disastrous it's a long Marathon event uh
both the rapid and the blitz so they'll
be back those higher seeds the cream
always Rises to the top as they say but
uh yeah it's just
a strong packed field no easy points for
anyone
and uh plenty of banana skins along the
way
absolutely Jordan Ram Forest has beaten
our Timmy of just so we know Napoli has
had a very good result
beating Salim with black as has Yu yangy
beating the eccentric Timor Gareth
Fabiano still playing uh his
game
uh we will go back to another game now
and I think we have to go to irrigation
against rap War uh we've got an ending
uh and
with irrigation with white but there's
actually not too much to discuss
I'm surprised they're still playing on
King's hd5 is an extra two pawns and
time to resign and maybe that's what
happened already
I think we did see a report resign those
g h pawns are simply going to pick up uh
each other hold their hands and March
through to promotion
um yeah great result for Eric icy who
continues his hot streak four out of
four now
could we see Eric I see against Carlson
maybe and uh yeah all right
let's go to Fabiano playing against
Rasmus svane
and
this is an interesting one opposite
color Bishop ending
but one where the problem you've got is
hmm
there's multiple causes for black
you can't Advance your apron
and at the moment striking B5 yeah the
moment you backtrack with your king the
white king comes over towards A1 and the
white Bishop will sacrifice itself for
the F Pawn right another theme of the
day it's oh it's the wrong colored Rooks
Pawn likes a pawn promotes on A1 which
does not match the color of Black's
Bishop so I think as soon as carolana
gives away
with his King White's King just runs
Sprints over to A1 and uh yeah it looks
like uh safe A Miracle safe by svana
another strong German player uh
meanwhile we do see grishek analyzing
his game it looks like he had a draw
with the white pieces so he's yeah needs
to pick up the pace if he wants to
contend at the top of the table
yeah that was a draw against Jacob boy
of again another talented Uzbek Grandma
so we can see the playing wall there uh
some uh Spectators in the crowd which is
obviously uh nice to see uh Kazakhstan
uh you know with the Deep chess
tradition
um
has
um you know
some of the top promising Juniors
especially in the women's Chess World
when I think of Kazakhstan I think of
them as a Powerhouse in women's chess
you've got
um
alic for example you've got Bibi Sarah
and various others
uh just incredibly talented uh players
um and but from the male side they
haven't been able to produce a superstar
in a long time David at least not that I
can remember
a Kazakhstan
Superstar do you do you know of any
I mean I know some very strong Grand
Masters but uh it depends on your
definition of Superstar I guess none
have ascended to the very very top of
world chest but that could be a matter
of time I know Kazakhstan are pumping a
lot of money into their younger players
into improving the foundations of the
game in the country and also hosting
events like this can't hurt right this
type of event is going to inspire
generations to come
a lot of the young players I've seen
getting autographs hanging out with
these uh top Grand Masters hopefully
that pushes them
to be even better and meanwhile
svana has just moved his Bishop a bit of
a surprising move I thought the king
wanted to stop the uh a pawn
uh as mentioned in the feature chat here
it's a good question how is this
position not completely lost it's
because it's opposite color Bishops
first of all but it's also maybe we can
show this Lawrence it's also because the
a pawn is the wrong color and I think
now we will see svana move towards that
corner with his King he does so in this
fashion just to stop the black F Pawn
from moving and as soon as A5 happens
maybe we can show this variation again
um then for example Bishop D2
let's say the black king moves the white
king just slides back into A1 and
let's find a convoluted way to win the
white Bishop for the black F Pawn and
this will happen sooner or later
uh maybe to go towards D3
um
yep say eventually
yeah I was gonna go Bishop G5
2
something like this where black
eventually pushes but white can happily
take because this position here
is a theoretical draw the wrong rook's
Pawn for the bishop the bishop has to be
on the same color as the promotion
Square in order for this to be winning
this is no way to win white just stays
in the corner and it's a draw
so uh yeah Savannah is very close from
achieving that all he needs to get all
he needs to do is to get his King into
A1 into the corner and Fabiano will try
and prevent that as long as possible but
it's inevitable now
not sure why uh Swan is refusing to go
to the corner with the white king he's
going up
books in the black king but surely he
knows that technique
of course he does still not going for it
but we will see a repetition and a
handshake it is a draw
and a little discussion thereafter the
game
I'm not sure if Fabi had had any serious
chances there but
perhaps
most games have actually
finished
uh
I can see with it
is still playing
against shimanov
uh we're gonna try and get some coverage
there while svana and Fabiano
uh both discuss
um the shimanov vidit ending is actually
looks particularly
tricky I would take white myself and
here we are we can see both players
shimanov in the pink shirt and visit in
the white shirt
uh visit with the black pieces
and shimanov
had to
give up yeah and
they're gonna agree a draw
um after takes texting we should take C4
uh this is going to be just well there's
nothing to discuss at Bishop and pawn
each you have to give up your Bishop for
the pawn and it'll be a draw so
the right smile there by shimanov
and I believe that is the end of the
round
uh we
yeah it looks like all the games have
finished and what a round it was some
big big important results uh including
Magnus beating abdusatorov a couple of
drawers in each Gary against Duda fair
to save against nihal sarin and actually
in both sections the open and women's uh
it does look like already there are some
clear leaders and it will be a case of
catch up uh for the pack
but uh yeah Lawrence it looks like
they're not letting up the pace uh these
players after four intense rounds of
Rapid chess
absolutely Magnus Carlsen still showing
his determination and grit excuse me
we have
a coughing attack just before the break
van Forest Arjun Magnus Carlson all on
four
we'll be right back when I get some
water see you soon
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from a new person
so I first learned about ill Cafe
through my buddy Aaron he was like Hey
me and a group of fellas meet at this
Cafe downtown on Sundays and we play
chess there it'd be really cool if you
could stop by and hang out with us and
you know just feel the vibe and so I
showed up
and it was a nice bug I was like yo ill
Cafe is pretty ill
hello
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're back where we are rejoining the
action from round four the game's still
ongoing we can see that some uh do tend
to uh go over the normal time uh the
game that we are seeing at the moment
is on board
uh three tanjongji against mamadova
David what are we seeing here
and we're seeing a very long Rook end
game white has an extra Pawn a few
moments ago White had two extra pawns
but one of them has disappeared it is
however an endgame that is technically
winning for white white should win here
Tang Song you should take the full point
but the winning technique is not
necessarily so straightforward first I
think she should bring her Rook back
along the G file as she has done the
black king is now kept in a mating net
step two white has to advance the king
forward I think just step It Forward one
square to f8 uh push to White Pawn to F7
and then you build a bridge it is the
Lucina position okay she's gone for it
in a different way uh this is still
winning I believe and yeah sooner or
later that white Pawn will match forward
and cost black a rook nothing to be done
I do think actually that Black's best
bet a few moves ago would have been to
leave White's H Pawn on the board white
earlier had an H Pawn and she took it
but now the black king is vulnerable to
check mating ideas and
yeah I think with the uh capture of that
white Pawn Black's remaining drawing
chances slipped away and uh yeah all
times all you need to do now is move the
white king
King E8 push that F Pawn
no way to save the game now um there's
various ways to finesse that idea you
don't need to rush she also has one
minute on her clock tangs on you
but uh what do you think Lawrence can
mamodova save this one no I think it's
gone
I don't think you ever saved this not
not really
um because especially because I believe
that white can play any move here
uh and win
um
you know just King E7 looks good enough
King E7
uh King G6 F7
um and if Rook F2
uh oh I have to be careful actually am I
blundering Rook F2 of course oh no I can
Queen what am I talking about yeah
seven rookie six check yeah rookie
rookie sales check
yeah King F5 and then Rook anywhere
along the sixth
foreign yeah but is she about to okay
suddenly there was a very narrow path to
Victory okay uh if we go back to the
current game position she played King f8
but after King G6
suddenly
yeah will we see a turn around suddenly
or a scene oh my Miracles that we've
seen many today uh suddenly after F7
which I think was her plan King F6 would
have maybe turned the tables
threatening Rook h8 mate this must be
what she missed and goodness we catch up
with the current position
is this a draw now Lawrence The Rook is
checking from the side let's catch up
with the game yes oh suddenly I think
White's got it again I don't know why
it's gone
yeah and uh we did miss the last few
moves there but white was about to make
a new Queen it was Unstoppable in the
end I'm not sure she ever let it fully
slip it was still in Practical terms
very difficult uh for black to defend
and that's what happens at the end of a
long day end of a long rapid game
defending is just the hardest thing in
the world
it really is and the top players also
tend to just put Relentless pressure on
you I mean
you know one of the top players of this
entire tournament interestingly in the
women's section it is the Valentina the
Destroyer gunina on four out of four the
only player to have 100 but she is
followed by a pack of hungry wolves on
three and a half mahmad Zada uh who is
on three and a half we've got Elena
Daniel
and Leia garifulina
um all on three and a half loads of
course rounds to go there uh gunai
mamazada somebody I um I got to
commentate on Watch and meet in the
Gibraltar tournament and she's
incredibly strong incredibly strong so
won't surprise me to see good night
making a run for it and in the open
section as we mentioned three players on
uh four out of four hundred percent
Carlson in about forest and Eric AC
we don't know the pairings yet but what
we will do is briefly have a look
at some of those key games let's have a
look we looked at the Magnus Carlson
game let's have a look at the van Forest
game because we kind of missed a lot of
what went on there
uh David we had uh uh yeah this this uh
this slow Italian
and yeah we we actually saw it around
here after C6 thought black was doing
okay but Jordan just said you know what
I'm going to work on those light squares
got a bit more space
control some more squares and that is
the move Lawrence a blender Knight A6 a
retreat we're trying to reroute to C5
but walking into a pin
huge blunder
simple loss of a pawn yeah I'll tell me
I've had to give up even more material
to justify it but could never fight back
yeah and Jordan never really let it go
slowly you know expertly look at this
and now a thousand pieces down and the
rest is uh yeah around here I think we
saw it the rest is history
um
was there any other game that was of
real
uh
let's say uh that had a real effect on
this on the top of the standings not not
that I can see but perhaps what we can
do is we can
I was going to say bring up a Hikaru
Nakamura game
we can take a look at some of the final
positions for example board two Anish
Gary's draw against Duda just to show
what happened
um right we don't need to talk too much
about this one it wasn't the most
exciting battle we left it uh quite
early on when it was balanced after the
opening and he had a small Advantage at
least symbolically with a stronger
Knight but
look at this bunch of exchanges and
Singapore name game extremely blocked no
way to make progress
correct and you meant you mentioned some
others nihal sarin couldn't break
through in the end against uh fedexev
that ended in a draw Nakamura you
mentioned slightly lower down
and uh he's dropped two draws so far I
think Nakamura
yeah no Nakamura is actually they they
put him slowly up here he crushed Basim
I mean
uh I'm very very curious to see we'll
flick through the game uh quickly we had
a king's Indian uh interesting line with
Bishop D3 a bit unusual but uh still
oh sorry I was going to say Hikaru
picked up this idea because Magnus used
it against him in the speed Chess
Championship
has been taking notes and it paid off
there you go
and the classical King's Indian position
where Amin managed to get in the F5
break
but uh apparently encourager said I
don't care and therefore not the best
move apparently you have to go Knight
takes E4 here and then follow up with a
B5 break but this move F4 not so good
because after takes takes it now G4
um black gave up a pawn which is very
thematic to get the square the Cara just
said I don't really care pawns are Pawn
I'm gonna get my king safe and start
attacking your king
attacking your weaknesses
and now he's got a square for the night
to come to and trade some Rooks off the
board expert stuff so far by Hikaru gets
As Nice to the promised land of F5 and
in fact
hmm
already here the position is toast Ramen
because he can't
protect various weaknesses and he's
already born down and after a h8 knight
H4 GH4 Ambush weight four black is just
too much material down can't truly hope
to hold this position
um and the agar actually gives some
material back a very nice idea to just
finally expose uh the final flaws in
Black's position and
very nicely done by Hikaru Nakamura
yeah maybe we can show the checkmates in
the final position just two moves away
uh black resigned because after king d8
queen f8 and queen E8 is Checkmate yeah
really patient stuff really oppressive
by mcmur
indeedy so
hikaru's still up there I mean we're
still way too early remember this is uh
a fifth uh sorry a 13 round tournament
so it's five rounds today for tomorrow
and four the day after
so plenty of Chess only four games down
another nine to go I'm curious what the
parents will be
we don't know them yet
of course we will
take a look when we
want you can see the playing all there
as well here are the standings
uh just uh so it's visual for you guys
three guys at the top Carlson ban Forest
Eric Gacy
then banjo players on three and a half
there's one name there that I am
actually even never heard of I started I
I stand back or zayath
uh know that name
do you David I don't know the guy
I must admit I don't know the name I
think I've seen it before when
researching certain openings uh but I
haven't met him he's an international
master from the host nation from
Kazakhstan he's 24 years old and yeah
he's an I am so he is breaking up uh the
pack there of kind of world-class Grand
Masters and three and a half out of four
is no mean feat it's uh extremely
impressive achievement so far from The
Young player and there will be a lot of
players inspired especially from
Kazakhstan taking place in their home
country they'll be looking for those
upsets looking for those scalps and
um yeah I'm hoping that he can continue
the run but it's gonna be tough he's
going to be facing the real elite in
this next round
yeah but he's he's done it you know as
you said extremely well so far he has
beaten
uh and draken and Shanklin back to back
with the black pieces I mean that's
pretty impressive
uh really excited to see this guy play
well
the players are
slowly coming back I don't believe that
we have the pairings just yet
there we can see MBL and Mase
uh you can see
yeah
no I was gonna say Lords yeah we do see
some of the players coming back but it
is often because they just have
different approaches to the game a lot
of players just like to sit there
meditate beforehand now we see Tabata by
I believe walking towards this board
and um yeah as they wait for the
pairings some players want to lock
themselves away maybe even with a laptop
preparing for their future opponents
some people meditate some people walk
some prefer to go snack up
and um yeah it looks very lonely in the
playing Hall at the moment but
um yeah they'll flood back soon they
will be itching to get the day done
itching to get going in the fifth round
of the day and uh yeah I mean either way
I don't think we'll be left with more
than a maximum of one player maybe two
um on 100 by the end of this round and
it's just for the others keeping intact
keeping as close as possible
uh for example Nakamura who has dropped
two draws he cannot allow any more
points to slip by the end of the day
especially if someone like Magnus keeps
winning
and um we see some local players I
believe just uh in the foreground
maybe waiting for their favorite uh
players to arrive to get some signatures
get some photos
and uh okay now we see you Yang Yi as
well wandering around
waiting ready to start
yeah
um
you
you you David were one that you were
never arriving early to a game you
always preferred to arrive late don't
you
I mean time management has never been my
strong skill uh Lawrence in life and in
chess but uh meanwhile I think the
pairings have finally arrived we see the
players coming okay let's have a look
there's parents up on the screen
and it's Eric I see against Magnus
Carlson on board one dude against Jan uh
Jordan van forest or two janaponishi
against Gary on board three another
stacked lineup uh some huge clashes here
Eric Hanson against Mama jorov I'm
seeing further down
uh wow some huge names in this one who
are you watching out for
well I mean of course the top matches
Eric AC Carlson after magnus's
destruction of Eric AC in 2022 uh in
certain events where you just pummeled
Eric AC is Arjun finally going to get
back some sort of
uh confidence really against Magnus
because it's it's not been you know
finals that have been very close Affairs
they have been one-sided lopsided
iridocy wants to prove that he can hang
with Magnus Carlsen but for whatever
reason at the moment Magnus is a really
tough player for Arjun of course Duda
van Forest should be a very very
interesting game too as should uh the
publishing Geary Yu Yang Yi uh yanky you
I beg upon uh against nihal sarin uh
also interesting I wonder if nihal can
magic a win here with black to put him
right in the mix and then our super dark
horse uruzayev uh playing right against
for the safe that wouldn't be a bad
pairing for him either against veter who
can sometimes be a bit erratic uh
donchenko Nakamura uh this is actually a
bad pairing for Hikaru I tend to feel
um if Alexander wants to be very solid
he can
um he might want a frustrate Hikaru
today Predator MBL MBA will be happy
with that Fabiana White against Shimano
Fabi will be very happy with that
pairing as will Eric actually will think
he's got a chance against Shakura Mama
job a Timmy of mamadov is also a wild
one
let's look at the women's section
we we we we we will have a look at the
women's session very very soon
uh you can see there though a lobby of
the players you can see there at the
front the young boy of volodar merzin uh
might be a name that many of you guys
haven't heard before
extremely talented young Russian player
he's rated like 2600 hasn't got the GM
title yet I don't understand how just
probably hasn't got the title ratified
yet but very very talented uh there with
uh who can I see you can see Ahmed oddly
there you can see uh Boris gelfand in
the back
uh you can see
a whole mix of
different players young and older like
you've got the Uzbek boys
who are obviously have got a very close
Bond very very friendly thing that makes
a big difference also when it comes to
winning tournaments I think having a
good team spirit is actually massive and
they've got that
um
don't really see too many others yet
they're everybody just waiting for the
pairings
waiting to get down to
play
yeah does this look like the ideal
weighting conditions for you Lawrence I
mean it looks like the players are just
herded in and
I mean I guess they're all impatient to
get going it's never ideal when there's
been a delay I think it was caused by
those long games that we witnessed
earlier those long rook and pulling
games there was another queen in game
that delayed the round but uh like you
say all the top players they're sitting
there or standing there sorry with their
coaches with their friends teammates
entering picking each other up putting
them each other in the ideal uh frame of
mind how do you spend your
that time uh between games yeah I do the
same try not to the overly prepare
because I think that especially in a
format like this it doesn't really do
you that much uh there's not much
benefit to over preparing your opponents
can play anything it's rapid so better
just to go in with a good frame of mind
good energy if you're relaxed feel
rested uh good mood so speaking to
friends is often nice
and yeah I would do something similar I
wouldn't lock myself in a in a random
room in that building and and try to
prepare uh that doesn't feel
like an optimal optimal uh way to spend
my time but
what we're going to do is we're going to
go for a break
and we'll be very very quick and in just
a few minutes we're going to be back
with the final round of today round five
of the fide World rapid chess
championships it's going to be explosive
Eric AC Carlson amongst others don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to a live
coverage of the feed a world rapid and
Blitz championships It's the final game
of the rapid for day one uh in the open
section uh we're going to be covering
all the action online strength of course
here with my good buddy David Howe we've
seen uh some fast starts by some of
these superstars
namely Magnus Carlson who just defeated
raining
world record Champion Nadia back after
all your cracking game Magnus clearly
determined this year to show his might
and power not wanting accidents of last
year to repeat themselves so Magnus on a
perfect score
as is this young man here Arjun
irrigation the Indian Superstar who took
the World by storm really in the past
couple of years his accent has been
unbelievable
but he's had tremendous problems playing
against magnets with either color the
score for Magnus in 2022 has been brutal
we're going to keep it this game David
uh
are we gonna get again well it looks
like we've got B4 and
what have we wow
yeah
the jabada London system sorry Lawrence
I got over excited by the uh opening
choice
this is one that you're quite familiar
with if I'm not mistaken
you played on occasion yourself
yeah I've played it a whole bunch Magnus
has also given it a go in a lot of
Bitcoin and you can see Magnus there
it's very annoying when you try an
opening out and then you have to play
against it
um
you know lots of different ideas but you
can't quite decide which system you
should go find Magnus might actually go
for a little thinking so which system he
wants to play here uh it's an opening
that
really got popular thanks to especially
it's uh the theory of the opening has
developed tremendously in the past few
years black is of course fine if he
knows what he's doing but you can get
some very interesting positions
depending on how how much black knows
Magnus played this with white a whole
bunch in some Blitz Games
but I'm curious to see which setup
Magnus is going to go for
mm-hmm and uh it looks like he's pushing
some pawns Magnus you mentioned this
kind of rivalry that's developed between
the two and Magnus having the upper hand
over Eric icy however the last match
that these two played and regardless he
did at least pick up one win so I think
he's got one win against Magnus from
like
10 12 games which is not a great score
necessarily but it did break the mental
block so Eric icy will fill some small
Solace some small Confidence from that
result and yeah the other thing I'll
mentioned about erigasi is in the
opening phase he is so well prepared so
quick especially in lines he can predict
uh analyze I've played him myself in a
few Blitz Games and I've never felt so
under the cush under pressure at an
early stage and while we have the
position up Lawrence for the first time
so we can check back in on what Magnus
has done maybe we can rewind from the
start just to show the viewers this
slightly unorthodox opening Choice from
both
yeah indeed so we get D4 Knight F6 now
of course the main move here is to play
uh two pawns C4 and get a a normal deep
Pawn opening but no the move Knight C3
comes threatening to build the big
sensor with E4 so black replies D5 and
now white puts the bishop on F4 so it
looks like a London system but as many
of you know who play the London system
you don't often put the Knight on C3
early this is why it's called the Jabara
London
um and it's an interesting opening black
can immediately go wrong if he plays uh
the move C5 way too quickly for example
you know just to illustrate one line the
Knight comes out all looks fairly normal
suddenly after the movement ip5 that's
one little trick where you could get
into some trouble so that's why Magnus
played the move Pawn to A6 to cut out
any uh Knight to b5s White NOW played E3
and Magnus Advanced with the move B5 on
the queen side and H4 by irrigation wow
this move might look uh let's say
a bit crazy but it's very much in line
with how you should play this opening
why at first it gets some space for his
bishop and he might use this Pawn to try
and cramp the king side so Magnus puts a
stop to it immediately with H5 and now
Knight F3 comes by Eric AC now there are
two potential outposts for Knight and
Magnus goes E6 but I don't think
irrigation is going to be too unhappy at
all of this Magnus is going to try and
play very quick on the queen side but
white has got spares for his pieces so I
don't see Eric AC being too dissatisfied
here
yeah both sides have reason to be happy
both sides are playing quite quickly at
this early stage
um I'll just mention two things Lawrence
one is that I played Magnus on chess.com
a few days ago a small mini match and he
played the Jabbar London against me so
he had white in that game and he crushed
me in 20 moves of course but um also I
had a conversation with him I think it
was in a lift about four or five years
ago in an elevator and I I had black we
were playing on the same team together
and I was like oh I don't know what to
do against this opening my opponent
plays every time he's mastered the
dribaba London and Magnus was like why
are you worried just play A6 B5 just
push your pawns play C5 next white has
no plan white has no Pawn breaks and it
looks like he's going for that exact
same same strategy now essentially
Magnus is saying yes you can put your
pieces on the active squares the white
Bishop looks great on F4 why tonight's
look great but what next and everybody
see doesn't necessarily have
at least a natural plan um you can find
some convoluted way to maybe push the E
Pawn forward put the white Bishop on D3
put the White Queen on E2
um but Magnus hey there we go and move
from aragosi but Magnus is happy to play
C5 I was gonna say he's just gonna Push
All Blacks pawns forward and what next
for Eric I see we do see the moves
uh occur flying down on the board now
and it does look like a London system
very much so actually looks like this
White Knight on E2 has found a weird way
around uh to this square but everything
else is pretty much Orthodox London
system and Magnus
developing his night the question now is
where are both sides going to Castle
White's King maybe doesn't feel as safe
anymore on the king side after pushing
the White H Pawn and same for its
counterpart Black's King has no Safe
Haven necessarily in the next few moves
we might see a standoff with neither
side willing to commit both sides asking
the other to choose a side for their
King and okay no standoff arag I see
trusting his instincts putting his
Knight on G5 is there a threat Lawrence
in some in some world of taking on
e-sticks yeah just trying to get to that
black king immediately
right now yeah
well okay let's let's test it out um
let's say black played
um
Rook C8
is Knights xc6 move I don't think it is
uh probably not yes you need more pieces
you just don't have
that much uh play but you can certainly
start to build it
um
so
the question is what is the
what is the best way I quite like the
idea of getting this Knight to F4 I mean
maybe
I can just Retreat the bishop and put
this Knight on F4 and then I'm eyeing up
all these squares so that's why Magnus
plays Queen is six
to give some additional protection there
yeah tricky one tricky one an A4 by
irrigation very classical move
very classical move he wants to meet
before with the move A5 an important
submission took in between move uh
fixing some horns
and now if this queen
goes away let's say queen d8 now you can
do all kinds of things having this extra
Pawn here on A5 actually makes a huge
difference Queen A4 is a move Queen one
is a move
Bishop G3 is a move
Bishop C2 is a move
all kinds of moves that exist here lots
of different plans
and I think uh irrigation would be very
happy with that
so I like April with David do you do you
like it as well
I love it laurenson I like just creating
these small little ideas these small
threats
um in the background there it looks like
we have seen a result you Yang Yi and it
looks like an early draw uh in that game
to finish the day for those two but uh
yeah arig I see I just love the fact
that he's planted his Knight on G5 where
it can nearly never ever get kicked away
because there will be tactical
possibilities later and Magnus has felt
obliged to lock up the center which
comes with massive risk long term uh now
black is essentially saying okay I'm
long term gotta push pause but short
term you have chances to attack me and
uh Magnus offering a trade of dark
Square Bishops I I wouldn't rush if I
were irrigating out I would want to
maybe improve the White Queen position
maybe even build to push that E Pawn
forward
but uh yeah again this is what Magnus
once dubbed in an interview anti-young
player chess he's just giving his
opponent five or six options on every
move and like you said just a moment ago
Lawrence white can play Bishop C2 white
can play Queen B1 white can play B4 A5
there's a whole bunch of viable logical
moves but what do you pick and uh if you
start drifting then Magnus will punish
you if you pick the wrong plan Magnus
will punish you
um yeah it's it's interesting
objectively this feels wrong for black
look at that uh Bishop on B7 locked in
behind its Pawn chain and the black king
as well
still undecided about where it's going
to find a home later but
if he can survive Magnus and it's a big
if if he can then I think in 10 15 moves
we might see him start to turn the screw
so everybody needs to keep the pace he's
been playing very quickly very well so
far he also needs to find that
productive plan that's
Beyond me I've got to say I would be
struggling here I would spend five six
minutes finding a move and then realize
I was in time trouble and it would
backfire but
um yeah all right guys see I'm expecting
him actually maybe to castle kingside at
some point because White's King has to
make a decision and you won't be ready
to blow up in the center until your king
is fully safe
you know I think in general though Eric
Gates is going to be very very happy
with this position because his play is
kind of straightforward he knows that a
trade of dark Square Bishops is fine he
can put a knight on F4 he can look at E4
breaks there are lots of ideas very
natural ideas so he doesn't have to
search high and wide for Exquisite plans
I think you've got to be really happy if
you're irrigation here don't you David
yeah I mean I would be happy objectively
with the position but you can have a
fully relaxed uh relax if you're playing
Magnus Carlson especially Magnuson beast
mode and uh okay he does Castle the
white king
plans will include White playing F3 E4
uh maybe trading off the dartsgo Bishops
planting white tonight on the F4 Square
um so that as you mentioned there are
plans very logical plans safe plans but
yeah you will get impatient if nothing
breaks through and uh if Black's
positions somehow stays
stable over the next few turns to be
honest I'm skeptical I really think this
doesn't suit magnus's style that much uh
to kind of kind of sit there and just
wait and hold he wants to have some
long-term advantages and here black
doesn't have too many of them
but yeah we'll see it's still early days
it is but I think this is the first time
that I've seen Arjun really have
just the kind of opening position he
wants against Magnus rather than
something where Magnus is pulling the
strings
I actually think Magnus is just a lot
worse here
I mean Bishop takes D6 Knight F4 Queen
F3
and just put this on the board
you know some kind of plan like this put
the queen on F3 and break with E4 and
he's gone 94 out of what looks to me
like
you know effectively desperation
um
the position is that bad already and now
for example if I play Bishop takes E4
these xe4 I can take on D6 and then I
can play Knight G3
um
you have to go night
F6 I guess
I can play Queen C2 attack it even more
you can go green E5 and now I at least I
can go F3 at the very least
and
this looks this looks bad for Magnus
because you can't get the king safe
another either side of the port
yeah he takes F3 that Lawrence uh sorry
to continue oh sorry but yeah E4 just
plowing forward uh in that line I I love
it every move you're creating a threat
you're gaining time forcing blacks
replies and that's how you build
momentum in a position build the
initiative and uh yeah Queen D5 as you
mentioned then
F3 takes E4 just well yeah power through
Rook takes up through the next move by
white White's pieces are springing into
action black is still stuck with a king
in the middle and uh yeah some bad Pawn
structure bad Bishop
losing a lot of time in the process and
this is just one option available to
Eric I see I wouldn't be surprised if he
actually takes on e4 if we go back to
the game position
um with his Knight
and uh for example Knight takes E4 and
then Knight G3 immediately something
along these lines just allowing a line
Bishop takes F4
yeah I think I'd be quite happy there
with white
um oh okay maybe F5 I must say I thought
I could take on H5 here but black does
have some counters
still G6 well it's complicated
and he didn't do any of that
no he played Knight G3 immediately which
is also interesting because actually
after takes takes
you do lose one of these guys now
uh just rookie one and that e-pawn is
falling for black so what do you want to
do so so Knight F6 oh Knight F6 sorry
rookie one
and you can't yeah
you play F5 that's why it's breaking
through
it's just a position in general just
looks
horrible for Magnus
it's not the first one he's had today
either
but against an opponent like Arjun maybe
just maybe that's going to be more of an
issue because now that Arjun has one
uh that game against Magnus
um
he'll have the confidence that in the
future he'll be able to actually you
know
yeah that he'll be able to beat Magnus
on a more regular basis effectively
and meanwhile Magnus does play a very
quick move dropping the bishop back to
E7
I mean it's such a crazy complicated
position everything's hanging for black
white has a choice of two different
pawns to take the black Pawn on e4 the
black pawn and H5 yet Magnus is still
keeping that speed I'm just not sure
whether he's trying to provoke Eric I
see whether Magnus is taking risks again
to kind of go all out for the win to end
the day on a high or is he just
frustrated his position so bad so he's
trying to hustle on the clock
um it could be either of the two but I I
do feel Magnus needs to kind of knuckle
down and just try and escape this game
survive it ideally with a draw or more
but uh yeah Eric I see I'm so impressed
um
kind of one of the leaders of the engine
generation of course
it's uh yeah just just looking so calm
and composed he's another one with great
body language just so stoic that the
board never breaks this pose never leans
back never slouches
Arjun
I have a feeling he's just gonna take
the E4 Pawn with his uh Knight on G3 and
again post the question to Magnus where
is your compensation
not immediately visible
yeah
totally agree
totally agree looks fantastic
maybe we can check out some of the other
big yes let's do it let's do it uh
we have the other
young man on 100 this time it's yawning
around Forest
who played uh who plays against Duda
this looks like a king's Indian samish
variation with F3
and that famous line with C5 92 Queen A5
interesting line
Rook C1 Bishop p7 both sides refusing to
take on D4 for the moment now back does
uh but
this looks like
I don't know
a pretty poor version
of
a samish to me I don't know about you
David but
this is not the kind of samish I would
like to play as black
yeah maybe it's okay
yeah maybe it's okay yeah
black has to been deprived of his G7
Bishop the beautiful Dart score Bishop
this marocy binds with white you nearly
never have any risk worse comes to worst
you allow black to break out with a pawn
strike and you exchange a bunch of
pieces and you're pretty safe there I
have a feeling Lawrence do just going
for checkmate I have a feeling he wants
oh let's have a look for Knight H6 check
and uh something along these lines
maybe even play H5 at some point give up
some material put the White Queen on the
long diagonal the A1 to h8 diagonal
knowing Duda that's what he he will be
dreaming of right now and uh yeah it's
like waving a red flag to a ball if you
let Duda attack you
throwing these pawns forward I've seen
Duda Checkmate his opponents way too
many times to feel confident in Black's
uh chances here it's also not Jordan's
uh style to defend necessarily so I
think you're right in everything there
it's gone a bit wrong for black but
for now no immediate threats any white
threats do take five or six moves to
build up like Oh look The counterplay
maybe in the meantime by striking out
with B5
yeah that's a typical way isn't it where
black looks accounts Below on the queen
side with B5
a lot to consider here for Jordan but
certainly a bit of pressure exactly the
sort of position
that down just off uh would have wanted
to
get
all right
um
the publishing theory of course we
should have a look at but actually as it
turns out no fireworks here at all Geary
2 well prepared The Universe She also of
course incredibly well prepared we have
a dull Queen and Rook middle game which
will almost certainly
uh and in a peaceful outcome
to won't spend too much time there
yeah it's likely to fizzle out but I
would maybe choosing a publisher just
because white has only one isolated Pawn
on D4 black has two on C6 and A5 and if
you can't Pawn Islands it's always nicer
to have fewer weaknesses than your
opponent but like you say Laura it's
just too little material left
I'd say 90 this one is going to be a
draw which is a decent result for both
uh both players have started the day or
the tournament well
agreed I think both players will be uh
relatively happy
uh with with a draw
um
they're still well in the mix
so
both players definitely will be happy
uh looking at the other games nothing of
major
importance I would say
um let's go back to Magnus because I
think it's just such an interesting
position and concept the move Queen C2
played by Eric AC
uh looking to win a pawn this way and I
see no way to stop that one being won
so
yeah you're right it's almost
indefensible that E4 Plus
yeah the self-control by Eric I see
though to play Quincy too when he could
have grabbed that pawn immediately
very impressive stuff
um yeah anyway black can preserve that
pawn is to for example take on G5 but
you don't want to part with your Bishop
pair I think that's Black's only
conversation when he inevitably
goes down upon maybe it's over the
bishop I'm not even sure how to take
probably with the bishop
um
yeah that that pawn on H5 for black
maybe Magnus is regretting all those
moves ago pushing it to H5 because it's
a clear Target in all of these
variations why tonight was gifted the G5
Outpost
and if black could push his Pawn back to
H6 then he would feel safer he'd feel
much calmer about castling King side
and yeah all of these variations that
pawn is a massive problem
for Magnus meanwhile okay seven minutes
for black six minutes for Eric I see
still looking good for the Indian player
and um
yeah what do you think Lawrence uh
should we stick with this one for a
while or should we check out that one of
the dog
um
yeah I think I think that would be very
interesting
to go and see
on board five
who's in joint second place right now uh
Kazakhstan uh from Kazakhstan he's an IM
he's facing off against fedes
Firebrand
and it's like a crazy position I've got
to say we can jump over I can't quite
locate him at the moment
so let's put this one in the meantime
okay
and uh yeah Magnus needs to come up with
something ingenious
I'm struggling to see it if we go back
to the game position as well instead of
taking on G5 what else for Magnus the
move F5 is beyond
yeah it's beyond ugly you can't even
contemplate a move like that one uh
weakening your king weakening your Pawn
structure
I'd rather give up a pawn than uh and
make those concessions
what else I just can't see a move for
black oh an attractive move
there's always a takes B5 in the air
and yeah black needs a miracle like I
mean Magnus we've mentioned it this has
been the theme of the day Carlson
naponishi Nakamura they've all had
difficult positions at one time or
another but
how do you hold do you head towards a
slightly worse end game where you might
be pulling down but it's holdable do you
Freak come to play go on the bit counter
attack
just don't see him for black I don't see
how you can achieve either of those
things
and uh yeah I I do see in the feature
chat many people supporting Magnus
believing in his chances to be pushing
or to hold at least
that's I've got to admit I'm skeptical
at the moment it will need all of his
uh creativity fight back in this game
Queen C6 meanwhile lining up
what do you think of that one Lawrence
well I mean it doesn't actually protect
the pawn right you can take twice
so take take
and queen takes E4 for example
and
it is a pawn
um yeah
I don't objectively know how yeah go on
oh sorry uh you don't know how to
evaluate or yeah
I guess white is better but I'm not sure
how much better
probably a lot because Rook A1 is coming
and
yeah probably black interlocker
that could take on e4 perhaps try and
win the H4 Pawn then that variation but
tonight 64 the problem is Bishop takes
H4 Knight D6 checkers
a monstrous move uh super strong not
just winning a pawn but Bishop D6 check
is coming Black's king is not safe like
you said Lawrence Rook A1 is an
automatic
yeah yeah I think this is the simple and
safe way to maintain the advantage and
this is most likely what Eric icy should
go for unless you find something even
stronger
um which might require calculation which
might require a few minutes of this
clock
all right
yeah this looks like a fairly
straightforward way
to operate
every guy sees slightly down on the
clock both of them have got about five
minutes left
each Magnus deep in thought in his
normal pose
but you take wipe here all day
every day
yeah we've got a few results
yeah sorry we've got a few results that
have come through so now publishing Gary
no surprise they did a great draw we
already knew about you Yang Yi beating
sarin and The Outsider uritzaif has has
actually lost to FedEx reasonably
quickly
oh goodness this went wrong in a hot in
in a hurry uh it was a new kind of
Milner Barry uh new new variation
uh where white gives up a bunch of
material looks okay at the moment but
fair to say if he just takes all the
pawns trades a few pieces and and white
didn't have a chance goodness that's a
wreck is drug oh my goodness this queen
flying in yeah this is this was always
going to be a catastrophe uh
catastrophic game for i i s stand back
he had a great tournament until now
still can put in a great tournament but
a really very easy game for the save to
put him back in the mix on four and a
half out of five
you know unfortunately it looked like
ursif he was full of adrenaline after
some great results so far today but
um that type of thing can happen if you
play these risky opening sacrificing
pawns going all out in the attack if it
doesn't work
it will backfire um so tough game but
he'll bounce back he'll be stronger for
this experience and meanwhile fedesev
he's going to be riding High he's going
to be one of the leaders heading in to
tomorrow four and a half out of five
great score
so this is some of the result slots yep
absolutely
well we've still got our main game uh
very similar position to what we looked
at just a moment ago Magnus uh and it's
now a pair of queens have come off I
guess a pair of ropes will come off
and uh White's just gonna have an extra
Pawn
and it's going to be one of those where
every guy see either he's going to be
able to
uh uh convert or or not and and Magnus
holds but I think Magnus winning chances
are very slim in this game I would say
but then again he can also magic a lot
of things can manage
um
yeah
um as is mentioned in the feature chat
right now Eric I see is very quick uh he
doesn't really worry about the clock too
much he's got great instincts great
Blitz player but you know I guess Magnus
his conversation does lie in the fact
that black has two Bishops doesn't look
great right now but if the position ever
opens uh those Bishops Will Spring to
life there is also a Target on B2 which
B2 Pawn can be hit by Black's Knight in
some uh in some cases I'm not sure
whether you immediately go for it with a
move like Knight to A4 maybe you save
that one for later that can push on the
queen side with E4 so there are some
small hopes long term I still don't
believe in it as you mentioned Lawrence
I still think black is the one fighting
for his life trying to save the draw but
we've seen Magnus turn around crazy
oppositions than this one and okay he
castles is that a second Pawn sacrifice
right now E4 Pawn hangs so if we take on
H5 I'm pretty sure black will take take
and take and actually losing this E4
Pawn is is massive because suddenly the
D5 Square becomes available for the
Black Knight so I think you have to
prepare it I think you have to go F3
here I mean it feels like the only
legitimate move in the position and now
Magnus is pretty much forced to play the
move G6 uh protecting the pawn
uh and now the technical phase of the
game
begins because
it's not easy for white either to make
progress now
oh wow and Lawrence I loved your F3
movie he didn't go for it he took on H5
what did he do he did take what exactly
curious
I think he has a specific idea in mind
but I'm not sure it's so strong uh in
that variation okay Magnus has Just
Whipped off that Knight on G5 and after
it's recaptured
the E4 Pawn drops does white want to go
Bishop E5
but
I think this is this one all under
control after Bishop takes E4 which
takes E5 maybe we can show this uh black
and just play a move such as Bishop to
G6
and
if white does take on G7 that Knight is
trapped
so I'm not sure whether you can win it
anytime soon but uh Eric icy will have
to take this one into consideration
black can start playing Knight A4 going
for counter play
hey there are some news let's catch up
with the game all right let's catch up
all right so there was a trade of
everything Rook 88 and something very
similar to to what you're suggesting uh
there David uh black wants to trade all
the pieces off
and after Knight takes G7 as you said
Play A Move Like Bishop G6
but actually why can't I take
nurse I think he's going to take with
the bishop in this position and he's
going to go Knight to A4 trying to win
the B2 pawn and uh Magnus wants to
create counter play
uh so for example after Bishop takes A8
if the G7 Pawn is captured Knight A4
immediately white can't hold the queen
side suddenly all three results would be
possible
um yes it's opposite color Bishops but
they'll be an imbalance with Pawn
structure who knows who's even better in
this position anymore
yeah um so very very sneaky by Magnus he
realizes the Rooks were the only things
uh only pieces that could potentially
defend B2 so he swaps them all off and
aragaisy in the current position if we
go back again
he's got to ponder that does he trade
the Rooks off if not and Black's Rook is
coming in
yeah okay two will happen if white moose
his own Rook
yeah I've got to say Magnus he's at
least asking difficult practical
problems yet again he's so unique in
that
um you can never relax you never write
him off he loses a pawn that's never the
end of the story
and um yeah I mean as again as mentioned
in the feature chat here by Anita drink
you remember Magnus winning a drawn end
game I remember hundreds of those cases
uh he seems to do it on a daily basis
Rook takes Rook has been played
and the bishop recaptures
and Knight A4 what do you do against it
you could play a move like Bishop D6
potentially bring it around to A3 but
then white Bishop does a defensive job
defending B2 and
that's never a good sign going passive
against someone of magnus's quality
yeah if the knights come off remember
opposite color Bishops it's guaranteed
to be a draw
is there anything to do now uh Lawrence
is there anything that's the problem I'm
staring at this position and I don't
actually see a constructive way forward
here for white
mm-hmm
I really don't I think this has been
brilliant about Magnus to get out of the
jam
no way to continue risk-free if you want
to win you will have to take some
significant risks if you're iridocious
for example let's see one minute
one minute left as well Magnus with a
nice Chunk Up on the clock and he does
go Bishop E6 looking to meet Knight A4
Which Way three
and this is a sensible move
sensible but will it be enough to win
feels unlikely enough to win
probably not enough to and I don't think
Magnus is in serious danger anymore
um
and I think he'll be very happy with the
draw from this game because he was in
serious trouble at some point
um
so I think yeah I think then you have to
be happy with the draw
yeah Magnus will just play a move such
as Bishop E4 activate uh reactivate that
bishop and uh yeah no matter where white
eventually recentralizes his Knight to
the threat of a knight exchange should
guarantee Magnus that half point
I still see a lot in the future chat a
lot of comments supporting Magnus
thinking he can maybe grind out a win
from this position but remember he is a
pawn down
I think as you mentioned Lawrence a draw
will be a very very good result in this
game especially given the course of how
things have developed
and okay the black Bishop will just move
to a square such as C2 now Black's
Knight will plan itself on D5 if
anything it's a fortress
uh opposite color Bishop end game
I think we will see that handshake
before too long to be honest
Eric I see low on the clock
will he fight on
I don't think that's the uh I think if
the knights come off the answer is no
it's been a long day they both have
maximum score of course it's not really
any risk but yeah if the
if the knights are exchanged here it's
and he's got you know under a minute
you might not want to risk it now let's
see
okay what if it looks like he's kept the
knights on he's played his Knight to H5
I believe
um there we go we saw it on the camera
the board confirms it this looks like an
odd Square
Black's Bishop can drop back to attack
this Knight Black's King can start
getting ambitious coming forward
yes there's still no risk for white
really you can always drop back and
exchange those nights off later but
Eric I see at least he's showing
psychologically whose boss he's saying
to Magnus I'm not scared I'm gonna try
at least to beat you
but that means a lot as well I mean
because a lot of players would just swap
nights and say it's a Magnus and draw
but every case he understands he's on a
journey now he's gonna be playing Magnus
for many years to come and he wants to
show magnets that he's not afraid so
this is actually a very important move
yeah I agree uh this is going to be an
enduring rivalry and he's never been
afraid of Regice but it's nice to
reiterate that to your opponents and
Lawrence maybe while this game yeah well
I'd hesitate to use the phrase fizzle
out but while it Fizzles out uh let's
check in on some of the other battles
let's go to Jan uh Kristoff Duda against
uh you're a man forest and wow this
position here
looks good for white to my eyes I mean
we're trying to win this B port and then
just have two past Pawns
how am I supposed to be worse here
uh
with white
the bar is slap bang in the middle so
the computer is not that impressed by
White's position here but I think any
human player would just see this and
think goodness this is yucky for black
with B5 so weak
um yeah you're you're right first
instincts does say it's yucky it does
look difficult for black to defend maybe
black can just give a check on C3 or
blacks Rook could potentially land on C2
uh White pawns are very far Advanced on
the king side so they're potentially
weak as well
but I didn't see what to do after Rook
C3 checking F2
Rosie two maybe now just to keep the
harassment of the white king
T3
oops exit two
mm-hmm
you want to take on B5 I guess yeah I
have I guess I have to
yeah and even if I exchange Bishops
Black's night could always land on the
eight that one looked
um holdable for black but we did see
something else and
okay wow black did give up the B Pawn
this is very good
using the PIN
he's a clever guy Jordan van Forrest
he's very he always solves his problems
with tactics players I mean they vary
across the spectrum of uh tactical
versus strategic and I've never seen him
take the kind of boring solution he's
always living life on the edge always
trying to solve things with pins double
attacks tricks and yeah it looks like
white can't hold his bishop and if the
bishop is captured
we see a Grimace as well from Young
Christian of doula if the white Bishop
is captured
your winning chances are fizzling uh
disappearing white tonight actually
looks quite poorly placed unless you can
break through with the white Rook to the
eighth Rank and get some mating attacks
then uh yeah that white knight might
regret planting itself on the edge of
the board Duda meanwhile pushes forward
we should mention the clocks dude is
down at 25 seconds
Jordan has over two minutes
um what would you play here Lawrence
would you just take that Bishop Whip It
Off yeah I think so
but F6 brilliant you're not rushing
trying to liquidate all the pawns here
uh
and if he does that
he's going to be rocking and rolling
because
there's just not going to be enough
material left I love F6 I think this is
a great move
very little time also for Jan just off
here
yeah and uh Judah really wanted to force
the issue now he's as you say played
Rook C4 he's forced this exchange whites
Rook will land on the seventh rank maybe
some targets there uh black has to be
slightly wary of Czech mating ideas if
the black Bishop didn't stand on D7 then
Rook C8 check would immediately uh
create a checkmating pattern so that
Bishop is attacked I think Jordan wants
to defend that Bishop with his King
is that the idea you don't really want
to retreat with this bishop get pinned
later on
I guess he could recruit
but the whites uh yeah White's B Pawn is
about to drop so Jordan does defend that
Bishop with his King
Duda 20 seconds pawns are dropping he
needs to go into defensive mode he needs
to backtrack reverse gear
save this game
just like with Magnus sometimes you've
got to do what you got to do you've got
to play the position into the position
demands that white just tries to make a
draw
that's he's going for it creating a
threat of Rook A8 check that would be
devastating to the black king hmm
but Jordan will grab a pawn first Rook
takes B3 comes with check
I think black's King should be safe
enough
Mercedes V3 King F4
worst comes to the worst at some point
you do play a moves such as E5 check I
don't think you want to rush that
necessarily but Rook C3 is another move
just to be able to retreat The Rook okay
he Retreats The Rook immediately
now can White's night at some point
find its way back into the game it needs
to
bring it in now maybe if I maybe via G8
ef6 Knight G8 is that a move
why not Lawrence
yeah
you know he's gonna play that as well
right I mean that's such a move
of course he has
uh now it's
Black's turn to play for the draw yeah
just try and find a draw yeah so so King
F7 I think is false because Knight takes
is swimming Knight takes of six King
takes F6 Rook takes D7 but I think that
this even this is probably a draw
yeah
everything is discerned yeah
so and we're headed straight down that
line Lawrence you're right yeah
exactly so what I'll do just face as
well do the grimacing he knows that
maybe he had chances in the middle game
but this end game is going to end in a
draw
let's see this
Rook D6 qv7 right
yeah and not much to
say or do
Rook H6 will be played and
oh well
E5 hours before check yeah
yeah getting hoovered off the board yeah
I think Jordan now you see him lean back
he knows yeah there's a draw
nothing to be done
yeah
waiting for the handshake
He Is We Are and then we'll head back to
the other action
in the meantime has beaten Tabata by a
big win for Alexander Christchurch
shankland on a bad run reform lost to
sargassian Mama jarov beat Eric Hansen
as well so some of the fan favorites
there
uh
lost their way
Duda trying in vain
to
uh to do something but of course only a
draw is a reasonable result
in this position
in the background there Lawrence we saw
Eric icy walk away so shall we wrap up
how that game finished yeah actually as
Magnus
it did end up in a draw uh opposite
color Bishop position
so the last time we looked it was around
a little bit here
uh
yeah so G4 and F5 great move by Madness
uh forcing a number of Trades and yeah
once you have the double G pawns
opposite color Bishops the Knight not
able to get back there's nothing to do
in fact once the Knight does come back
and the Knights come off there's nothing
to discuss it's opposite color Bishops
very standard win Magnus wins are pawn
it doesn't matter
and when the bishop comes away for a
draw was agreed because
it's just a draw it's just nothing to do
in this position so first points dropped
for
Arjun and
Magnus
uh first points drop for Jordan Ram
Forest as well of course who was on
four out of four
and that means with all of these draws
that we now have a bunch of players
on four and a half out of five
uh namely Carlson fedes of erigasi and
Van Forest there are still some games
going on let's go to Fabiano caruana
who is playing
against uh
yeah let's give me a second here and
I'll bring that game up
and we can see them on the camera now
it's looking very tense Shimano very
very low on the clock
and uh if we do a quick count we see
that black has an extra Pawn White's
Bishop also stuck on the edge on A7
if we head into another rook and Pauline
game we could well see a draw I think
Fabi wants more though and okay he pins
that black knight that black knight is
pinned always to Sunday pin twice now
along the diagonal uh along the file and
uh White's King is rushing towards
Black's weak King side Pawns Lawrence
predictions here it's still three
results right the same results King F4 I
mean a lot can happen here
um I think I'll go with Fabi because I
think this is objectively tougher to
play with black over the board
uh even though the bar is slap bang in
the middle
of the page
doesn't look intuitive at all to me I
get very concerned if F6 and H6 just
disappears so he's gonna go King F5 here
100
um and it was it was nice to see Magnus
after finishing his game still watching
uh he's such a student of Chess such a
fan he's uh I think checking out the
progress of his fellow Countryman Ariane
tari but uh yeah this if we go back to
the Fabi game uh yeah it's really
heating up like deep Pawn pushing
do you give a couple of checks do you
get greedy with white do you grab the F6
Pawn do you ignore the black F6 pawn and
maybe go towards a Black's H Pawn
because white h51 is potentially the
winner there we go Fabi drops his King
into G6
I like it too and that that white H Pawn
I would be terrified Black's pieces are
so far away from preventing it
and okay shimanos gambling everything on
the advance of his D Pawn D2 coming next
I hope it doesn't care well Abby wraps
and
I have that white Rook that white Bishop
they tend to combine quite well if
rabbit Bishop out but now there's a
threat black Rook wants to take that
white Bishop just distracting away white
rook and A1
okay so Fabio is held to trade off
King G7 will be played
but then if King 63 is a draw well if
King C3 is a draw there's no no race but
they've only got 20 seconds is very
difficult to actually calculate
how how this is all working out
uh
process of elimination though is black
you don't have many other logical moves
you have to support your king uh your
Pawn with your king so if you can plays
King D3 I don't think that was the
difference there with King D3 King C3
um Black's next move could well be Rook
B4 coming afterwards
that's a great move David
yeah
black just needs to give up his Rook for
Whites Whites two remaining pawns and
then it's a draw the Deep Pawn will cost
White's Rook it's life
and there we go he finds it Shimano for
it
we're headed towards a drawing this one
as we see two of the youngest players in
the tournament on the camera
yeah yeah
before was was was really good enough to
hold the draw
Rook G1
wow
fabi's saying okay you can take on G4
but this is very interesting because
black can take on G4 check
and make a queen but Fabi is basically
just saying I never lose this position
anyway and I might try and queen my Pawn
Bobby actually trying to play for the
win here and it looks like we've got
that
position wow after Rook G6
which is which is
huge risks yeah massive risks and again
this is why the top players are the top
players that's why Fabi has been in the
top bracket of World Chess for so long
because he knows what is acceptable risk
and what is too much risk and uh I think
he's right I think White's H1 is strong
enough that white is never really in
trouble so why not test the opponent
and there we go White's Pawn is about to
be one square away from promotion
should be a draw we should mention
Black's Queen can give checks along the
diagonal checks from afar and there'll
be a whole bunch of checks White's King
will not be able to hide but he's
testing the opponent and
the opponent here shimanov in this case
has 15 seconds
it would be so easy for black to blunder
and allow White's Pawn to run through
on the other hand now with Queen G1 it's
clear that black has got all of this
scope with this queen to come to the
seventh here so you're never really
going to be struggling for checks like
Queen A7 check here King G6 Queen G1
check is just fine uh
or queen H1 this also has to be good
enough
[Music]
I respect Fabi for asking the question
though first uh this thing is opponent
one move more two moves more making him
uh be accurate with the checks it will
be a draw most likely but uh it won't be
for lack of trying on fabi's part
and uh is that something you feel
missing from his CV that he wants to
correct uh Fabiano
he would love to he would love to
um
no question about it
uh
it's an important tournament for for all
of these guys no no it's it's not just
some random rapid tournaments the World
Championships they hold it in very high
regard
so uh
and the players are very stubborn I
think this is the third time they've
reached this position but they haven't
agreed the draw yet and okay finally the
handshake
fighting game
yeah uh very very nice game fighting
game by both of these players who else
have we got to
look at
uh
we can go down to
see here
now we've just seen uh followed on
Merchant another player you highlighted
earlier in that packed crowd he has just
beaten with it in the last few seconds
oh wow okay it's Vincent kaimer has just
made a draw with Daniel duboff in the
last few moments
yeah I'm wondering okay are there any
the games still going it doesn't look
like it
um not the top games we're down to sort
of board 43
uh and so on if we're gonna look at
games we've got a game Marty rosian
who's not had an easy time
um slightly better
uh against uh Sergey Udin
um not particularly interesting Petrov
rachmanov is a draw tomashevsky
uh after winning his first suit lost to
Carlson lost to murder in merzin is now
beating nestorov
not a particularly exciting position and
that's about it oh
Countryman Amit Garcia drew the first
round won the second lost his last three
having an absolute
nightmare surprise David that we there
are absolutely no English players really
except amid where is Luke where is going
is it because it clashes with Christmas
that makes it impossible what's that it
wants the deal there David
uh I wish I knew Lawrence uh I'm here
busy with you uh yeah it's a pleasure to
commentate of course I've played in the
world wrapping up Blitz myself but
England don't have a strong tradition uh
in terms of participation in this event
I think it is Christmas I think it's a
cultural thing
um England have a lot of strong players
of course but uh Kazakhstan is far away
and it is that special time of year uh
meanwhile we do see a few games still
going so uh maybe we can get it up on
the board Lawrence this is aravind well
I believe playing with white
um
uh yeah we've got aravind here playing
with white we'll quickly look at this
and I think after this one we'll
probably call it a day
uh because all of the major games are
are pretty much done
uh this particularly
this particular game is
what this could go on forever couldn't
it actually theoretically
although that said maybe there's just no
way to make progress and Min Lee playing
Black of course legendary Blitz and
Rapid player especially online
uh that this might just be a fortress of
sorts because
um
there's not actually a way to make
progress here
yeah you're right
I think his username on chess.com is a
wonderful time he's uh that's right he
beaten me countless times uh on
chess.com but he is the one fighting for
the draw here as black
I think we've seen a slightly different
move Bishop C5 was not played on the
board and I think that's a transmission
error that Bishop is on C5 now as we see
in front of us but it's defended by
white rook and like you say Lawrence
it's a fortress because as soon as White
Rock and Bishop tried to line up against
that H6 Pawn like we'll start giving
some annoying checks to the white king
so
um yeah it's destined to be a draw of
this game
and uh I will try and go to
try and go to a game where the moves are
correct looks like this one for example
the tomaszewsky game
is uh one of them but this is not very
interesting it's just a full extra piece
with the past
apron
um and tomaszewsky's just gonna March
this Pawn down the board
so I'm just gonna find a
Queen C8 Queen takes C3 is it's probably
good enough
also worth noting that's the correct
queening Square
for the
uh
the bishop
yep you're completely right without
white tape on it is a draw but uh yeah
unfortunately for black there's never
going to be a Perpetual check when you
have so many pieces to Shield the white
king
so this is just a matter of time
and uh yeah I agree with the
um
the featured chat here it's nice to see
wonderful time all suited up for the
occasion I expect great things of him
especially in the blitz event I think
he's gonna cause some big surprises
and yeah
he's he's very very strong
um
I will try to
just get the right game up here as well
because this is
actually not quite the right game
um as we see on the camera uh it does
look like Min is uh very very confident
about his chances to hold nothing much
has changed since we uh last left the
position uh maybe we can right
just focus on the players because oh
there we go he's calling the Arbiter
he's claiming a draw now he thinks it's
been 50 moves since the last Pawn push
or capture was made
okay no he's just alerting the Arbiter
uh to start counting
he's just giving some tracks
dead draw here white will block the
checks but now White's Bishop is
immobilized and yeah unfortunately we
don't have the right uh transmission
here off the moves but nothing much has
changed
it's just the status quo rook in three
pawns against bishop and pawn no way
we'll even see that beloved end game
Lawrence Rick and Bishop versus Rook
that would be a fitting way to end the
day
it would be but it's it's just not
happening uh
there's just no way that Min Lee is
uh is going to allow that
yeah let's just sit keep an eye our eye
on the big screen and
yeah let's just hold tight ready for
that handshake in a matter of moments
and I think that will end the action for
day one of the tournament okay Rook D3 a
very nice move non-committal attacking
whites Bishop
our event I like the fact that white is
trying to press for a win you should
always play as soon as as long as
there's uh even the slightest chance but
in such a skilled Defender uh in a
position where the opponent has a
fortress
and he will call time on the game soon
now what do you make of today's action
Lawrence has it lived up to yeah I think
you looked for
I was going to ask you the same thing
but the answer is pretty much
yes uh we've had our ups and downs we
have had some uh some inspiring
performances uh I would say that Jordan
has particularly impressed me uh Magnus
of course Magnus previously didn't ever
start a world rapid with three out of
three just so you know this was the
first time he ever started a world rack
with three out three which is shocking
to think about it
um so Magnus getting off to a good start
is very nice Eric Gacy uh you know
looked like he's he's he's really up for
it
um some of the other players as well I
mean I've just had to have lost to
Carlson but he beats Sun up
I was trying to stay in it there's a
whole bunch plays on four out of five uh
meaning that uh you know there's you
know it's going to be very very classic
car Nakamura perhaps we're talking about
disappointing results I said that
donchenko was going to be a pretty poor
pairing for for Hikaru if donchenko
didn't want to risk and donchenko took
half a point off Hikaru so Hikaru
dropping one and a half points today as
did Alexander grishop as did Rickard
Rapport dubov and Fabiano so a lot of
the top players there on three and a
half and then of course anybody on three
out of five or less is already way
behind the pace
had a horrible day I got on Two and a
Half
out of five so
um
yeah it's uh it's been a it's been a
tough one
thing I will say is that it's it's not
about I know it's a cliche but it's not
about how you start it's about how you
finish and a lot of these players who
are lingering around 50 percent or
around
plus one so that means three out of five
points or three and a half out of five
all it takes is one good day one winning
streak and they're up there again
um I remember last year when I played I
was languishing around 50 I won my last
three games in a row and I got a prize
so
um it's yeah it's about uh just kind of
waiting for your moments taking those
chances when they come and it's gonna be
frustrating for Nakamura for all his
fans out there potentially but
one good day tomorrow and he's right
back up there Magnus will drop more
points the others will drop more points
it's inevitable in such a strong field
and uh yeah I agree Lawrence today's
been fantastic it's so much action
especially that uh Carson against Abdus
tour of game that's the Highlight for me
but but uh I'm hoping that this vein
continues very few short draws very few
boring games gotta say
yeah it's one of the highlights of of
the world rapid and Blitz is you know
that uh
boring drawers don't tend to happen very
often at all get a lot of Fighting Chess
a lot of the interesting chess new
openings whatnot
um
and yeah we can see here aravind against
windley
I mean being able to draw this in his
sleep basically rookies
okay five whatever
thinly insisting on the draw aravind
saying I want to play on thank you
but uh no threats anywhere
this is a strange Fortress because
you've got a bishop and porn against
three pawns but there's just nothing you
can do you've got no leverage against
the pawns and mainly
playing any move basically saying I can
draw this position with any move aravind
of course getting that 10 seconds bonus
per move meaning the game can continue
but probably there's been a threefold
repetition somewhere already
okay five
mainly very very bored with the
situation
um now we we can understand his
frustration uh it's been a long day for
the players for viewers for uh everyone
involved but uh yeah it's guaranteed to
end any moment now and maybe we should
start wrapping up Lawrence because I
think we will see the draw I think we'll
see aravind uh admit that he's not
getting anywhere
and uh yeah maybe we can talk about the
leaders just uh those scores one last
time
yep we can do that
um so
in the
uh in the main event with uh the the
open tournament Magnus Carlson Vladimir
fit of Sev our generic AC Jordan van
Forest the guys on four and a half bunch
of guys on four and in the women's rapid
only one lady on four out of four and
that is Valentina the Destroyer gunina
having a great tournament when she's
informed she can be unstoppable but
she's closely followed by a group of
very talented players on three and a
half tanjong Yi Leia uh Gary frullina
pumping Elena daniellan and hunai
mamatsada
so that is also tightly contested very
difficult to call either way
um so far in terms of favorites but
certainly you know if you pick Magnus to
be top of day one you're in good stead
plenty of chest though coming
tomorrow I think that game did that game
finish or no they are
still playing it out and
just nothing to do in that aravind
versus Moon game uh we are going to
have uh I think the full standings
remember we're back the same tomorrow as
well that's 10 o'clock Central European
Time
one o'clock Civic time all the games are
starting at this hour except for the
last end of lids in order to be able to
incorporate the closing
ceremony
um
yeah on that note Lawrence yes uh maybe
yeah maybe it's time to allow our
viewers to go and celebrate Christmas
with their families indeed indeed uh go
and have a great Boxing Day Christmas
whatever you're celebrating it's been an
absolute pleasure apologies for the
Husky voices you could probably tell I'm
a bit under the weather today but I will
get a good night's sleeping tomorrow
I'll be back with David Howe to go
through day two of the world rapid
championships it's been an absolute
pleasure for myself David and the rest
of the team see you tomorrow same time
same place is Magnus gonna continue in
his good
Lane of form we'll soon see you tomorrow
bye everyone
[Music]
foreign
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best
your first diploma
your first job in a big company
edible emotions from the first date the
first expensive things you bought when
you got your first paycheck and your
first Investments with freedom broker
Freedom broker look at your favorite
brands from A New Perspective
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign